the public order emergency commission is
now in session the commissions
good morning bonjour
we're going to start the day a little
differently today rather than have one
of the
Convoy
or protester Witnesses we're going to
have a start with a commission Council
presentation yes good morning Mr
commissioner it's Daniel Shepherd for
the commission if Mr clerk can bring up
the PowerPoint presentation
Mr commissioner today the commission is
presenting its next overview report
dealing with fundraising in support of
protesters
next slide please
calm
or705 describes the major fundraising
activities that took place to provide
money to support protesters in Ottawa
this overview report describes a variety
of entities that were involved in this
process including crowdfunding platforms
financial institutions payment
processors as well as cryptocurrencies
the report provides a narrative of
meetings and decision making that took
place with respect to how these
fundraisers would be organized
constructed
and how money would be distributed
and it provides information available to
the commission about the ultimate
sources and disposition of approximately
24 million dollars in donations
next slide
before getting into the results of the
investigation a few words about the
process that the commission used
it began by reviewing information
provided by the parties to the
proceeding however a great deal of the
information necessary to complete this
investigation was not enhanced at the
parties
the commission using its powers of
summons as well as negotiations obtained
additional documents from six
non-parties to this proceeding as well
as engaging in an open source
investigation for further information
commission Council also interviewed 10
Witnesses Who provided statements that
then were used to complete this report
next slide please
there were certainly a number of
fundraisers that were in play during the
Ottawa protests
this overview report focuses however on
four main sources of funding
the give the GoFundMe and email money
transfer campaigns associated with the
freedom Convoy
the adopted trucker
crowdfunding and email money transfer
campaign
the second Freedom Convoy fundraiser
hosted on the give send go platform
and a subset of cryptocurrency campaigns
that raised virtual currencies in
support of protesters
next slide
this represents the results of the
investigation
each line depicts a different source of
funds and tracks how those funds were
distributed and how they were dealt with
at various points by a number of
different intermediaries
thickness of each line represents the
amount of funding in question
I'll return to this slide towards the
end of my presentation to review exactly
what the commission learned about the
sources and final destinations of funds
next slide please
before turning to that however it's
useful to review some of the individuals
and entities that played significant
roles in the fundraising associated with
the freedom Convoy
some of those individuals include Tamara
Leach who was the creator of the
original GoFundMe and email money
transfer campaigns for the freedom
Convoy
Chris Guerra the organizer of the adopt
a trucker campaign and its Associated
fundraisers
Chad Eros an accountant Who provided
advice to the freedom Convoy organizers
created the Convoy Corporation and
played a significant role in the
creation of the give send go campaign
and Jacob Wells the co-founder of give
Sango who's also involved in the move of
the freedom Convoy crowdfunding campaign
to his platform
next slide please
there are also a number of companies
that were involved in the various forms
of fundraising
you have already heard me refer to
GoFundMe and give sent go which are two
crowdfunding platforms that take in
donations in support of costs
they're also Canadian financial
institutions that had important roles
such as the Toronto Dominion Bank and
the Royal Bank of Canada these were two
financial institutions that received
some of the funds
and finally payment processors like
stripe and its Canadian subsidiary
stripe payment Canada Limited played an
important role in the background to
these fundraisers as I will discuss
later in my presentation and is set out
in more detail in the overview report
next slide please
one thing that will become apparent As
One reviews the overview report is that
frequently there were events that were
taking place in parallel
it is not a strictly linear story that
can be told but rather one has to
understand that different actors were
engaged in different forms of
fundraising contact conduct at the same
time
the first part of the story that the
overview report details has to do with
the period January 14 to February 2nd of
2022 associated with the creation of the
freedom Convoy GoFundMe campaign and its
Associated e-transfer campaign
next slide please
this Story begins with Tamara Leach and
the creation of a crowdfunding campaign
on the GoFundMe platform on January 14th
of 2022.
at the same time we're rather four days
later miss Leach also made a post to
Facebook that put forward an email
address that solicited direct email
money transfer donations in support of
the freedom Convoy
both the gifts and go campaign and the
email money transfer campaign were
associated with a bank account at the
Toronto Dominion Bank in Miss Leach's
name
and both campaigns began to receive
funds on the days that they were created
next slide please
in its interview with commission Council
representatives from GoFundMe indicated
that they became aware of the
crowdfunding campaign on their platform
within hours of its creation
this was because it was flagged through
its algorithms due to the very high rate
of donations that were made very early
in its creation
this flagging caused individuals within
GoFundMe to review the campaign
and relatively early on those
individuals began to be concerned about
the ability of this fundraiser to comply
with the GoFundMe terms of service
in particular the concern related to the
GoFundMe terms related to
campaigns Distributing money in
accordance with their description
when an individual creates a
crowdfunding campaign they have to
describe what it is that they're going
to do with the money that's raised
GoFundMe requires people who organize
campaigns on their platform to actually
distribute money in accordance with what
they tell the public they will do with
it
in the case of the freedom Convoy
fundraiser the description said that it
would do certain things with the money
such as we are asking for donations to
help with the costs of fuel food and
lodgings
funds will be spent to help cover help
cover the costs of fuel for our truckers
first and foremost
will be used to assist with food if
needed
and contribute to shelter if needed
any leftover donations will be donated
to a credible veterans organization
which will be chosen by the donors
GoFundMe reported that it had concerns
with these statements they indicated
that for example they were uncertain how
it would be possible for what was now
thousands of donors to all agree on a
credible veterans organization that
could receive leftover funds
so these initial concerns they tasked
what they called their vit team to reach
out to miss Leach
this is a group of GoFundMe employees
who are responsible for dealing with
high-profile fundraisers and they
reached out to miss Leach starting on
January 16th of 2022 to discuss the
fundraiser and how the funds might be
spent
next slide please
these communications continued between
the 16th and January 27th initially with
Miss Leach but very quickly turned over
to a group of other individuals who are
working with her to manage the campaign
and to deal with GoFundMe
over the course of this period GoFundMe
Representatives post questions and
received answers
and by January 27th they had reached the
part where they felt comfortable
releasing at least some of the money
that had been raised up until this point
donations remained in the control of
GoFundMe
on January 27th in order to formalize
the assurances that Miss Leach had and
her Associates had provided GoFundMe
they provided something that they refer
to as the attestation letter
the attestation letter was a document
that they asked Miss Leach to sign that
set out a number of obligations on her
part that she would have to agree to in
exchange for access to the first one
million dollars of funds
this included pledges that she would act
as a fiduciary for the beneficiaries of
a fundraiser that is to say the truckers
involved in the Ottawa protests
that you would deliver funds in a manner
that was consistent with what she had
set out and the fundraiser itself
a series of accountability mechanisms
such as requiring truckers to sign
registration forms and to provide
receipts in order to receive
reimbursement and to make reimbursements
through email money transfers to create
a form of a digital paper trail that
could be tracked
finally there is requirement for the
group of advisors that had surrounded
her on these matters to form a formal
finance committee that would be involved
in overseeing the distribution of funds
Miss Leach signed the attestation letter
on January 27th and returned it to
GoFundMe
next slide
this point that GoFundMe decided to
release one million dollars Canadian to
miss leeches bank account
however
the money did not actually get
transmitted on January 27th and this led
to some confusion amongst various actors
as the commission discovered while
GoFundMe had reached the decision to
release the funds on January 27th it
wasn't until February 1st that an actual
trans uh transaction was initiated
in the time between January 27th and
February 1st Chad Eros the accountant
who by this point had been brought in by
the organizers to assist them in their
dealing with GoFundMe began to express
concerns about the idea that funds would
be sent directly to Ms Leach's personal
bank account
in his view it would be more appropriate
for there to be a non-profit corporation
that would receive donated funds and
would manage their distribution
to that end on January 30th again after
the money was agreed to be released but
before any release of funds took place
Mr Eros Incorporated the freedom 2022
Human Rights and Freedoms non-profit
Corporation
which is referred to in the overview
report as the Convoy Corporation
as I've mentioned February 1st was the
date in which the actual fund transfer
from GoFundMe was initiated
records obtained from Toronto Dominion
Bank indicate that on that date Chris
Barber was added as a second signatory
to misleach's account that was receiving
the finals
records also showed that a second
account at TD Bank was opened jointly
between Miss Leach and Mr Barber on that
date
the overview report refers to these as
the first and the second TD accounts
respectively
February 2nd in the early morning hours
was when the 1 million dollars was in
fact deposited into the first TD account
however for reasons that I'm going to
get into later in my presentation very
little of that money was ever accessed
and on February 3rd TD Bank itself
placed holes on both the first and the
second TD account
next slide please
for continuing the story of the GoFundMe
fundraiser I'm going to speak a little
bit about a second fundraiser that was
taking place during the same period of
time
the adopt a trucker fundraiser on the
give sent go platform
next slide please
Guerra articulated the concept of adopt
a trucker on Facebook the idea was to
pair Ottawa area residents with incoming
truckers so that the truckers could
receive support like showers food and
billets
in order to support this concept Mr Gare
created a crowdfunding campaign on
January 18th on gift sent go
this campaign was attached to a bank
account in his name located at the Royal
Bank of Canada
sometime after the creation of that
crowdfunding campaign he also with the
assistance of a man known to the
commission as surge created a website
the website did a number of different
things including soliciting email money
transfer donations
those donations were associated with an
email address that was also connected to
the same RBC account
and again on January 18th these
campaigns began to raise funds
next slide please
so I'm going to return now to the
GoFundMe campaign and discuss the events
that took place that eventually led to
that campaign being shut down
next slide
now I've already indicated that on
January 27th
GoFundMe had authorized the release of
one million dollars in funds
we'll recall that January 28th was the
first day in which protesters as part of
the freedom Convoy began to arrive in
Ottawa
GoFundMe Representatives told the
commission that on January 28th they
began to receive conflicting media
reports about the nature of the protests
that were taking place
they were aware of some media reports
that describe the protests as peaceful
and other reports that described it as
involving harassment or unlawful
activities
this led GoFundMe to have concerns about
terms service compliance not only with
respect to whether the funds would be
distributed in accordance with the
description
but also their requirement that funds
not be used to fund unlawful conduct
a series of further Communications
between GoFundMe and Convoy organizers
then took place
on January 31st GoFundMe sent emails to
organizers asking a series of questions
and in particular asking them to confirm
that no funds would be given to
protesters that were engaged in a range
of unlawful activities
one of the activities specifically
mentioned by GoFundMe in their
Communications was blockades of Roads
subsequently on February 1st the day in
which the one million dollar transaction
was actually initiated GoFundMe emailed
organizers asking the further series of
questions including whether or not they
would agree to publicly disavow unlawful
conduct that GoFundMe was concerned may
be taking place in Ottawa
GoFundMe ask the organizers to respond
to their questions within 24 hours
our response was not received within
that time frame and on February 2nd the
same day that one million dollars was
received into the first TD account
GoFundMe decided to suspend the
fundraiser pending further investigation
over the course of the next two days a
series of important meetings took place
on February 2nd representatives of
GoFundMe met with deputy chief Bell of
the Ottawa Police Service
and on February 3rd with mayor Watson of
the city of Ottawa
on February 3rd
the freedom Convoy organizers also had a
series of communications with GoFundMe
a letter drafted by Keith Wilson asking
as counsel for the Convoy Corporation
was sent
responding to the questions posed in
gofundme's February first email
subsequently a telephone conversation
took place involving Mr Wilson Mr Eros
other associates of the fundraisers and
the GoFundMe platform
in their interview with commission
Council GoFundMe Representatives
indicated that they left that meeting
unsatisfied with the responses that they
had received and they continued to have
concerns about the lawfulness of the
protests and the role that the funds
might play in those protests
on February 4th GoFundMe had a second
meeting with deputy chief Bell
it was also on that date that
representatives of GoFundMe reported
that they believed that individuals
associated with the freedom Convoy
leadership were using social media to
encourage harassment of GoFundMe
employees
GoFundMe reported that its employees had
received a number of threats after the
decision was made to suspend the
fundraising campaign and those threats
increased in frequency on February 4th
in the evening of February 4th GoFundMe
made the decision to cancel the
fundraiser and over the course of the
next 24 hours arrived at the conclusion
that they ought to refund all donations
made to the platform
next slide please
the overview report also describes the
events that took place surrounding the
move of the freedom Convoy fundraiser
from the GoFundMe platform to the Gibson
go platform
but as I mentioned before often events
were taking place in parallel
and as it turned out there were critical
events involved in that move to give
sengo that were taking place as early as
January 26th even before Miss Leach had
signed the attestation letter let alone
the GoFundMe campaign being shut down
next slide please
in order to understand this part of the
story there are some additional
individuals who have to be introduced
on January 26th a man named John Ballard
reached out to Jacob Wells the
co-founder of gifts and go
Mr Ballard is understood by the
commission to be associated with an
american-based social media platform
called cloudhub
in the January 26th meeting Mr Ballard
spoke to Mr Wells about the possibility
of the two men working together to
convince the freedom Convoy organizers
to move their crowdfunding campaign off
of GoFundMe and on to give sent go
in furtherance of this discussion on
January 27th Mr Wells created what he
described to the commission as a mock-up
of a campaign on his platform showing
what a freedom Convoy fundraiser would
look like on give sent go although to be
clear this was not an active campaign
and was not capable of receiving funds
on January 28th Mr Ballard obtained Mr
eros's contact information by way of Mr
Guerra
Mr Ballard contacted Mr Eros and asked
him to join a phone conversation to
discuss the possibility of the freedom
Convoy raising funds on gift sent go
Mr Eros agreed to join that conversation
however before that phone call took
place Mr Eros reports receiving a phone
call from another man named James peloso
who is associated with the organization
taking back our freedoms
Mr Eros and Mr peloso had not previously
had interactions with each other
Mr ploso indicated that he should be
involved in any phone call involving
give sent go because taking back our
freedoms had funders who would not agree
to fund the freedom Convoy unless one of
their individuals was on the inside for
discussions related to fundraising
activities
on January 31st
a meeting took place between Mr Eros Mr
Wells
Mr peloso
Mr Ballard
and another individual named Jeff brain
who is the founder of clout hub
during that meeting Mr Ballard described
a plan to move the freedom Convoy off of
GoFundMe and onto gift send go
as part of this plan he also suggested
that freedom Convoy organizers should
use clout Hub as their main web presence
to advertise their campaign and indeed
their movement as a whole
Mr Ballard also described how clout Hub
would provide a secure means of
communication between organizers of the
freedom Convoy
Mr brain again the founder of cloudhub
also offered to provide Freedom Convoy
organizers a quarter million dollar loan
to finance their operations pending the
ability for them to access donated funds
at the end of this meeting
no decision was made with respect to
taking clout Hub up on its offer to use
its services or indeed to accept a loan
from them indeed Mr Wells and Mr Eros in
their interviews with the commission
found it confusing that cloudhub was
involved in these meetings at all
however as a result of this meeting Mr
Eros and Mr Wells did form a connection
and as a result of that connection an
agreement was made to create a
crowdfunding campaign on give sent go
connected to the Convoy Corporation
that campaign was created and went live
on January 31st again prior to the
release of funds the next day from the
GoFundMe campaign
ultimately when the GoFundMe campaign
was shut down
Miss Leach advertised the fact that the
gifts sent go campaign was in existence
and funders then moved and made
donations there
next slide please
I mentioned before
that payment processors played an
important role in the story of the
fundraising of the freedom Convoy
this was a role that was played largely
behind the scenes and it had the most
significance when it came to the gifts
and go campaign
to the public there was only ever one
campaign on give sent go associated with
the freedom Convoy fundraiser
however for reasons connected with how
stripe operates there were in fact in
effect two campaigns associated with the
freedom Convoy fundraiser on give sent
go
and in order to understand why that came
to be one has to understand a little bit
about what payment processors are and
how they operate
most crowdfunding platforms don't
actually accept and distribute funds
themselves
they are in effect kind of a social
network shell that provides a platform
to attract donors
the actual work of receiving electronic
donations and distributing those
donations to bank accounts are done by
payment processors like stripe
on the give send go campaign
in order to set up a campaign at all one
needs to have a stripe account
however in order to create a stripe
account an individual has to have a bank
account to associate with it
this presented a unique difficulty for
Mr Eros
because at this point the Convoy
Corporation did not have a bank account
recall that the Convoy Corporation was
only created the day before on January
30th
he therefore could not create a stripe
account and therefore could not attach
it to the Gibson go campaign
as a temporary solution to this problem
Mr Wells suggested that he used his
stripe account
attach it to the campaign on give sent
go and that is what happened
and so between January 31st when the
campaign first went live
and February 7th
the Gibbs and go campaign was actually
attached to Mr Well's stripe account and
through that his personal bank account
on February 7th
Mr Eros did create a stripe account
however that account was not connected
to the Convoy Corporation directly
by February 7th the corporation still
did not have a bank account
in order for Mr Eros to create a stripe
account he reached an agreement with
Keith Wilson to have the stripe account
attached to Mr Wilson's trust account at
his Law Firm
once this took place on February 7th the
fundraiser was switched over for Mr
Wells stripe account to Mr eros's stripe
account
and from February 7th
until February 10th or 11th the evidence
on that point is conflicting
donations made to the give sent go
campaign went into Mr eros's stripe
account
on either February 10th or 11th
the stripe account was switched back to
Mr Wells stripe account and all further
donations made to give send go campaign
went there
next slide please
I'll return to the crowdfunding
campaigns in a moment but before I do a
few words about some of the activities
involving cryptocurrencies that were
taking place
the majority of these activities
occurred between January 27th and
February 17th of 2022.
next slide
there were a number of cryptocurrency
campaigns and fundraisers taking place
during the freedom Convoy
this overview report focuses on three
main ones
the first was a cryptocurrency campaign
associated with Mr guerra's adopt a
trucker campaign
I mentioned before that an individual
named Serge created a website for adopt
a trucker
in addition to soliciting email money
transfers that website also provided
information that would allow individuals
to donate any of six different types of
cryptocurrencies
to the adopt a trucker campaign
however it appears that those
cryptocurrencies were not in the control
of Mr Guerra directly but were rather
controlled by surge
a second different type of
cryptocurrency campaign
took place in association with Pat King
this was the freedom Convoy token
campaign
a new cryptocurrency that was created
and marketed in association
with the freedom Convoy
the idea behind this campaign was that
individuals would exchange pre-existing
cryptocurrencies for this new
cryptocurrency called Freedom Convoy
token
built into Freedom Convoy token
was a process by which four percent of
every transaction involving it would be
diverted to an entity called the freedom
Convoy Foundation
the idea being that this would provide a
long-term source of funds for Convoy
protesters
however the commission was unable to
determine whether or not such an entity
even exists
and it appears that there's not an
active market today for Freedom Convoy
token and therefore funds are not
flowing to any such entity
the most significant cryptocurrency
campaign addressed in the overview
report was the honk honk hoddle campaign
next slide please
this campaign was started by an Ottawa
area resident named Nicholas St Louis on
or about January 27th
well Mr St Louis was the creator of the
campaign there were a number of
individuals that were associated with it
at different stages including Benjamin
dictor
using a cryptocurrency crowdfunding
platform called tally coin
this campaign ultimately raised
approximately 22 Bitcoin in donations
the value of those 22 Bitcoin at the
time was approximately 1.2 million
dollars Canadian
although today the value would be
significantly lower
of that money
approximately 800 000 was distributed to
protesters involved in the Ottawa
protests
this was done
by splitting eight hundred thousand
dollars worth of bitcoin into 100
individual electronic wallets
and then handing out in sealed envelopes
100 sets of instructions on how to
access one of those unique online
wallets these were distributed to
truckers in Ottawa
over a 24-hour period on February 16th
and 17th of 2022.
next slide please
we get to the part of the narrative
contained in the overview report that
deals with how all of the funds we've
just been discussed were eventually
blocked from arriving in the hands of
fundraisers
in order to understand this it's useful
to understand two types of court orders
that were involved in the process that
led to these funds being blocked
the first is something called a
restraint order
that can only be obtained by the
Attorney General of a province or of
Canada
and it exists within the criminal codes
proceeds of crime provisions
in essence a restraint order is obtained
by the Attorney General when they are
able to show that there are reasonable
grounds to believe that some property
meets the definition of offense related
property
offense related property is defined to
mean any property that is used in any
manner in connection with an indictable
offense
or is intended to be so used
the effect of a restraint order is to
prohibit anyone from dealing in any way
with the property in question unless in
accordance with the terms of the order
of order to understand is called a
marava injunction
a marava injunction is a civil court
order
it is ordinarily obtained by plaintiffs
in civil proceedings against defendants
it is used to freeze and preserve a
defendant's assets and funds when there
is a risk that they may be dissipated
its purpose is to freeze those funds in
place so that if plaintiffs are
successful in their lawsuit there will
be assets that they are able to execute
judgment against
both of these types of orders restraint
orders and marava injunctions played a
significant role in how funds that were
raised were ultimately disposed of
next slide
on February 10th the Attorney General of
Ontario applied ex parte to the Ontario
superior court of justice and obtained a
restraint order against the funds that
had been raised on the give sent go
platform those being the freedom Convoy
campaign as well as the adopted trucker
campaign
as a result of the restraint order
stripe froze the accounts of Mr Guerra
and Mr Eros
it did not however freeze the account of
Mr Wells as it was held not by stripe
payment Canada Limited but by the
American payment company stripe which
stripe felt was beyond the reach of the
Ontario restraint order
I've mentioned before that is either on
February 10th or 11th
that Mr Wells changed over the stripe
account associated with the freedom
Convoy fundraiser for Mr eros's Frozen
stripe account to his own active stripe
account
Mr Wells also took action with respect
to the adopted trucker campaign
well Mr guerra's stripe account was
frozen by the restraint order
Mr Wells switched that campaign over to
a backup payment processor based in the
United States called rally pay
thus while both of the fundraising
campaigns remained attached to active
payment processors and could continue to
receive funds it will be difficult for
those funds to arrive in the hands of
the organizers
by this point in time both TD Bank and
RBC had been put on notice of the
restrained order and they too were
prevented by its terms from dealing in
any way with the funds raised on gift
sent go
on February 17th zexi Lee in her role as
the representative plaintiff of a
proposed class action of Ottawa
residents obtained a marava injunction
this order applied to a broader set of
categories like assets
it included those assets covered by the
restraint order but also applied to
several other individuals and other
assets for example it applied to assets
that were raised by Mr King and applied
to a range of cryptocurrencies that were
not the subject of the restraint order
on the same day
the Toronto Dominion Bank applied to
court
to pay in through an interpleter
approximately 1.4 million dollars
that were in the first and second TD
accounts in the joint control of Miss
Leach and Mr Barber
they did so on the basis that the true
owners of those funds were unknown and
that the funds should be held by the
court until such time as the proper
recipients of that money could be
determined
the money then stayed in these various
bank accounts in various locations
Frozen by both the restraint and the
mareva orders
this changed on March 9th when the
marava injunction was varied to allow
these funds essentially to be pooled in
the hands of an escrow agent
who would hold them all pending the
outcome of the Ottawa litigation
and in the days and weeks that followed
the funds that we have been discussing
so far were transferred to the escrow
agent where the commission understands
they remain
next slide please
this then takes us then to what the
commission understands about the sources
of the various funds and their ultimate
destinations
next slide
during the events in question there were
many public statements and questions
raised about the issue of foreign versus
domestic funding
and in the ordering Council creating
this commission this issue is also
flagged for the commission's
consideration
as a result of this the commission made
inquiries with various entities about
the sources of funds both in terms of
number of donors
and in terms of the value of donations
the result of these inquiries show
different patterns for different
fundraisers
the simplest are the email money
transfer campaigns associated with the
freedom Convoy and adopt a trucker
those campaigns were 100 Canadian in
that they relied on the email money
transfer system that exists within
Canada all donations to those
fundraisers originated at least
immediately from a Canadian domiciled
financial institution
the freedom Convoy GoFundMe campaign was
also largely Canadian in its origin
GoFundMe reported that 86 percent of
donors were based in Canada
and that by value 89 percent
of donations originated in Canada
the two campaigns on give sent go
however show a different pattern
both of those campaigns were largely
american-based in terms of where donors
were located
Freedom Convoy 59 of donations
originated from the United States 51 for
adopt a trucker
however when measured in terms of the
value of donations
the values are slightly different
55 in terms of the actual dollars
donated through adopt a trucker
originated in Canada
and in terms of the freedom Convoy
campaign an equal amount of money
originated from Canada and the United
States at 47 percent each
the remainder from other countries
around the world
next slide please
and so we return then to this chart
that describes the value of money
flowing into and out of a number of
different entities
I'll begin with the GoFundMe campaign
the GoFundMe campaign raised in excess
of 10 million dollars Canadian
one million dollars of that was released
to miss Leach's Toronto Dominion Bank
account
however the full amount was also
refunded to donors
in other words while GoFundMe released a
million dollars it also refunded all
donors the full amount of their
donations making up the one million
dollar shortfall themselves
in addition to the one million dollars
that was deposited into Miss Leach's TD
account from the GoFundMe fundraiser she
also received
419
416.63 in email money transfer donations
out of this approximately 1.4 million
dollars put into the first and second TD
account
only twenty six thousand dollars was
accessed
the remaining one million three hundred
ninety three thousand dollars and change
was placed ultimately into escrow as
part of the marava injunction
with respect to adopt a trucker
Mr Guerra raised around eight hundred
thousand dollars Canadian on gift sent
go
of that amount
approximately three hundred and thirty
thousand dollars was released by stripe
into Mr guerra's RBC account
the remaining money contained in Mr
Gareth stripe account was either
ultimately paid into escrow
or was the subject of a variety of
credit card disputes chargebacks or fees
by various financial institutions
in addition to the 330 000 that Mr uh
sorry that Mr Guerra received into his
RBC account he also received
approximately Thirty one thousand
dollars in email money transfer
donations
of this amount approximately two hundred
and twenty thousand dollars was released
from Mr guerra's RBC account and spent
on a variety
of things
approximately 141 thousand dollars was
paid by RBC from that account into
escrow
with respect to the freedom Convoy
campaign on give sent go it begins to
become a little bit difficult to provide
precise figures
this is because Gibbs sent go was
reporting donations in U.S funds
but that those donations were made over
a period of time subject to a number of
different exchange rates
what we can
is that gives send go reported receiving
approximately 9.8 million dollars U.S in
donations
and that using the February 10th Bank of
Canada exchange rate that would be equal
to roughly 12.4 million dollars Canadian
of this
around
3.75 million dollars was put into Mr
eros's stripe account
and the remaining approximately 8.6
million dollars went into Mr Wells
stripe account
the money in Mr eros's stripe account
was sent into escrow it was not provided
to Mr Eros or into the trust account of
Mr Wilson
there is a bit of a discrepancy there
which was explained by stripe being
taken up again by credit card
chargebacks and a variety of fees
in terms of Mr Wells stripe account
while we the commission did not have
access to any banking records associated
with this in Communications between Mr
Wells and stripe that the commission did
review it appears that all donations
made and put into his stripe account
were refunded to donors
with the exception of certain fees that
were subtracted as well as components of
those donations that donors had
indicated should go directly to give
sent go
with respect to the Hong Kong hoddle
campaign as I mentioned before out of
approximately 1.2 million dollars of
Bitcoin that was raised 800 000 of that
was distributed to protesters
paid into escrow was
7.57 Bitcoin
which at the time was worth
approximately
413 thousand dollars
finally there was a ten thousand dollar
Bank draft that was also paid into
escrow
this money originated from a very brief
period of time when the Convoy
Corporation did have a bank account at
the Steinbach Credit Union
next slide please
the overview report contains
substantially more detail about these
transactions and the events surrounding
them
for the parties the overview report is
available in the participant database
and for members of the public this
overview report will soon be published
in both English and French on the
commission's website along with over 100
Source documents that provide further
detail on the things that I've discussed
in my presentation
with that Mr commissioner I'd ask that
com
or705 be entered into evidence
okay thank you very much so that
I've had detail on all the movement of
funds
now are we in a position to
move to the next uh
phase okay
the next witness is Benjamin dictor
foreign
a religious document or do you wish to
affirm
we have the Bible the Quran or the Torah
available you have a cedora Torah yeah
please
Torah
thank you
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Benjamin dictor
b-e-n-j-m-i-n dictator d-i-c-h-t-e-r
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth shall be God yes I do
thank you
good morning Mr Victor good morning
uh well uh the registrar takes the Torah
your Council here Jim Cara halios I
believe wants to make a brief statement
before we begin okay
uh thank you Mr Mather my name is Jim
carahallios I'm counsel for the witness
Mr dictor the last name is spelled
k-a-r-a-h-a-l-i-o-s
thank you Mr commissioner for giving me
a minute in the introduction Mr Victor
has a a couple of requests
um as the commission has posted on their
website Mr Victor made a late
application for standing
um that was dismissed uh in that
application uh the application for
standing was done jointly with um Mr
Christopher Guerra who as we saw in the
previous report
was the lead on the adopt a trucker
campaign Mr Guerra has a standing as a
member of the uh what we are calling the
Convoy organizer group uh Mr Guerra is
in attendance here today we received
yesterday the time allocations today
um uh with regards to after the evidence
in Chief is provided it provides for 15
minutes for the Convoy organizers in
five minutes for uh I believe the
Democracy fund the jccf and 10 minutes
for Mr Victor's Council
given that the Convoy organizers and the
jccf Democracy fund have very similar
interests Victor Mr Victor would like to
ask the commissioner with the approval
of Mr Guerra who's a member of jointly
the Convoy organizers and standing and
gives his approval to consider and I
hope my friend from the Convoy
organizers would uh agree to reallocate
some of the 15 minutes provided to the
Convoy organizers to Mr Victor's council
at the end uh for further questions
okay so if I understand correctly uh
you're seeking to have a transfer from
the Convoy organizers uh of five minutes
to your uh final submissions or
presentation that's correct I think that
would better balance the time allocation
after the evidence in Chief with the
interests of everyone involved okay I
don't know if that's been discussed with
the Convoy organizers or not
I haven't had a chance to discuss with
my friend but Mr Guerra is here today in
attendance and he's a member uh jointly
having standing with the Convoy
organizers and he gave his Blessing
um so I apologize Mr commissioner I
haven't had a chance to talk to uh legal
counsel the Convoy organizers in advance
well I see Convoy organizers councils
just walking in so
um that obviously hasn't been discussed
uh so uh we can address it when we get
to the point of cross-examination if it
hasn't been sorted out before then
and I can assure you uh we won't be
short-changing the witness we've been
quite uh understanding about the
situation for Witnesses who are not uh
represented by Council thank you Mr
commissioner the second uh brief uh uh
thing I'd like to ask on behalf of Mr
Victor is
um in his application to have his
Council lead his testimony here today
you correctly pointed out Mr
commissioner rule 59 that allows for Mr
Victor to apply for additional time in
the evidence in Chief led by his counsel
if I understand it correctly at the end
of Mr Mather's evidence in Chief if you
could just give a Mr dictor a little bit
of time to decide whether he wants that
rule 59 application to be brought
forward to you for more time and
evidence in Chief by me that would be
appreciated
so that's a similar it's sort of
different different periods of the uh of
the testimony but yes similar okay well
the same response where we will of
course uh Endeavor to make sure it's
it's fair to the witness and uh
we
obtain the evidence we need thank you Mr
Commission
okay good morning again Mr Victor good
morning uh my name is John Mather I'm
commission counsel
um I just have a few questions about
your background uh to start I understand
you're from Toronto is that correct uh
yes I grew up in Toronto in a middle
class family Bay of New York Mills
I grew up in a Jewish home I was adopted
and I hit the jackpot with my family
and later in life I found out from my my
biological siblings who found me I Am
The Descendant or the the grandson of
Brigadier General Dennis Whitaker so
yeah
um and what's your current occupation uh
I'm in my trucker and I produce podcasts
how long have you been a trucker uh
several years about four four years
approximately and I've been an owner
operator
for a couple of years
and can you just give the commission a
sense of the nature of your trucking
business where you travel what sort of
loads you carry uh yeah I drive to the
United States mainly and as we call it
the upper right corner
so Rhode Island New York New Jersey all
that sort of stuff uh with the carry I
work with predominantly Commodities
paper that sort of stuff
and can you uh
give the commission a sense of the sort
of podcasts you produce a variety of
stuff so uh Professor Stephen Hicks we
produce a podcast called open College I
do a legal podcast called not on record
with a couple of lawyers and a really
well-known legal researcher so I've been
learning a lot over the past a couple of
years a wide range of stuff and we've
we've changed some of the stuff that
we've had on this little it started as a
hobby and we're slowly growing it into a
small little side business any other
podcasts
uh I mean there's a a few of them
there's we did for a while
um
uh you too with Mike Bullard we're not
doing that anymore
uh untrue crime Dana Davison one Godless
woman uh she's a Saudi activist the
quiggan report
and we at the most I think a total I've
produced and created seven different
podcasts with different creators
sometimes uh podcast companies or they
fall under umbrella like is there a name
for your podcasting publishing platform
yeah possibly correct possibly correct
okay well tongue-in-cheek humor okay and
were you uh podcasting uh with possibly
correct in January 2022. uh yes it was a
little bit slow uh things were you know
you're coming off the the new year and
um it kind of Ebbs and flows there's
different times where it's busier
depending on what my creators are
sending me you know they'll do their
scripts they'll do the recordings send
it to me and depending on their
availability that availability that's
when I'll upload content
and the commission has read reports that
indicated that you've also had jobs
including being a gemologist designing
safety equipment for motorcyclists and
owning a commercial printing shop is
that accurate I went to school for
gemology and I was a diamond grader was
my specialty
um I patented a product for motorcycles
many years ago and moved out to Canada
when my girlfriend at the time was
diagnosed with cancer
uh and I had a printing business on
Ryerson University's campus well
adjacent to Ryerson University's campus
for uh several years yes
I also understand you ran for City
Council in 2014 is that correct ran for
City Council in 2014 and also ultimately
ran for federal politics for the
conservatives right and that was in 2015
2015 yeah and I should when I say City
Council in this setting I should say
that was the city council of Toronto yes
Council of Ottawa is that correct yes
um and you've also founded a group
called LGBT sorry LGB Tory yes um can
you
tell the commission what that group is
yeah LGB Tory was uh basically
um a community Organization for friends
of mine who were conservative and in the
gay community there was a lot of uh
tension that was building up and they
felt very I don't know we'd say
alienated where my business was was
adjacent to the gay because I have a lot
of gay friends
and uh so we decided let's put together
uh an advocacy group a meeting Group
whatever just to allow people to come to
come out and you know doc who founded
with me always says it was easier to
come out as gay than it was to come out
as a conservative in the gay community
when we started
and is that group still active
periodically uh we actually we had a
meeting a couple of months ago and
looking at moving forward in the near
future I'm so busy with so many other
things at this point so they just kind
of meet with me for my ideas advice
messaging that sort of stuff
um shifting now to the protests in
Ottawa in 2020 in January and February
2022 how did you get involved
Tamara Leach called me on January 15th
and uh you know I knew Tamara it seems
to be when I'm learning in testimony I
knew her the longest and she reached out
to me she said we've started a GoFundMe
campaign within the past couple of days
it seems to be taking off uh if you
could come on board help me with
messaging uh pressers press releases all
that sort of stuff and I said um yeah
sure so I
decided to to get involved with her and
how did you first meet Miss Leach
I met her
2017 or 2018 I was in Alberta I was
connected to her through some other
people I went to Medicine Hat and that's
where I made a state of their house
actually when you say you connected with
her through some other people who were
those people uh people that were fans of
one of the podcasts that I was doing and
so they invited the podcaster out and I
just kind of tagged along and got to see
a Medicine Hat and Grand Prairie for the
first time in my life
and what was that podcast that they were
fans of uh the Quicken report quicker
yeah
um so sorry you said that was around
2017 2018 yeah 17-18 summer then and uh
after you first met Miss Leach how
frequently were you in contact between
then and January 2022. well pretty
frequently actually we would
um sometimes every couple weeks
sometimes once a month just hey catching
up how are you that sort of thing me and
her really bonded on the whole I think I
made fun of positivity sort of good
energy sort of thing we really connected
when we first met each other and she had
interest in politics and so we would
discuss politics in general and there
were a lot of concerns from people in
rural Alberta uh what had been going on
in Canada from the perspective of people
in her community what did you come to
learn about Miss Leach's political
interests
uh when I was in Medicine Hat uh I
didn't I didn't know that she had been
involved uh politically and new people
in politics out there I thought she was
just you know just a fan sort of thing
and I just kind of okay fine she knows
people in politics great and just didn't
really delve all that much into it at
that point but it sounds like you had
subsequent conversations with her about
politics is that right oh yeah yeah for
sure that's one of the things we would
talk about she'd call me and you know
just general what do you think about
what's happening and through those
conversations what did you learn about
misleegis politics what was she trying
to do what was she hoping to achieve
what was her interest you know what I
don't know it's really interesting
because she's she's really practical and
I wouldn't call her extreme to any side
I would say she's I don't like the
labels it's the problem uh
so the political Spectrum thing I would
call her maybe very center right if
we're going to use that antiquated
definition which I don't think is
accurate but she's very very Pro you
know she's no I know something very
libertarian on social issues and she's
the same way so we we crossed over a lot
of that stuff and I'm not asking you to
put a label on this leash what I'm what
I'm interested in understanding is
through your conversations with her what
did you understand you know the causes
that she was interested in what what was
she trying to achieve regardless of what
the label is
um I don't know I know she like she
ended up with this Maverick party and
which I tried to explain to her like J
Hill who's leading the Maverick party is
a conservative party MP like that's as
establishment is it's not a real party
Tamara is what I told her what are you
spinning your wheels with this for
uh but she says no I'm going to give it
a chance you never know like you know we
need to have more voices for people in
Alberta I'm like okay and actually uh
leading up to prior to the Convoy I had
a conversation I guess Before Christmas
if I'm memory remembering correctly and
she seemed to be coming around and she
said to me yeah
I think you're right all this time I
think I'm just getting frustrated
because she notices all people tied to
the conservative party in Maverick I
don't know the details that's just what
she was communicating to me so the sense
I get from that response is that she was
involved in the Maverick party and you
raised with her you know this is this is
tied to the conservative party or has a
relationship and that's an establishment
party it sounded like that was something
you weren't in favor of is that fair no
it's it's kind of the the deceptive
tactic that if you're the conservative
party then just be part of the
conservative party don't make fake
parties like just you see a lot of that
going on lately and I just find it's uh
it's deceptive to the voter base who may
not understand this is the sort of thing
that goes on in politics I just don't
support that be who you are right
at that point in time in December 2021
were you still a supporter of the
conservative party
you know I still I have some I have some
people in that party who love me and I
have some people in that party who hate
me uh because I will call us they call
the conservative party out when I think
they're doing something wrong so I don't
know it shifts depends on uh the month
and what's going on and who's leader and
I personally just leaning up to the
Convoy
I just feel like I'm done with politics
just it's not for me
again setting aside labels how would you
describe your political views in
December 2021 to January 2022.
um like I'm a downtown middle class I
grew up middle class uh
Canadian
fiscal conservative libertarian on
social issues let's all get along let's
all talk to one another and let's not
get into these different Echo Chambers
and silos which is something that I've
seen worse in over the years and I saw
it particularly on the University campus
when I had my business there
so miss Leach calls you and I forget you
said what date you thought it was but it
was January 2022 and she asks you if you
can come and assist with messaging and
press releases
um I think we know from the evidence
that you took her up on the request is
that fair yep why did you want to
participate in the Convoy
um I would I was very uncomfortable with
the mandates and the arrive can app and
the the Data Tracking I know lots of
truckers that were being affected by it
I'm vaccinated myself but
um I saw the amount of stress that it
was causing on people and I figured if I
can I know where her frame is in terms
of being very positive
and I figured
um might work well together to get a
positive message out there peace love
unity and freedom which are the four
words I kept repeating over and over
again
what day did you arrive in Ottawa
January 28th and how did you get there I
drove your truck no no I drove my car I
never I because of the nature of my
contract with my uh owner operator I
can't I can only I only have insurance
when I'm hooked up to a load so I I had
no desire to bring my truck here
did you consider at all whether or not
you could find a truck or another
commercial vehicle to bring with you you
know in solidarity with the other
truckers that had arrived no because my
perspective my I was there to be
messaging right and I figured I'm going
to be spending all my time doing
interviews and talking I'm not yeah I'll
try to get on the street and talk to
people but I wanted to just get maximum
exposure and again uh convey that
message of peace love unity and freedom
what did you hope to achieve by
participating in the Convoy
I thought I hoped we would uh help to
convey we would affect some positive
change and help bring some people
together and I got to tell you on the
28th
it's amazing
we're in front of the Chateau Laurier I
see
thousands of people walking across from
into Quebec because we know how strict
the regulations were in Quebec with
Canadian and fleur-de-lis together signs
that said Liberty and freedom and they
came up and they were on Parliament Hill
and they're hugging these albertan
truckers and Saskatchewan truckers like
everybody's finally getting along and so
this this division of you know Quebec
doesn't like Alberta and that was gone
everybody was getting along and you know
Keith stole one of my experiences and
I'm glad he can conveyed it yesterday
with these two truckers and Tim Hortons
one was from Saskatchewan the other one
was from Quebec and they were
communicating via Google translate and
they're hanging out they're joking it
was amazing it was absolutely beautiful
um and so again you've said that you
were there to assist with messaging and
and public relations is that fair yeah
that's a good way to look at it and uh
was there anyone else who was uh working
on on that aspect of the organization
yeah ultimately had a team of three
people working with me as well in my
hotel suite and we were one the ones
putting out most of uh the press
releases and messaging and all that sort
of stuff okay
and as
um maybe if you could assist the
commission and and give us a sense of
what it involved to be doing messaging
and press release and public relations
what what did your day-to-day involve uh
scheduling lots of interviews my my
email and Twitter threads uh sorry
Twitter DMS uh social media direct
messages I was getting requests from all
over the world from every news agency
imaginable and I was trying to figure
out who can we go to where I know we'll
get Fair representation and compared
with who's going to have
um enough engagement and enough views
that'll allow us to be effective
um and as the commission understands
it's uh you gave some television
interviews during the Convoy is that
correct many
um and those included with Outlets like
Fox News
uh Tucker Carlson Hannity uh
Newsmax did a lot of podcasts Gad sad
Jordan Peterson Stephen Crowder like
just had looked for what is what I what
I believe is current media and yeah
and you as I understand you also gave at
least one interview with Russia Today is
that correct yes I did yeah and you say
you gave interviews with what you view
as current media can you just explain
what you meant by that uh yeah so media
that has been successfully able to
leverage uh alternative media platforms
so uh we're not doing an interview with
a media organization that's going to
have 30 000 people watch at night and
then it's not going to be uploaded
anyways there's no archival of it so
it's kind of a balance of those newer
platforms that I actually with Russia
Today I explained that they're one of
the I like them or not they were one of
the platforms that was able to leverage
both uh online media as well as
alternative media
So when you say current media you were
looking for in your view the media that
had the largest platforms or would reach
the largest audiences that is that
that's right that would be the most
effective yeah for sure
um and I understand that you uh would
not give interviews to Media
organizations such as the CBC the
Toronto Star the Globe and Mail is that
correct that's right and why wouldn't
you give interviews to those Canadian
media well for example the Toronto Star
put out
um a meme and I I can't remember the
exact cartoon but it was completely
defamatory that of the truckers
you already saw some narratives coming
out from established Canadian media
trying to tie us to January 6th which
has nothing to do with this protest and
we saw in testimony here that there were
text messages coming from the prime
minister's office which proved exactly
that so I was right
foreign
we've heard some evidence from different
Witnesses so far about uh you having
suffered some injuries uh during on your
on your way to Ottawa and during your
time in Onawa I'll just give you an
opportunity can you just explain exactly
what happened and when it happened
so on February 4th uh somebody came into
my room and said the lawyers just did a
video that's the complete opposite of
our messaging we call it the war the
worlds video
uh now and I looked at it and I was
horrified it was come to Auto come to
Ottawa your freedoms are dying Canada is
dying here like Doom and Gloom not peace
love unity and freedom which built the
movement so I went over to the ark hotel
to
explain my sentiments and maybe a little
aggressively but you know there are so
many problems going on at that time
that's just another wrench that was
thrown into the spokes of the wheel
and uh as I went back after a 20 30
minute long uh meeting about a few
issues a number of issues I'm sure we'll
get into
um I was presented with the class action
suit and a retainer here we're going to
give you free legal advice if you guys
sign it so that was the nature of the
meeting and I went back to the Sheraton
and I realized I lost my laptop I was so
heated I didn't pull it out so I went
back and I slipped the first time I was
going back and forth and finally uh in a
panic going to get my computer my laptop
which is my life
I slipped on this massive thing of ice
in front of the EDC building
and I slipped on the ice
and I remember the exact moment I still
picture it I was it was nine o'clock 9
30 at night on the the fourth
approximately
and there were a couple of trucks in the
parking Lane
a bunch of cars
the driving lanes were completely open a
couple of cars were parked in front of
the Sheridan dropping people off
and it was silent there was no one
around and that's why when people honk
him like it was dead silent I felt very
alone and secluded it was weird so I
tried to get up I heard a crack
I've never broken anything but I'm
wiggling my toes I'm like it's all
broken so uh but I couldn't get up and I
hear from the distance uh in front of
our hotel a trucker a red suit big beard
says uh you need help and I'm like I
think so he's screamed him well yeah I
think so it comes over and he says um
you need help I'm like yeah he puts his
hand on my my ankle and he says Jesus
Lord God bless this ankle heal it now
thy father and whatever like I love you
man but I was thinking of a paramedic
and another guy is like do you need help
I'm like yeah this time send a medic
please
and it was amazing because there was you
know just an hour there was so much
friction
but and this was a common thing there
was friction and then we get together
friction we get so we were able to work
out our differences when he we needed to
They Carried me on to the into the arc
hotel lobby they put me on the couch
they called the paramedics and everybody
just it was a serious moment everybody
came back to help me Chad was by my side
Miranda was pumping me with drugs I
don't know she's given me uh Bridget was
there the doctors came down to look at
me to say uh that um that is broken so
it was uh it was an amazing and then the
paramedics got there in I don't know 30
30 minutes 45 minutes and they said yeah
it's broken you need to go to the
hospital
so I said uh okay should I call an
ambulance they said well the problem is
uh you're not an important case you're
just a broken ankle there's other people
have more serious cases if you can call
one it might take about an hour or so
so I asked the our volunteers and they
said yeah we can one of us can drive you
to the hospital and
Ottawa General I'm telling Ottawa
Hospital 20 minutes from the hotel to
having a a doctor cutting up my new
genes
it was crazy it was great so so that
that was that incident and then I'm
gonna return to a second were you also
in a car accident just briefly is that
true uh yes I was thinking before okay
so it had a bit of a better run of bad
luck
um yeah but there were other things on
my mind my mind was the messaging we
need to keep every everybody happy and
peaceful and all that sort of stuff but
yeah so I want to pick up on the uh the
context or the what what what happened
before you you slipped and and fell
um you said that there had been a press
conference on February 4th with I think
you said the lawyers is that right no it
wasn't a press conference somebody came
in and said uh the lawyers put up a
video and that's
Doom and Gloom the opposite of our
messaging and I said what lawyers
who who what lawyers are talking about
that's when I went across to find out
who these people were okay so
um did you see the video yourself yes I
did and did you recognize the lawyers in
the video no no I needed who did you
come to learn who the lawyers were by
Keith Wilson okay okay and so you were
staying at the Sheridan Hotel that's
right and you went to the ark Hotel yeah
and why did you go to the arc hotel to
find out who was in the video because
that's where they were and who's the
they uh so um we had three different
hotels so the Sheridan became messaging
my team was dealing with that the arc
Hotel was doing I guess Logistics that
sort of there was always conflict there
and the Swiss hotel I think was security
communicating with the police emergency
lanes all that sort of stuff they
actually had it took a while but they
got it pretty well organized so I was
told that they're at the arc hotel now
go and see them that's why they said the
video so I went there and they are at
the hotel the the lawyers yeah and then
who did you meet at the hotel
uh Keith
um Andre
um
uh Eva
and Chad I met him for the first time
there's a couple other people hey
Bridget came Tamara came in about 15
minutes after
uh after I had my heated exchange
there's maybe 10 people there so Keith
Wilson yeah Eva chippyuk yes Andre menu
memomari I believe yes okay uh chatty
Ross Bridget Bridget Belton yes and
there's a couple other people from the
board I don't remember who okay
um and what described the conversation
you had at that point in time
um
I might have used some trucker words
with uh with Keith to explain my uh
discontent that I just spent uh almost
three weeks of my life getting everybody
on a message of peace love unity and
freedom and it worked people are here
with hippie tie dyes there's people left
wing right wing all wings just hanging
out together
and you just I said to him do you
understand what you just did
knowing I have a brother in policing two
nephews in policing like I understand
that world a little bit
mood and behavior is what they're
monitoring they don't care what we say
it's mood and behavior the mood and
behavior was positive until right now
you just undid all of that and he seemed
concerned
and he said oh oh I'm sorry well
and it should have thought that before
but anyways that was it and then the
next thing was well you've just been
served congratulations with a
multi-million dollar lawsuit and what
are you talking about a class action
lawsuit for what for a Hawkings what
honking it was the same night that it
was I broke my ankle so
you had this conversation with Mr Wilson
you expressed your concern
um did uh did did things improve after
that in terms of Mr Wilson's messaging
uh no it's um
it seemed to be on the same trajectory
and I felt like one of the things that
to look at the Convoy itself when people
talked about the Convoy organizers there
were many different groups right it
wasn't just one group and every
different group had their own idea but
we were all converging on the idea of
arrive can and and the mandates but he
seemed to be representing another group
that wanted to go in a different
direction and what was your
understanding of that direction
uh that it was counter to peace love
unity and freedom and it was
it was weird it was
um it seemed to be coming from
you know I started to put the pieces
together after a couple of days that
these people were politically connected
in some way shape or form
and
um
you know it just within a couple of days
we have uh or a few days later we have
uh Keith Wilson and
um Randy hillier's buddy Tom moratzo
and Doug Ford's buddy Dean French
setting up meetings with people in the
city pretending to be negotiating some
sort of deal and what was shocking is
nobody in the Ottawa Police in the
mayor's office uh in the city council
did the most basic due diligence to see
if these people possessed the position
of moral persuasion that they could they
could speak on their behalf
it was just really weird did you think
that Mr Wilson and Mr marazzo could
speak had had the position of moral
persuasion no I didn't I don't think so
why not
um just because firstly for up until
that point on the GoFundMe was myself
and Tamara and that's why we were
getting so much attention so many people
reaching out so many people knew who we
were
I'm a trucker so it's a little bit of uh
you know there's a culture amongst uh
truckers as well these were lawyers that
I don't know they seem to have some
ulterior motive or they seem to know
people in politics that I don't know
that they had our like they may have
been organizing a deal
um with the city but maybe they're
they're structuring a deal for Doug Ford
but it wasn't for the truckers that
makes sense so it sounds to me that um
you had a concern that they were they
were pursuing political a political
agenda and or ulterior motives is that
fair
yes and it's one of those things you
can't put your finger on it you kind of
you realize there's something going on
and these people are well connected so
do you think Mr Wilson and Mr marazzo
had the same goals as you in terms of
ending the mandates uh no I don't think
so I think their their goals were ending
the protests and getting getting
everybody out of the city as quickly as
possible because when when I first met
Tom marazzo he said to me if I thought
we got summer he said listen I'm just
going to be here dealing with the trucks
I don't know who put him there I I don't
you know there was very fluid all the
time okay fine he said I'm going to be
dealing with the trucks
I'm Gonna Be a Ghost
Nobody's Gonna Know I Was Here I will be
invisible and I thought great perfect so
finally because every day we're dealing
with different people setting up their
own press conferences we finally got
that under control like great so I'll
deal with the messaging
the trucks are parked so I don't know
what you want to do you want to move
trucks that was a little suspect to me
in the back of my head but I just kind
of left it there and then the next
morning somebody comes into my my hotel
to tell me at Tom marazzo guess what
he's doing I'm like what a press
conference
it's less than 12 hours ago he told me
he's not gonna what is going on and
that's uh that's the cats we were trying
to herd did you ever speak with Mr
Wilson or Mr rozzo about the concerns
you had about what they were doing ah
yes yes many times to everybody I spoke
to Tamara about it Tamara agreed with me
and she put out a number of messages to
people she was typing messages with me
to tell people she got on the phone
because this happened numerous times
telling people no comms or no
Communications goes out unless it's
approved by Benjamin and his team
so that's with respect to who's doing
the messaging button that's right your
concerns that uh Mr marazzo and Mr
Wilson were seeking to end the protests
or find a way for the protest to end is
that something you ever brought to them
and asked them about uh I didn't say
them directly because I'm going to go to
him and say you're trying to sabotage
the protests I mean then it's a little
bit jumping the gun it the indicators
seem to be there but I couldn't prove it
so
what did you do to try to understand if
this is actually what they were trying
to do
um what I wanted to do was just control
the messaging first stop going out and
doing press conferences I remember when
Keith said to me uh yeah we're going to
try and reach out to the city and I
remember saying
to bring it up to the city for just wait
dance parties barbecues we're feeding
the homeless just wait
so then we have to have a press
conference every day I'm like it's not a
hostage negotiation and you're the ones
because they agreed with me that the
Legacy Media just lies so you're telling
me the legacy of media lies yet you want
to run to the Legacy meeting to a press
conference every time like just calm
down everybody relax we'll do a press
conference at the end of any every week
except for if something materializes and
we need to do a press conference when
the government brings some sort of
Representative who's going to speak with
us I can't hear they're talking
sorry
okay
you try and either
not talk or keep it down please and Mr
dictator yes We're translating all of
this oh sorry slow down a bit please
slow down it's uh I apologize you know
you get excited and that's okay but try
and get excited with a slope okay
will do my apologies so Mr Victor I've
heard you know what what you've said
about
dealing with the messaging and your
approach to the messaging and I
understand your what you're saying with
respect to I wasn't going to go to Mr
Wilson or Mr marazzo and say I you know
I'm concerned you have ulterior motives
are you trying to are you trying to end
the protest did you raise that concern
with Miss Leach Mr Barber Miss Belton
anyone who I presume you didn't have a
concern with Tamara for sure and Tamara
and I spoke
all the time
there was a day and a half that I have
had to leave from the when I left on the
30th came back on the second ended up
being the third because of the car
accident
I must have talked to her 25 times that
day like we were in constant
communication me and Tamara had great
communication during the entire time and
what did Miss Leach say in response to
your concerns uh I'll handle it we'll
take care of it I'll talk to them uh the
the primary thing was the uh the
messaging of course but when this whole
idea of let's move trucks to Wellington
it's I don't understand what what is the
goal of that I mean I was just in some
of these not the the streets in the
middle of downtown that only had a few
trucks on it I didn't see these
residential streets and I'm sure
people will tell give me some you know
anecdotes of a street here and there
that might have had a truck on it okay
that might be the case
but that was not my experience I just
the whole idea of let's consolidate
everything into Wellington the cops told
us where to park Chris Guerra was here
for a week he got maps from the Ottawa
policing Park your trucks here because
we wanted to have safety routes so
safety Vehicles could get through during
the protest emergency vehicles and
people could just generally drive around
and I was driven around a couple of
times so I was in a car when I came in
and out of the city like I got in and
out of the city no problem
and we'll get to the uh the agreement
with the mayor to move the trucks more
in a moment but okay I I understand
that's what you're referring to when
you're talking about moving trucks to
Wellington
um and the evidence we've heard so far
is that
um the mayor wrote a letter saying that
he would agree to meet with some of the
organizers if the organizers were able
to show that they could move trucks out
of the residential areas onto Welling
and perhaps elsewhere uh perhaps
elsewhere in it and we'll get to how
that came about in a moment but
ultimately at some point you did you
learn that Miss Leach had entered into
that agreement with the mayor no I
didn't know that she got into that
agreement until like during the Convoy I
don't even remember seeing that it was
all really opaque
so it was we're doing a deal what we're
taking care of it okay well that's the
inverse of the way it's supposed to work
you got to tell the messaging people
first so we can communicate it to people
because all that would do is that would
heighten potentially conflict and
anxiety of the protesters protesters
who've been sitting out there freezing
all day and need to be able to tell them
what's happening but they wouldn't do
that no much how much I tried right but
at some point you learned that Tamara
had sent those letters I appreciate and
we'll we'll probably speak to a moment
you
that it may be the case you didn't
understand what was happening at the
time but at some point you learned that
yes Tamara had exchange letters with the
mayor I don't remember seeing it during
the Convoy I might have and just amongst
the thousands of messages it just in and
out I I okay great and forgot about it
because they're doing so much other
stuff Have you ever spoken with Miss
Leach
about the agreement that she reached
with the mayor uh no I haven't spoken to
miss Leach since I gave her a hug in my
hotel room uh the night before she was
arrested and because I didn't want to
put her at any risk and I knew the
slightest misstep that she would be
targeted so
um Miss Leach was arrested uh after the
agreement with the mayor and after
February 14th when we've heard evidence
of moving trucks onto Wellington in that
last time you spoke with Miss Leach did
you ask her at all about whether or not
she had agreed with the mayor to move
trucks up onto Wellington no I was
because I was so focused on messaging I
just had done uh that was when I did the
statement on Jordan Peterson's podcast
to clarify that we are not here to
overthrow the government we are that's
what elections are for we hope that our
parliamentarians and our media toned
down the rhetoric she was really
stressed so Tamara was coming in
um infrequently different days two three
times sometimes once a day sometimes not
at all she would should disappear
and it's because she was under
tremendous amount of stress uh not only
this class action suit that we were all
uh given we didn't know what to do
everybody was scared and we were being
told we had to behave in a certain way
or else we're going to lose our free
legal advice but at the same time
uh every three seconds she was getting
hounded with another problem here
another problem there and I did
communicate to her and I said Tamara we
need to get you Handler and she didn't
want to she wanted to deal with people
directly which I get that's her strength
she really communicates well with people
um but she I mean you know what decision
fatigue is
I'm she had decision fatigue by early
morning she was just burnt out because
it was so many demands that being put on
her I put a little bit of a moat around
me I had the three people in the comms
team working with me and I said
everything send it to us and we'll
filter it otherwise we won't be able to
to deal with a million problems all at
once but her uh management
structure or system is different than
mine I guess
and and just to further that so she
would come into my room uh to give her a
hug and to relax and calm down the
world's not falling everything's gonna
work out the government's not evil
they're problematic but we have a lot of
love around us and
I just remember we did a bunch of those
little sessions where we focused on all
the good things
so I again I I take it you uh you see
Miss Leach as one of the organizers of
the the Convoy is that correct yeah one
of them Mr Barber one of them is William
uh Miss Belton yeah one of them as well
anyone else who you think was sort of a
key organizer or played an important
role
there's so many people that that I
wouldn't even know because there were so
many I remember I went to a road Captain
meeting
I went and crutched in the snow it's
over to the ark because no one would
come over to me I'm like okay let me
just go sit down with all of them
for 40 people in the room I had no idea
who half those people were but they were
leading different convoys from around
the country it was great they're amazing
people from all over different cultures
of Canada
um so it's it's not a group of two or
three people there were hundreds of
people and then there were all these
other little groups as well it's a very
you know the parallels to bitcoin very
decentralized and uh but I think we had
the greatest what I mentioned before uh
position of moral persuasion that we
could uh help influence people more but
that's not a guarantee and that actually
came up on the 18th when the road
captains came into my hotel after a
trucker had guns drawn out him is they
smashed his windows the police pulled
guns on him arrested him in the snow
Tamara had been arrested Chris had been
arrested the road captains came into my
room there seemed to be I don't know if
a lack of leadership but maybe a lack of
decision making or they needed just
another head to bounce ideas off of
and they told me the story and I said
okay well
I'll support what you guys want to do
but if you're asking me if the police
are getting violent maybe it's time to
leave
and to my surprise the first person to
pipe up was Bridget and she said we
can't let people get hurt we need to
leave and then Joe did the same thing
and all the other Road captains that
were sitting on my bed and standing up
and Johnny and everybody said yeah and I
said okay call your police liaison
officers right now don't argue just tell
them we're gonna leave we're gonna go
we're gonna communicate the message to
everybody that we're gonna leave
um and then I went on to social media
and I did I echoed that sentiment in a
Twitter message that I probably should
have done a thread to clarify it better
but a little bit of a panic
and then Keith Wilson called me and said
you need to leave
I said well I need to I'm in a
wheelchair with a broken ankle what do
you think of the bust down the doors the
hotel and arrest me and uh he said they
just might Keith don't be so dramatic
that's not I'm not on the street but he
argued with me for 20 minutes
and he convinced me he said to me I
always remember he said somebody needs
to be able to speak up for freedom and
if you get arrested too and end up
getting subject to a gag order then you
can't speak
I thought like all right and inside a
friend in Ottawa and uh I called an Uber
I got out of the hotel the Red Zone
which is what the police wanted to clear
out and I went to stay with my friend
until I could get my cast off
um when you arrived in Ottawa were you
aware that Pat King had had involvement
in organizing the travel of the Convoy
across Canada to Ottawa
January 24th or 25th the first day that
Tamara left Ottawa
my social media lights up
and I see some videos from this guy Pat
King
never heard of him
I called Tamara said who's this guy oh
he's some blogger from uh I know
wherever he was I said okay he's got to
go uh we can't have this sort of
rhetoric peace love no no this this is
not for here so I know who he is tell
him he's got to go and there was a lot
there's some back and forth a follow-up
call she can confirmed the videos she
ended up telling him she told me she
told him to leave and he was very upset
but he said fine if I'm not welcome here
I'll go home and I said great nothing
personal but we can't have that sort of
rhetoric here and then the next day or
two I don't know what was going on
behind the scenes because they were
driving across the country I was in
Ontario preparing doing messaging and
she said to me yeah he said he was going
to leave and then he showed up at the
next trucker stop I'm like well
you've got to deal with this I know what
to tell you so and when you talk about
Mr King's rhetoric uh
what what rhetoric
uh I don't know if he was trying to be
comedic I don't know if it was serious
but uh some offensive rhetoric to myself
and uh well not to me personally but to
certain ethnic groups indigenous ethnic
groups Jewish groups whatever
and then I saw the vid first I saw is
bullets I don't know who I just stopped
in the middle I I too much to get rid of
this were you able to see Mr King's
testimony yesterday I did okay and uh
some statements were put to him
including uh statements he made about
indigenous people
um statements uh he made about
Asians is that what you're referring to
uh yes do you remember were those the
social were those the postings that you
saw at the time okay
and I take it and you can correct me if
I'm wrong but you're con uh were you
concerned uh did you did you let me put
it to this way
um
were you concerned about the fact that
the the substance of those statements
did they offend you or were you
concerned about those statements would
be associated with the Convoy or was it
both
I personally don't get offended very
easily I got thick skin and I think
people who say silly things should be
able to say silly things and we should
be able to respond to them I didn't
really care about that I really cared
that he would negatively impact
um the the tenor of the Convoy the mood
of the people it might cause I was
worried that he would cause some
unnecessary anxiety you know when I was
thinking about how are we going to
Envision this protest
a little too personal well personal but
I thought of don't laugh at me I thought
of when I was younger going to Grateful
Dead concerts or fish concerts or Almond
Brothers or Bob Dylan that that Vibe of
peace and love especially the Grateful
Dead without the drugs so I'm not into
drugs and I thought that's that's the
feeling that we need for this protest to
bring everybody together and I was
worried that these sorts this sort of
rhetoric which is completely
inappropriate uh just did not marry to
what we were trying to achieve
so uh and and as as discussed with Mr
King the media reported on some of his
past rhetoric um some of those past
statements
um the media also reported on statements
you had made in the past are you do you
know what I'm talking about uh yes yes
and in in particular there was reports
that uh in in this case from the Global
Mail that at some point in 2018 you gave
a speech to the people part People's
Party of Canada in which you allege that
Isla Islamic front groups were
infiltrating the country's political
institutions and they quote you as
saying quote the adaptation of political
Islam is rotting away at our society
like syphilis do you know the media
report I'm referring to the specific the
Globe and Mail I didn't I don't remember
it's been a few years but yes in general
yeah is that something you said in 2018
yes and I entered my testimony in the
Ontario legislature into evidence in
this hearing where I quoted quoted
numerous
imams that were quite extreme in their
rhetoric about Jews and the gay
community and amongst lgbtori there are
a lot of people that supported us that
were part of our group that were really
concerned about that sort of rhetoric so
I stand by the statements
did you have any concern and I
appreciate you stand by the statements
but you don't even concern about how
those statements might affect the
freedom Convoy given your role in the
Convoy uh no no I didn't
um
as you've noted in uh you provided con
you provided context to those statements
in the legislature is that correct yeah
in the Ontario legislature
um at the time did you take any steps to
contact the media who reporting on those
statements and provide the context you
provided the legislator and now provided
today no I mean I look at during the I
mean my uh skepticism for uh Legacy
Media is quite high and I saw during the
Convoy a headline from the same
newspaper that the truckers are
weaponizing freedom in the name of white
supremacy or something like that I just
kind of at this point I dismiss it all I
really I really encourage you right
the commission has heard a fair bit of
evidence about Mr King's role and we've
spoken about Mr King and also about Mr
James bowder as someone who was involved
in the organization uh in your view how
influential were Mr King and Mr bowder
to the Convoy I don't even know what
James Bater looks like I've never seen
him before
um I so he had some mou thing that was
written in 2019 I thought it was a meme
it was a joke like that's not how people
are serious about litigation and
political change right so I just
dismissed him there was the other guy
Jeremy McKenzie who's been my personal
troll because I'm a Jew for the past
several years and these are all people
that have almost zero following but the
the Legacy Media seems to be wanting to
make these people who have very little
or nothing to do with the Convoy into
celebrities that's why I was really
concerned that in the case of McKenzie
that he's being asked to testify here
why and nothing to do it's not tracker
had nothing to do with the Convoy
there's just rhetoric do we want to make
him famous like I don't get it it makes
no sense to me when you say Mr Mckenzie
was your personal troll can you expand
on that
yeah he um
uh he see has made several comments
throughout the years about Jewish
conspiracy theories he I I laughingly
say he makes Mel Gibson look like a
rabbi
he is really really aggressive towards
Jews whatever that's fine I don't really
care and while I was producing a podcast
several years ago this woman who is a a
Saudi Refugee who grew up over under
extremism she was a doctor and moved to
Canada
and he was harassing her online he was
harassing me online like this is what he
does apparently that's comedy whatever
fine do you think what Mr McKenzie does
as comedy no
what do you think it is
I think we we're leaving this era where
there are people they when they want to
when they say something that is uh
extreme rhetoric then they say oh it's
just comedy but when it's you know
digestible then they say oh I'm this is
serious they want it both ways
um and I think he kind of he goes in
that category and that's why these
people have such small followings but
again there are Personalities in the
media that want to elevate these uh
these individuals it just makes no sense
when people say oh they have you know 20
000 followers firstly that's not very
much and secondly yeah he would have two
if it weren't for you keep talking about
him the Streisand Effect right
foreign
now and we we got we got to it already a
bit but I just have a few more questions
about the agreement that was reached
between Miss Leach and the mayor and and
uh some of the events that surrounding
that so
um
the the the mayor and Miss Leach
exchanged letters on February 12th
um on February 13th there was a news
report that came out saying that the
agreement that was reflected in those
letters had been reached and then if we
could pull up com831
questions
and so this is a tweet from your Twitter
account if we can scroll down you can
see the timing just so we can scroll
down to the bottom from 8 24 pm
and if we could scroll up
it says more fake and this is you're
referencing the the media report I
referenced says more fake news this time
from City TV News No Deal has been
struck the federal government has not
yet lifted its mandates and passports do
not watch hashtag fakes news it's bad
for your mental health this is
completely false
why did you send that tweet
from the original time that I was told
by Keith that he's going to reach out to
the the city I mentioned before and he
said why just wait for the government to
the you know whether they will come to
us
uh but no just went over my head went
over my sense from the rest of the board
is that they felt the same way Maybe I'm
Wrong maybe they told him differently
but that was not my sense so throughout
uh that week I would yeah maybe tease
Keith a little bit we actually had a
pretty good working relationship which
is why I was shocked yesterday
and um I would say to him so Teeth Keith
how's the deal gone and he would say uh
well not not great and on February the
13th uh I did the same thing I said to
Keith uh how's the deal going and he
says not great so either he was lying to
me or he was lying in this scenario I
don't know and then that night I went on
to I was starting to go into Twitter
spaces to communicate with people
and I just got uh destroyed sorry I got
attacked by a couple of thousand people
in a Twitter space you're a bunch of
sellouts Randy Hillier put out a tweet
so I I don't know if you can't convince
Randy Hillier Tom morato's buddy that we
have a deal that how have we convinced
the city or anybody else there's a deal
but okay fine
and so I sent a message to Keith the
following morning
and I said Keith I just got attacked
last night I think I got everybody
calmed down and whatever what's the
status of this deal so I can put an end
to it I can't remember how I worded it
exactly and he said neither Eva nor
myself have drafted anything for the
city more rumors
okay
so everything is the same as I've been
told the entire way throughout the fine
so if we if we could pull a bjd uh
six zeros one seven
and this is a document that you provided
to the commission I believe yesterday
okay yeah
what was the date of the Tweet we just
saw is that February 13th at 8 24 pm
so I must have the wrong number
um
perhaps I I I think we have the message
you're referring to um I I don't have
the number now it maybe have an
opportunity to show it to you and
confirm that's the message but so you uh
you had a text exchange with Mr Wilson
or a messaging and Signal yeah signal
exchange with Mr Wilson on the 14th when
you said what's going on and he said
there's been been nothing with the mayor
and again we will when we have the
opportunity we'll pull that up
um my question for you now is
between when you read the news article
that you tweeted about and when you
tweeted about it
did you ask anyone
whether the news article was true or
make any inquiries about the news
article no just just out of time being
overwhelmed with stuff and you know I
already communicated my skepticism on
Legacy Media and I'm getting it directly
from the source I'm getting it from our
lawyers who's Telling Me No Deal I mean
I know that right but your lawyer told
you that on the 14th not on the 13th
when you tweeted it out no no what I say
I spoke to him on the 13th oh sorry
that's before so during the I did
another so how's that deal going and he
says not so good okay fine and went late
at night into the Twitter space and then
we had to reconfirm it again the next
day so that conversation you had with Mr
Wilson on the 13th was that in writing
or was that no face to face I think it
was in my hotel room if I'm not mistaken
or the adjacent room we were always in
and out
um I would sometimes go to the other
hotel rooms Tamara's and the others or
they would come to me
and then if we could pull up
com841
thank you
so the first uh your Tweet which uh is
is there uh says more fake news from
City TV No Deal has been struck and then
we see this is a retweet by Tamara Leach
uh or sorry from Miss Leach's account
which I think is an important
distinction as we get to uh three
minutes later uh in which uh Miss
Leach's account says the media lies to
their viewers no quote deal has been
made and the mend dates and the
passports that's why we are here
um
the commission is has heard and received
evidence that it you had access to Mr
Miss Leach's Twitter account and that
you were the one who made this too well
from the very beginning yeah she asked
me to take over that she didn't know
Twitter very much she did Facebook so
you deal with Twitter
fair enough and did you did the new do
this retweet from her account yes and it
was very important because what was
happening this remember I explained
earlier I was trying to go for peace
love unity and whatever and there seemed
to be another counter narrative that was
creating anxiety and people were
starting to attack Tamara myself
everybody your sellout I never got my
money for gas what do you do you could
see the tenor already of frustration was
building up so I needed to communicate
to everybody no relax nothing has
changed if it is we'll let you know kind
of was my my thought but you could
already see the anxiety being ramped up
and I the last thing we could have was
any sort of conflict and violence and
that's what I that's why I was trying to
Echo that statement until we get
something substantive if we got a deal
in writing and said here we are okay
fine that's a different story but uh
that never materialized
you were in regular contact with Miss
Leach oh yeah that's for sure is there
any reason you didn't speak with her
before you sent out this tweet
now because we had a communication teams
of myself and two other people so all
the comms were amongst us
um on the you know the Twitter side
which became a primary platform that we
were using
and you know if we were doing that on
every little tweet then we would get
nothing done and Tamara didn't have much
interest in Twitter I noticed
was it that day with around that time
like she would do a positive good
morning message I saw those would pop up
periodically so she had access to the
accounts as well right
and
um but that's about it and I guess
because she was overloaded she was
dealing with so many other things and
she was I think primarily on Facebook if
I'm not mistaken which I was not
so Mr commissioner I've come in my time
if I could have five more minutes just
to address one more uh document and then
one more item okay and uh we'll come
back to that one document you wouldn't
yes yeah
foreign
actually why don't we do that document
right now so it's bjd18 I was one digit
off my apologies Mr dictator
hi
so on the screen uh this uh this appears
to be a message uh you've provided to us
I take it this is the message that you
sent Mr Wilson on Signal yeah and then
if we scroll down we have his response
yeah is that what you were referring to
yes okay
um
Mr Wilson has uh both given testimony
and also uh had an interview with the
commission
um and in his interview Mr Wilson stated
that uh you were at least to his
understanding aware that an agreement
had been reached uh with the mayor
between the mayor and Tamara and he
expressed some surprise uh that you uh
that you sent your Tweet and Tamara's
retweet and specifically Mr Wilson has
uh
uh identified this the following
document as evidencing that knowledge uh
hrf
1491
hrf401491
so we'll scroll down you'll see that
um this is February 12th at 3 47 in the
afternoon
um Mr Wilson writes you
uh the middle paragraph says hence the
drafting committee will keep working on
the broader document for review by the
board tomorrow but in the meantime below
is a draft communication for the
captains truckers specific to the
mayor's arrangements to allow you to
advance into Wellington and Elgin will
at the same time taking away the excuse
that Trudeau wants to unleash the police
goons and seize trucks
remember we are trying to block Trudeau
from having the justification to cause
the police to use the new emergency
Powers against the truckers and to allow
the truckers to stay here in Ottawa for
as long as it takes Etc then if you
scroll up
sorry to the top
you then replied
shortly afterwards saying looks good to
me
what did you understand Mr Wilson to be
talking about in his email when you
responded looks good to me this was a
communication to the premier's office
was my understanding is that they were
going to be drafting something for Doug
Ford they're making some Headway with
him
and that's how it was communicate okay
fine good to me if we get a response
they want they're finally going to talk
to us on the provincial level that's
progress
in Mr Wilson's email he says
below is a draft communication for the
captain slash truckers specific to the
mayor's arrangement to allow us to
advance into Wellington and Elgin what
did you understand that to me uh the in
terms of the mayor's arrangement I don't
know I don't know the details because
again everything was opaque that I
wasn't told any specifics or details
whatsoever
did you take any steps to learn what Mr
Wilson was talking about in that email
no this is what I was trying to do as I
explain with the messaging not step on
everybody's toes this is the drafting or
the legal committee okay fine you're
going to do it you can if you bring have
something signed whatever send it to me
when you have something prepared and
whatever and let me know
my final question for you Mr dikter is
you referenced
um that you had a good working
relationship with Mr Wilson and you were
surprised uh by his testimony yesterday
other than what we've spoken about is
there anything else that surprised you
yeah well there was one caveat which I
started to you know people say things
and you put the red flag up in the back
your head
so with the class action suit there were
um the injunctions emotions put forward
and whatever okay we already
signed off with him in the jccf turns
out a retainers with the jccf they were
going to go okay fine
and he came back and he said to me and
all of us individually but you remember
saying to me okay so I have good news
we got a number of items that the class
action suit uh wanted the people on the
The complaintants Wanted and they've all
been rejected
uh like with one exception
the one exception is the horn honking
has to be limited in scope into one
designated area and I said to them
here's about the horn honking like
that's not what we're here for we're
here for mandates whatever
and that's how he communicated it to me
and that that was it so then what I
didn't tell him
is I took that document and I sent it to
a friend of mine who is a legal
researcher at a firm
and I said this is what I was told this
document says I don't read legalese can
you just interpret it because he's
saying that the media is lying that we
actually won what is your interpretation
and she said to me I don't know who's
telling you uh you won they wanted the
uh the horns stopped or whatever that
was the part of the injunction
and they won so whoever's telling you
you won is not being honest with you and
I thought
is he just overselling it because he's
trying to be compassionate and he knows
we're under a lot of stress
or was it uh just dishonest I don't know
I tried to give him the benefit of the
doubt at that time and maybe he's just
trying to be supportive in some sort of
way
thank you those are my questions thank
you very much
okay uh commissioner sorry yes
would I be able to submit my application
for rule 59 to have
some more leading testimony from my uh
for my lawyer the normal is your lawyer
will do it at the end and that's when I
would do it I mean I unless there's any
particular reason to do it now
um I would suggest we do it at the end
which is the normal if if uh Mr
commissioner if you're going to make us
pick between now or the end I think
you're right the end is better I think
what Mr Victor is suggesting that I'd be
able to ask a couple questions now
leading questions and at the end I have
the opportunity to close the non-leading
question as per rule 59.
and how long do you propose to be
um at this time of five minutes
five minutes of some leading questions
yes okay are there any objections or
concerns
so uh oh sorry I do have a concern
um perhaps I had misunderstood
so for the witness who is not a party
now wants to ask him leading questions
is that is that what I'm understanding
yeah see he's we I denied the the right
uh or the right the uh the application
to have his counsel lead the evidence
and now he seeks to have five minutes to
do that there may be some additional at
the end
um and so that's what it's it's being
proposed and that they would be leading
questions for five minutes
so I guess I would opposed it because if
he was not given standings and I
questioned why he's allowed to examine
his uh clients and I guess further to
that if he is allowed to examine his
client why would he be allowed to ask
him reading questions
so Mr commissioner uh just for your
assistance and for the assistance of the
the parties and the public uh I'll rule
I just want to read what read the rule
59 says so rule 59 says that if a
representative for a witness intends to
reduce evidence in Chief not induced by
commission counsel the representative
will examine the witness immediately
following commission Council and then
we'll have a right to re-examine the
witness following questions by the other
parties there is no reference to Leading
or non-leading in the rule
okay so
um with that clarification I suppose he
can ask his questions now but I would
suggest that what's contemplated and
what's fair is that the questions be
asked in a non-leading fashion obviously
it's not the right to process
okay well I I guess it's uh there's some
uncertainty in the rule uh what a
surprise
um so uh
I think what I'll do is I will let the
questions go and if there's a problem
we'll deal with them
but I think it's preferable to get that
evidence out so before the parties do
their cross-examination thank you Mr
commissioner I'd like to point
um the witness to bjd 40. sorry okay
sorry BRB 40.
my mistake
foreign
yes I do that is the group one of the
group chats in Signal where we were
communicating myself Tamara the lawyers
the board
and what
um who was part of this group chat uh
like I said most of the board that were
involved Chad uh Keith Wilson Eva Tamara
um
uh Chris Cara like all of us were in it
and this Echoes uh the same sentiment
of the other text message
um
you made a statement in that group chat
on uh February 14th at 6 51 A.M
talking about how
um you're being accused of certain
things from supporters on your Twitter
space the night before or early morning
depending on how you look at it 1am
what was the response to your
um if we can scroll down we can see a
response to Mr Victor's statement there
can you read that out for the commission
yeah from Tamara I haven't seen any
statement yet so don't worry about
meeting at nine if I hear anything I
will let you know where was uh Mrs Leach
uh staying during the protest uh the
Sheridan where were you staying during
the protest in the Sheridan
what floor were you on
the 16th floor what floor was she on
I think the 14th but I might have that
wrong how often do you guys see each
other uh frequently there were a couple
of days where she wasn't around but
frequently
she ever mentioned to you in those
frequent interactions
that she was working on or had reached
any kind of deal with the mayor no and
if uh if she did I forgotten it but I
don't think I would forget that and and
this uh exchange on the group chat seems
to confirm that that's right
um Mr commissioner am I allowed to ask
about the email hrf 1491 that Mr Mather
was asking Mr Victor about just now a
different uh aspect of the uh content if
you like so far you haven't been leading
so hrf 1491 try avoiding leading and
that makes it easier
I'll do my best
if we can scroll down this was
referenced in Mr Wilson's testimony
yesterday uh he suggested to the
commission that this was your sign off
on a deal
can you read the first sentence or line
of the first sentence of the second
paragraph of this email from Mr Wilson
uh hence the drafting committee will
keep working on the broader document for
review by the board tomorrow but in the
meantime below is a draft communication
for the captain's truck or specific to
the mayor's arrangement to allow us to
advance into Welling Street and Elgin
while at the same time taking away the
excuse that Trudeau wants to unleash the
police goons and seize trucks
did a draft communication ever follow no
did you receive any other email
not that I'm aware of no can we scroll
down to the attachment that was with
this email
can you have a quick review of this
attachment document
Mr Victor
yeah
[Music]
let me know when you're done
does this look like
a
document
that's a deal or a contract between two
parties
uh no well that was my whole point
there's no witness signature date
nothing it's just
the letter what is this like in your
experience as a Communications person
what is this document public relations
like a press release
okay
if um I can ask the attention uh the
commission to pull up a document that
I'm bjd 12
it's an article in the Toronto Sun
talking about
um Dean French working on a deal
if we can scroll down to I think the
fourth page
some text uh maybe go up
um okay down sorry the next line in the
article
um
maybe it's page three sorry to have you
fishing
there's an article in this uh document
Mr Victor have you seen this article yes
I have
where Mr French gives his public
perspective
yes and he's critical protest and he
says
on page six of the document I don't
believe in protesting or honking on
residential streets
do you know who Dean French is
uh he is Doug Ford's former Chief of
Staff and uh friend since the 1990s
how did he end his tenure as a chief of
staff to the premier uh he resigned in
disgrace
did you read or hear
um
the mayor's testimony on Dean French yes
and I was confused when he thought he
was a credible person that he could
reach out to
and the other problem is how do you have
somebody negotiating on behalf of the
truckers who's not a trucker who's
connected to the premier's office who's
critical of the trucking protest
former Chief slowly testified that
the mood on the ground was a powder kick
if the truckers
heard that their interests were being
represented
by the first Chief of Staff of the
Premier who was responsible for most the
mandates in Ontario at a provincial
level
how would the mood of
changed on the ground or did it change
when reports came out that it was Dean
French talking to the mayor and Mr
Wilson and Mr marazzo that's where you
saw some of the conflict and I can
understand where Chief slowly might have
interpreted the Powder Keg issue because
again I said before the mixed messages
you want to go to a trucker and say hey
yeah the guy who brought in your
provincial mandates uh he's negotiating
a deal for you guys to leave which is
not a deal that's capitulation a deals
both sides get something and we would
have gotten nothing that would have
these are the sorts of things that were
causing so much anxiety and division
furthermore you know the first week was
really stressful we were overloaded we
had far more people than we imagined
would be here and it took about a week
to get everybody
finally on the organizational side of
all the different groups slowly to talk
together or at least decide go your
separate ways in some scenarios
and then this started and the level of
distrust all of a sudden came back again
okay I think your time is up Mr Carl
leaves so uh I'm I'm
gonna ask you to wrap up this part of
your uh
your question
you asked for five minutes I've already
given you much more am I allowed one
more question Mr commissioner thank you
uh you mentioned a War of the Worlds
video you mentioned dealing with
a Jordan Peterson podcast I think
talking about how we're not here to
overtake the government specifically is
the War of the Worlds video that you're
talking about
um
uh submitted a video of Mr Wilson bjd8
and the uh reason that you felt you
needed to explain that you guys weren't
here
uh was in response to the February 8th
press conference of Tom marazzo correct
that's right
um Mr Wilson yesterday testified that
when he met Tom marazzo
he was very impressed with his calm
demeanor
uh I'll ask the commission to pull up
um
a video bjd 17 it's 20 seconds starting
at 3 40.
Mama Rosa wrong
40 because it's a long uh video
I live in my car
I lost everything and you guys won't
even shut your mouth for two minutes and
let me get some sense into your heads
just stop just stop
check your ego okay
I'm sure Mrs Ms zexy Lee be very proud
of Mr marazzo talking about supporters
I'm sure you're here to give evidence Mr
Victor
um
um uh what can you say about Mr
marazzo's demeanor in the context of Mr
Wilson saying yesterday
I think we're going to close this off at
the moment uh you I gave you a question
you've done more so we'll okay put off
if we can deal with further questioning
at the end if need be okay
so we'll take the morning break and come
back in 15 minutes
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
questions
order a lot
the commission is reconvened like
commissary
okay so now we're ready to get started
on the cross-examinations
uh for the government of Canada first
please
thank you Mr commissioner good afternoon
Mr Victor
my name is Andrea Gonzalez I'm one of
the lawyers for the government of Canada
um
so as I've understood your evidence Mr
Victor you were the spokesperson and
really generally media relations person
for the freedom Convoy correct yeah we
had a team of three of three other
people and myself and I led the team you
were one of the directors of the
corporation yes I was
um and do you have a any formal training
degree or professional experience in
Communications media relations anything
of that sort no I don't have a degree in
Communications but I work for companies
previously that basically taught me
General
Media Communications owned a business
for many years had to deal with it so
I've been in media in and out of media
for business purposes for quite some
time and you do your own media
yeah yeah for instance you've got a book
that's set to be released next week that
you're promoting through your own
website uh yes I actually
um wrote that book with a friend of mine
who was a journal an investigative
journalist for the Toronto Star for 30
years
and a published author and I said to
John I said I don't know how to write a
book but can you teach me and can we do
this project together and it was amazing
to have somebody in my life who
understood the process of investigative
journalism to build a framework a
timeline all that sort of stuff so we
could get the story out factually as it
was and not just my story the story of
other people involved in the Convoy and
during the period of the protests
when you spoke or when you approved
Publications on behalf of the freedom
Convoy uh those were you were speaking
on behalf of the group that the freedom
Convoy represented right that was the
attempt so there were many other uh
ancillary groups that were attached and
what not
um you know you can't speak for
everybody you do your best to find a
message that will resonate with all
sorts of people and as you know as
you've seen by some of the people here
they're quite enthusiastic uh sometimes
they were upset
that the uh the tenor was it was not as
enthusiastic as they wanted so there was
a balancing act with a different uh
personalities involved
um right and you've you've said
previously you couldn't control the
truckers you couldn't control the
protesters well I think we were in a
position uh and primarily because of the
success of the GoFundMe and the
subsequent uh gifts and go where we had
the highest degree of moral persuasion
so if there was a representative of the
government that came to speak with us we
would be in a unique position that would
be easier for us to sell whatever
settlement idea that agreement we would
come to with the government it might
take a little bit of time and for
example I mentioned on February 18th
when the uh the road captains were in my
room
and they they agreed with me saying yeah
it's time to leave the government is
getting violent and Miranda piped up and
she said yeah but Ben some of these
people are not going to want to leave
and I said
that's your job as a road Captain to
convince them and persuade them to leave
if you need me to help we'll try and get
everybody to get on board with us so Mr
doctor I've only got a limited amount of
time okay um and what I've put to you is
a simple question that you have said in
the past in fact you've sworn an
affidavit it's in our documents jcf six
zeros14 where you said I do not control
the truckers and other participants in
the current protest in Ottawa you recall
saying that in an affidavit yeah control
and moral persuasion are two different
things and I asked you about control so
I just want to make sure we're talking
about the same thing no nobody controls
anybody of course right and um do you
recall speaking at a press conference on
January 30th uh sure yeah
um we have a transcript of that it's
com50895
um it's a transcript as I understand of
a video that has been prepared by
commission Council okay
have you had an opportunity to read that
transcript I skimmed through most as
much as I could in the past 24 hours
it's been hard
um but you would have no no
concerns about the accuracy of that
transcript from what I've seen so far no
I'm okay
um and uh
we can put it up if you need your memory
refresh but you said it that
um press conference at that that there
were so many truckers you lost track
right yeah
um and the various participants in the
protest had a variety of viewpoints
objectives demands Fair
no I think what we all we all agreed on
was arrive can and the mandates
everybody has all sorts of uh grievances
with the government uh but we had one
unifying grievance which was the arrive
can and the mandates which is what we
were here for and everybody kind of
understood that right that was the
Baseline and then there were others who
wanted
more there were some to your knowledge
you know that were um interested in a
change of government
and
again uh not the Convoy there's may
people might have said things
incorrectly uh people might have given
that impression there's always Fringe
elements uh in these sorts of events and
uh but that's not what we were about
from the very beginning when you say the
freedom Convoy you're talking about that
organization where you're one of the
board of directors you've spoken about
some others involved and those who
subscribe to that messaging and we're
following that group correct well there
was the board but everybody you know you
could see is evidence online that
everybody saw themselves as participants
of the freedom Convoy that that's how
they viewed all of this and the board
itself the the name we settled on was
Freedom 2022 human rights Freedom
organization and there were others such
as Mr King who participated in the
protest he had followers they had
different objectives and Views correct
well Mr King has a very small social
media following I heard some of the
numbers he threw out and I went online
and I know analytics and he has nowhere
near that sort of and he's got 3 000
followers online
uh which is why it's odd that we keep
focusing on him when on the 25th of
January I said to Tamara 25th or 24th
whichever day she left I can't remember
uh he's got to go and we had that back
and forth and she ultimately agreed with
me and then we released a press release
it was our first update to the GoFundMe
and it stated that Pat King represents
only himself he does not represent the
freedom Convoy and that stayed up there
for quite some time
um and I know the document you're
talking about it's gfm seven zeros
and a one
um and that uh
update to the GoFundMe page
in distancing the freedom Convoy from
Pat King you felt that was
that was important to pursuing the
objectives that you you and those you
were aligned with to get people in the
framework of peace love unity and
freedom yes we needed to ensure that
people didn't get confused that the
government didn't get confused and the
government could understand that we were
reasonable people that they could speak
with and they wouldn't get that
impression with that sort of rhetoric
which is why we all were quite concerned
about it and wanted it not to be in one
not to be involved
um and the uh these concerns about
what uh was being
um
seen on the part of the protesters
um this in fact prompted you to put out
a number of public statements distancing
uh the freedom Convoy from violence
correct of course yeah of course and
that had to be done
repeatedly
um for example there's a Sun article on
January 26
com5067
630-630 there was an uh official daily
event and safety report put out on
January 27th hrf708
um and in fact could we put that
document up on the screen
foreign
is this the type of document that would
have been approved through you or one of
the other three working on
Communications uh no this was produced
by Tom quiggan uh who's the intelligence
analyst but the reason we needed to put
these messages out to answer your
question it wasn't because of the
peoples because of the Legacy Media that
was putting out a narrative that was
completely false about these Phantom
violent people that I never saw and so
we had to put these things out to and
and we saw by the text message in this
testimony from the prime minister's
office that they were doing exactly what
I thought they were doing again I'm
going to ask you to just focus yourself
on on my question all I did was ask
whether you approved these messages
before they went out uh these the daily
safety reports no that was
and if we go down maybe on the second
page bullet number 10
Convoy organizers are developing an
internal intelligence capability to
identify potential sources of violence a
separate report on identifying violent
groups slash individuals will follow and
if that's going out in the name of the
freedom Convoy it's being represented as
something true and accurate correct uh
yes it also has the word potential right
now
um
the
objective As I understood it uh from the
GoFundMe page of the freedom Convoy was
to stay in Ottawa until all mandates
were lifted yes
um you understand sir you do legal
podcasts you're a former candidate for
Parliament that the federal government
does not have the jurisdictional
authority to lift all mandates in Canada
right Federal mandates yes well no
um the wording of the GoFundMe page was
all mandates I want to make sure we're
on the same page that the best the
federal government could do was lift
Federal mandates right yeah we knew if
the federal government lifted their
mandates and the pro the provinces would
follow and in fact the opposite happened
the province dropped all their mandates
and the federal government held on to it
until last month and sir you didn't know
that that was something you hoped would
happen right I think it was a good
educated guess understanding how
government works yeah
but fair to say there was
misunderstanding on the part of at least
some participants about
what the federal government could do
with respect to all mandates and there
were times when you found yourself in
the messaging ensuring that it didn't uh
give the impression that the freedom
Convoy was asking the federal government
to do that which it had no authority to
do right
get to ask that again yeah sure I'll
break it down
um there was
misunderstanding by at least some
participants in the protests as to these
you know Notions of jurisdiction and
what the federal government could or
couldn't do oh there's definitely people
in society who need some education in
Civics there's no question but in terms
of people who are leading organizations
and groups uh within our board we
understood that it was the Federal
mandate because that's the Mandate that
we're destroying truckers careers their
businesses and their jobs because they
couldn't cross the border
and so I've seen in the documents I
don't have time to take you to them that
there were times where you had to ensure
that the messaging was refined to not
lead the impression that the freedom
Convoy was trying to get the federal
government to revoke all mandates
right it was to it was to remove the the
federal mandates for sure and the
federal mandates would lead to all
mandates that was our optimistic
assumption and I think evidenced by what
happened on the provincial levels that
was probably a good assumption and you
you
um were asked in that January 30th press
conference that we talked about yeah
um about whether there was any point to
trying to get the federal government to
lift the Mandate on truckers crossing
the border because there was a parallel
restriction in place on the U.S side you
remember that
uh yes but the sorry I'm before you go
on
um I just want to clarify that
you you did in that press conference
um say acknowledge that fact but say
that you understood
that the U.S restriction had been
adopted at the request of the Canadians
come here first and the U.S never
enforced it
but that's what I want to make sure
we're both clear on the U.S mandate was
announced first right it was a no it was
announced after it was the Canadian
mandates that were announced first from
what I remember okay well
um I think the evidence is different on
that but I'll leave it there could be
um
and so
when you and the freedom Convoy say we
are in this for the long haul you recall
using that statement at times yeah
um
you were not
willing to leave until your demands were
met Fair
I was reflecting the um I was freaking
reflecting the sentiment of the truckers
that were coming here it wasn't BJ's
decided we're gonna stay here uh
permanently it's the truckers that
assembled their convoys and there were
so many convoys we couldn't keep track
they all agreed and that was their
sentiment I was trying to reflect the
sentiment of them for the government so
they would understand which was odd that
there are people in the city of Ottawa
that said oh they're going to be here
for two days okay
um and your understanding is that that
group
um would not be prepared to leave Ottawa
these were committed dedicated
individuals to their cause yes
as you understood it
and they were not going to leave Ottawa
until
they had accomplished their goals right
well I think at least if we start with
somebody from the government who would
hear them because what this protest was
this was a cry for help
and they felt completely alienated and
Abandoned and they were losing
everything they had and this was a an
act of desperation Mr commissioner I'm
one minute over my 15 minutes could I
have another five please
the circumstances I'll give you another
five thank you and generally reasonable
thank you
um
and so we've heard you give some
evidence about
the
agreement the deal between Ms Leach and
mayor Watson
um
and
uh the the tweets and your understanding
of that series of events and just to
confirm you you did come to understand
that there was an exchange of letters
um that set out
an understanding at a minimum a deal as
to what would happen for there to be a
sit down between the mayor and
representatives of the freedom Convoy
you understand that yes from what I
understand there was attempts to
communicate I didn't know at the time
nobody told me that people connected to
Doug Ford's office were involved in that
communication
um and
brought you discussed
Wilson's connections with those events
this morning
um who did you understand Mr Wilson's
client or clients was in the course of
these dealings well Mr Wilson told me it
was that we were his client but the
retainers was with the jccf
I didn't say anything because my mother
is a paralegal so I know some of the
basics I knew that retainer was not
legitimate but I didn't even bother to
pursue the matter because there were so
many other things on our problem and we
needed we were desperate for free legal
advice and that just became a nuanced
argument that maybe we'll figure it out
in the future
foreign
did you ever see the letters that were
exchanged between Ms Leach and mayor
Watson no to this day you've not seen
those oh no oh no I have yeah now you
have but not at the time yeah
um and so I gather you did not make any
efforts yourself
try and get those who were parked in the
residential areas of Ottawa to move
their trucks in accordance with this
with this exchange of letters yeah no
that was my understanding with Tom Razzo
where he said I'm gonna deal with the
trucks and I said great I'll deal with
the messaging and the next day he's
doing a press conference but I I didn't
want there's so many things I had to
deal with and I didn't want to step on
other people's toes that's what I was
trying to do
and you never approved any sort of
official written communication from the
freedom Convoy uh to its group of
followers saying we need to leave the
downtown residential core there's a deal
with the mayor that we need to make sure
we comply no no if that anything came
out under the freedom Corp logo I was
completely circumvented in that and not
told about it
okay thank you for the Indulgence Mr
commissioner those are my questions okay
thank you
next is uh the Convoy organizers
Mr Victor Brennan Miller I'm counsel for
Freedom Corp I've been watching you for
a few weeks nice to meet you
so just a couple of things I want to get
uh some things clarified here you
haven't been very clear with dates about
when things happen so I want to get that
hammered down is that okay sure all
right I understand on February 4th 2022
or maybe it was the third uh you were in
a car accident out in Kingston you ended
up in a ditch is that right
I ended up in a ditch in a tree on
February 3rd and 45 minutes later I was
in Tim Hortons doing an interview on
Stephen Crowder okay and so uh you were
in Kingston and then I take it you got
in back okay
sorry in Campville and then you got back
to Ottawa uh the evening of February 4th
is that fair uh no February 3rd February
3rd yeah I was picked up by a friend who
came to rescue me
after the interview to get back into
Ottawa right and then was it the third
or the fourth where you broke your leg
the fourth the fourth so February 4th
and
after you broke it like I take it you
were in the hospital for a brief period
of time or were you I got out of the
hospital the next morning at seven
o'clock in the morning I don't remember
much of that day because of delighted
and all the medication but Midway
through the day I started at least to
become aware and got back to slowly
working through media and stuff like
that okay so February 5th you get out of
the hospital
no no I was out of the hospital on
February uh yeah sorry February 5th yeah
the morning February 5th so morning
February 5th so you get out of the
hospital and your legs broken I
understand it was a pretty bad break eh
still hurts so much right and so you
said just now you were on a bunch of
medication is that correct yep for 24
hours yeah and what was that uh
deloitted okay
and I take it then after that you would
have still been on some form of pain
medication would you not oh just Advil
okay
and so after that time so after February
4th uh you're pretty restricted mobile
wise you stayed in your essentially in
your hotel room for most of the time
right yeah okay so you weren't out on
the street talking to anybody or
anything like that I tried to go out
every Sunday and I did to when Pastor
Hildebrand did his service
uh there was the Lubavitch Jewish
community that wanted to see me for
whatever reason so I would go every
Sunday uh the pastors would give their
service and started the first weekend me
Tamara and Chris were on stage and my
idea was we have to be here every Sunday
to thank everybody for coming out and
supporting us okay so I did that but
other than that you were pretty much
confined to your room right it was
confined to the hotel I did go manage to
go to one meeting at the ark when my leg
was broken that was the meeting with all
the road captains there was like 40 of
them in there
um one of the people working with me
said it would be a good sentiment even
though you can't so I did yeah right and
you weren't a road Captain right no no
right okay
and so it's fair to say that from
February 4th onward you weren't really
on the street talking physically uh in
their presence to any of the truckers
right
uh no but I had the person who was
assisting me on messaging she was going
to the arc hotel in the Swiss Hotel
meetings every morning keeping me up to
date I was in communication with Tamara
and the group over signal so there was
no lack of communication there and then
I had two friends that had come up well
friends one's a recorder and another
friend who came up to Toronto and so he
came up to Ottawa we're staying sleeping
over in the adjacent suite and they were
going out to the groups talking to
people bringing people back to the hotel
like that's how I managed so in this
individual you were saying was keeping
you up to date other than Tamara you
said you had somebody in Communications
working with you who was that his name
is Salman SEMA he is a an activist from
Iran okay thank you and you'd said in
your evidence in Chief that uh Miss
litch was constantly coming to your room
every day and that was happening on time
there were a few days that she
disappeared I remember one day I
couldn't get a hold of her all day and
you had to see the stress that she was
under uh I I really sympathized with her
right so she went to Quebec for example
a day and she got back to me at six
seven o'clock that happened a few times
but whenever she was in the hotel uh we
would see each other fairly frequently
and I take it that frequency of seeing
her it declined after February 7th would
you agree
uh no I don't I wouldn't agree okay I
saw her at the the my promo video is me
her giving me a hug the day that she was
arrested I'm not saying that you didn't
see her I'm saying the frequency that
you would see her from February 7th on
declined would you agree
I I don't remember it that way but it
could be because so much was going on
did you know that uh basically everyone
other than yourself and Chris Barber had
checked out of the Sheraton on February
7th 2023 and we're staying at the Swiss
I know there was a lot of jocking around
with hotel rooms because we were getting
death threats we went to the ark to the
Sheridan and I know she left did she
leave the Sheridan to Swiss it might be
but everybody was around and I know
Dagny was there with him every morning
and telling me was going on but you can
agree then that Miss Lynch wasn't
staying in the same hotel as you from
February 7th onward can you agree with
that that could be that could be
it's also remember
she had a hotel room every we had so
many different hotel rooms you know I
was in four or five hotel rooms that
were Tamara's I don't know if any new
which hotel room belonged to who it was
just a block of hotel rooms it didn't
really matter okay you know whose room
was whose right all of these folks they
had to basically come and see you
because you were confined to your room
uh I would go to the other rooms when
they're around so there was also a board
room on the 16th floor if I remember
that I went up to for a couple of
meetings
um so communication was there like it
wasn't you know so I want to take you to
February 11th uh 2022. okay uh you knew
about that meeting that was taking place
between uh the members of the board and
Dean French and the mayor or through the
mayor you knew about that on that day I
didn't know about that you didn't no
you're saying you didn't know about it
though I heard Dean French's name in one
of the there was a a news article I
didn't know the the capacity added at
the time now I do
uh I didn't know the details of it again
everything was opaque it was Keith we're
gonna go do a deal yeah with the city so
there was a a board meeting that you
couldn't attend around that time
um you attended by phone conference
because you were in your room do you
remember that no I don't you don't well
they had a meeting you were in
attendance uh according to our records
and this was all discussed it was on
phone or Zoom or you called in everyone
else was there physically it was at the
Swiss and you called in I don't remember
you don't remember no okay well that's
going to be testified too so I have to
be fair to you no no fair enough right
and so all of this was discussed before
the deal that was discussed with the
mayor everybody knew about it and you're
saying you didn't
no all right so the deal
um as I explained before when Keith said
we're going to reach out to the city I
questioned that strategy and the board
was willing to reach out to the city I
said uh I don't agree and I got no
specifics in terms of what they were
going to do because a deal is what
leaving how is that a deal
so the board the majority of the board
didn't agree with you
Fair
uh oh okay right and you were eventually
removed from this board is this correct
uh this was after yes yeah well after
right and you wanted to want to know why
well I'm gonna get into that
um and some of the animosity that arose
was that the board had voted to do all
these things
enter into these agreements then you
broke into or went into Miss lich's
twit Twitter or tweet account or
whatever they're called broke into well
you went into it and pretending to be
her the entire time right as she asked
me but you posted something that you
knew was a lie no you knew that they had
done this deal you knew there's no deal
no commissioner object I think the
questions are getting a little
argumentative and accusing the witness
of lying I don't think that's the role
yeah I hear your objection but I think
this is cross-examination and I'll give
some latitude
right now so you're saying before you
went in
to her account representing to the
public at large I didn't go into her
account I was using her account from the
very beginning and the account is linked
to her cell phone number right if they
didn't want me to be using it which was
never told to me guess what you could
just tell me you don't want to use it
which was never communicated no one on
the board and no one else told you to do
that you did that on your own initiative
no Tamara told everybody in the board
all comms go through Benjamin yeah I'm
not I'm I'm not asking about that I'm
asking about that no but this is an
important but this is important I
understand she was telling me everything
goes through him right that's nice and
so that gave you the prerogative to go
on to her Twitter and make something up
and say that didn't make something else
I think this is just getting into
argument and I think he's answered the
question so
after this deal goes through and some of
the trucks did get moved you're aware of
that then why did Keith tell me the
deal's not going well I'm sorry right he
asked you about right okay tracks
formally so let's try and focus on you
answer the question
and we'll get through this and so you
did get that email with the with the
comms
essentially sheet that was supposed to
go out to all the truckers about the
deal you did get that and we've seen it
up there and you replied looks good
it's just a it's a it's a comms piece
right it's not a deal it's
Communications right so what was your
expectation did you believe that the
city of Ottawa was going to enter into a
contract
well when I followed up after that I was
told there's no deal that was the whole
point I was getting bombarded online
people were getting upset truckers were
getting upset I had to communicate
something that's why I reached out to
them in those text messages that's why I
asked Keith is there a deal no and he
said specifically in a text message we
haven't drafted anything and and Tamara
as well told me uh there's nothing yet
I'll let you know if there's something
and it never was okay and so again
you're communicating the truckers are
reaching out to you and who were these
truckers reaching out to you that were
concerned but with people online have
can be bombarded with thousands of
messages but nobody from the board
from the board that you were on well the
board wasn't getting angry it's the the
people on the street that I didn't want
them to get angry and God forbid get
violence I needed to communicate at this
point There's No Deal there's nothing
and so let's let's talk about this so
you had set in your evidence that after
uh the police started taking enforcement
action yes that a bunch of people came
to talk to you because Tamara had been
arrested Chris Barbara had been arrested
and they asked what should we do and you
said leave you you need to leave no no
so what I said specifically and directly
I said I'll support you whatever you
want to do if you want to ask my opinion
I think maybe it's time to leave just to
give them a little bit because I thought
they would attack me for it to be
entirely honest and Bridget was the
first one to say to pipe up and say yeah
I think we should leave
uh Joe I think was the next one they all
said yeah it's getting violent and said
okay if that's what you want to do I'll
do my best to communicate that call you
later then we all started working and
right and so the deal that that was
being negotiated that I understand you
say you didn't know about it but the
deal there was to get the same sort of
thing done but to move the trucks
without any violence right
uh no the the deal was to consolidate
trucks onto Wellington is what I've been
hearing all this week but get them in
some residential areas no that's we were
leaving Ottawa entirely okay that's what
I communicate not consolidate them on to
Wellington Street to make it easier to
cattle the trucks so you were not happy
with Mr Wilson and miss chippyock and
the folks doing the negotiation
uh to try and end things peacefully but
you're okay with telling everybody to
leave once violence has started that's
what you would rather have done no I was
UN uncomfortable with Keith Wilson and
uh Eva because that's not the the client
uh solicitor relationship them telling
us what to do and going and doing off
their own deals and coming and dictating
to the truckers what we have to do but
you're on a board do you understand how
that works of course one more few on the
board that that's right I understand
that but the board gave him instructions
it's not just what you want because what
the board was doing to what this the
jccf was doing to them was scaring them
they offered them free legal advice and
if you don't listen to us then we're
gonna pull your free legal advice
everybody was scared we had the class
action suit we didn't know what we were
going to see potentially and then we had
all of this pressure coming from the
jccf regularly trying to dictate how the
messaging should or not the messaging
but how the the Convoy should operate
how the board should work whatever right
it was really difficult it really caused
a lot of problems and I also understand
again that you were making the decisions
about what media Outlets that you would
communicate through is that correct
which key with Keith Keith supported and
he mentioned yesterday that uh anyways
yeah I understand so but you
specifically mentioned here today
Russian today this right and I
understand uh that my clients had no
input into you communicating with
Russian today you just did that
uh yes like all the other interviews
right and you're familiar that Russian
today is essentially a Russian
propaganda outfit you're aware of that
yeah they thought it was hysterical as
well because because the CBC so you you
went to a Russian propaganda outfit
if I can in order to portray what you
believed was the message that you wanted
to portray uh Mr commissioner is he
asking the question or answering the
question on behalf of the witness he's
he's asking the question the witness
will get a chance to answer yeah okay so
you went to Russian today on your own
accord which you know is a Russian
propaganda outfit and thought that that
would be a good communication strategy
it's funny how back then they supported
me because there was a reason I did that
the reason I did that is because the CBC
started disseminating some more uh
narrative that maybe the Convoy is a
Russian operation and I wanted to bait
the CBC into building that narrative
that's how alternative media works and
they didn't take the bait but it was
great it was but you weren't instructed
to do that that was just on your own
initiative no I was instructed with my
team to do all the communications that's
what I was told to do but never
specifically contacting a Russian
propaganda outfit that's a wonderful
near narrative but they loved it when I
did it and everybody's changing their
mind yes I think it was a question all
right
okay
next we have the Ottawa Police Service
uh good morning commissioner good
morning Mr Victor my name is David
majakovski and I appear as counsel to
the Ottawa Police Service
yeah
um am I correct Mr Victor that when you
came to Ottawa
it was not your intention to disrupt the
lives of residents
uh no no the people who live here no
your beef was with the government
that's right and so there would have
been no reason that the police would
expect that when you got here you or
other members of the Convoy would engage
in harassment or honking or engage in
anti-social Behavior with the residents
uh I didn't see any harassment or
antisocial Behavior myself for the first
few days that I was walking around or
when I went on the stage any of the days
I've heard a lot of claims uh swastikas
for example and the woman I spoke to had
a swastika on her sign she said yeah
because I'm a religious Jew and what the
government is doing to me is exactly
what they did to us in Germany in the
30s I don't consider that anti-social
Behavior so people were just activists
they're just protesters perhaps my
question wasn't clear my my question was
with respect to the information
that was planned by members of the
Convoy before they arrived in Ottawa
they did not plan to do anything illegal
or harass people or engage in anti
social behaviors I don't think anybody
does and the Ottawa Police had a great
relationship start listening to the
question it was a pretty simple question
yep gotcha okay so you would agree with
me correct that wasn't the intention I
agree you came and um you indicated
therefore I guess that you would agree
with me that the police would therefore
not expect that there would be
anti-social Behavior or in a or
breaching bylaws or anything like that
based on what was being talked about
before the Convoy got here this is a
silly question I don't know what
anti-social Behavior means okay
um you would expect that the police
would not have anticipated that the
protesters would park their vehicles
wherever they want or honk their horns
or harass people wearing masks or engage
in racist or misogynistic behavior that
wasn't your plan so therefore you
wouldn't expect the police to anticipate
well and parking the trucks is where the
park trucks were parked where the Ottawa
Police told us to park them yeah okay so
my question to you again perhaps I
wasn't clear
um and I'll I'll break it down no no
that was not in our intention of course
right of course and so therefore the
police wouldn't expect that either they
would expect what you were promoting was
a peaceful uh demonstration with love
and where people got along correct
yes but my brother's a police sergeant
and I know they they have protocols for
everything they always anticipate that
there could be problem uh people in
every protest in every organization
right that's just the way it is you get
enough people together right there's
always going to be somebody who may
cause issues right and so you're aware
that the police had public order units
on standby in case that was necessary
the first weekend correct right uh but
you didn't anticipate it being a problem
Fair no and certainly what you were
reading on social media before you got
here it wasn't anticipated that this was
going to be a problem what was
anticipated was a peaceful protest yeah
just a very large one okay
um in spite of what you anticipated
however uh subsequently when you got
here
um there was honking of horns
for the first day and a half yeah
and there were residents and businesses
who complained about the behavior
engaged in by at least some of the
people all the businesses that I dealt
with were supporting us and thought it
was amazing many of the businesses were
closed downtown correct well they were
closed after so Rideau Center was open
initially all the businesses were open
and then
the city brought in some emergency thing
that made it one of the owners of the
business told me it's a hundred and
fifty dollar penalty a day if I opened
today but we're gonna support you but
that's why that happened from what I
understand
um and so ultimately there was an
injunction issued by a judge about the
honking correct yep and then there was a
further injunction that the city got
yep and so at least uh a couple judges
found that conduct had been engaged in
that was interfering with the residents
um the businesses of Ottawa correct uh I
don't know what evidence was provided to
him because I was not in that case I
don't know if it was just claims of this
and it was not substantiated and the
judge just ruled that if this is
happening it can't
uh because I was not I was not a
participant in those uh those
proceedings that you would assume that
our justice system works where there's
evidence and judges make decisions based
on that evidence of course but you know
judges have different leeway you know
everybody's different in what they
accept
um treason is a very serious crime isn't
it
yeah I would say so yeah okay and so one
of the things you did
um is if we could please turn up jba008o
it's a triple Force
uh that's something that uh Mr botter
put out do you subscribe to the views of
Mr botter no okay so you can take it off
that's fine so um I I take it
um then that you so you don't subscribe
to the views of Mr botter and it sounds
to me from your evidence that you've had
some disagreements with some of the
other members of the Convoy as well
correct yes I do you want me to expand
on the mou uh no no I'm just asking you
you've had conflict with the the views
of some of the other members of the
Convoy of the freedom uh Convoy as well
we were all really good we were all
really tight and we could resolve our
issues in the very beginning until the
Fourth of uh yeah the fourth of February
when I first met people from the jccf
and that's when all of a sudden uh the
distrust started and I think some of the
people who wanted to be on the board got
very upset but initially things were
great for the first couple of weeks
working with Tamara everything was
awesome right and so things however fell
apart and there wasn't cohesion within
the group anymore
on certain issues you know when I broke
my ankle I told that story when I was on
the couch everybody came and coalesced
around me they're all very supportive
and yeah we have some differences but
well it was an amazing moment so we were
able to resolve uh conflicts when we
didn't have people that were you know
fueling some division in my opinion I've
listened to the testimony from uh Convoy
protesters all week and it sound and
have you as well yes I have and it
sounds like there's a lot of
disagreements well I think the only
board member was uh was uh Chris Barber
right he was the only board members
testified
so it sounds like there was a lot of
disagreement among your views Tamara
leech's views uh no Tamara and I were in
sync the entire time at least you know
that was my impression we were messaging
calling texting like everything was
great right and so as I understand it uh
you were of the view
um that Keith Wilson wasn't honest when
he told you that there was no deal
say that again what what Keith Wilson
yeah he wasn't honest when he told you
there was no deal
uh it seems to be that's the case right
and he was the lawyer representing some
of the group correct he was representing
the jccf right so there was some
disagreement there and then I believe uh
Ms Leach didn't tell you about the
negotiations with the mem with the mayor
correct that's right I didn't know show
that with the mayor so there was um some
withholding of information there
was opaque for sure yeah and so when you
got the letter that she wrote that
freedom manifest you didn't interpret
that as telling truckers to leave right
sorry no no
um
uh just uh I just want to have you
identify a couple of pictures I just
want to move on uh to two sort of final
minor points okay and so if I could ask
you please uh Mr clerk to turn up jba
uh four zeros zero zero two
and so
um these are some pictures I take it
that you took
um on the day that um enforcement action
was being taken correct well I didn't
took it that was in a wheelchair I
couldn't go out in the snow I didn't
take that picture Okay um but you've
seen these pictures correct yeah that's
Metro Toronto police no
yeah so all I I uh well I'm saying in
fact we can see some uh indications on
the picture of some Badges of some
officers then we can see on the back on
the yellow vest we can see other
officers identified by a12
correct yeah right so you could see
where the various police were coming
from correct
uh I wasn't on the ground so when I was
in the hotel for example my friend
Salman who's been in many protests in
Iran uh he was running out and coming
back to me and predicting everything
saying this is what they're going to do
this is how they're blocking everybody
off and he said to me who put all the
trucks in one area I'm like I don't know
I have no idea okay um so that was mine
but I was I was in a wheelchair it was
snowy that day so I couldn't even get
out if I wanted to okay um let me move
on just to adjust my final Point uh you
can take that picture off please if I
could ask you Mr clerk to put up um
jba0020
so four zeros zeros
for the record I thought the parties per
the rules were to provide the witness
with at least
three days of the evidence they were
gonna call so I'm just uh for the record
the the next piece of evidence in the
last two uh Mr Victor was not aware that
it was going to be presented to him
today
well I guess I have um two comments uh
about that first of all the witness I'm
only taking him to something he referred
to which was the information they got
with respect to traffic but of course
these documents it was on only became
apparent that there were documents that
Mr uh
uh Victor had posted yesterday so that
database didn't exist so unless one is
checking the database continuously that
database did not exist but in any event
I'm only taking him to something that he
himself referred to which was the
information they got with respect to
parking when they came okay well let's
see where it goes
uh thanks if you could um
you were referring to some conversations
um about the police telling you where to
Stage Vehicles correct not me Chris Cara
okay and so that's an example of uh
something good morning Jason I'm still
waiting to get the traffic management
maps from the city but do you have some
info I can relay I've been told I should
have the map by noon today we have some
staging areas set up for trucks and
passenger vehicles but those areas are
on roads use infrastructure cannot
accommodate trucks with trailers we're
working on a staging area for trucks
with trailers and I'll pass that along
when I get it correct okay and so you
understood that was information the
police were giving to the Convoy
participants as to where they could
stage their vehicles correct yeah this
is one of the reasons I was surprised
Chris Carrow was not called as a witness
here because he was here for a week so
he could clearly comment on these issues
I just spoke to him on the phone a few
times during the week just to make sure
he's okay and but that was his area in
his Department right right and just the
final one in that one is jba four zero
zero zero six eight
and again so that is um giving some of
the information for truckers as to where
they can and cannot go correct yeah so
that's the information you're referring
to so they were told to leave space for
vehicles they were told where there
would no uh not be Convoy access and you
understood coming into the city did you
come in on what day
um I've been your way over time I
thought you were just going to put a
document to them and now you're going
into it you're going to have to wrap up
um sure just to finish that up what day
did you come in the 28th so that'd be
the Friday yes and on Saturday you saw
that a number of uh
entrances to downtown were closed off is
that correct yeah the the the team that
was at the Swiss Hotel was uh just in
dealing with volume that was the problem
nobody anticipated you know the largest
longest Convoy in history so that's what
really caused it I know they were
working with police from what I
understand to clear up and make sure
that the emergency laneways were opened
up and that was their primary concern
thank you very much
okay next is the Ontario Provincial
Police uh story to interrupt
commissioner it's Christine Johnson for
the Ottawa residents and businesses um
I'm just not sure if we were perhaps
that missed there in the lineup I
believe we have 15 minutes with Mr
Victor and I know it normally goes from
that most time to least time I'm sorry I
I didn't hear you you
know until with the Ottawa residents and
businesses just checking I'm not sure if
we were perhaps missed in the lineup I
believe we have 15 minutes with Mr
Victor and I know that it normally goes
from most time to least time you're
absolutely correct uh and I you're not
the first person I've
skipped in error so maybe you want to go
next
shirt I'm in your hands of course
knowing that we normally take the lunch
break around one o'clock if you would
prefer to have us start or perhaps a
party who has less time take us the
lunch break I'm in your hands I'd say
get started we're going to be running
late today so
foreign
good afternoon Mr Victor good afternoon
as you would have just heard my name is
Christine Johnson I'm one of the
co-counsel representing the Ottawa
residence and businesses coalition
I I just have a couple of areas of
questioning for you today
um it might come as no surprise that my
first area of questioning for you sir is
going to be about the honking uh that
residents and businesses observed during
the Convoy protest yeah
so you told us this morning Mr Victor
that on the evening that you fell and
slipped on the ice and broke your leg
that you didn't hear any honking at all
it was silent it was eerily silent it
was really weird yeah but you would
agree that there was loud prolonged
frequent honking day and night
throughout much of the Convoy protests
in Ottawa no I wouldn't agree with that
I would agree for the first couple of
days
uh but I was living down here too in a
hotel and uh we all had to sleep
truckers who had their kids in their
cabs they needed to sleep so I don't
know where this this narrative is coming
from I Didn't witness that you witnessed
no loud prolonged honking for the first
couple of days for sure uh when when
because he had multiple convoys coming
in all through the night different times
of the day people were moving things
around uh when they had the dance
parties or during the day like so many
kids who wouldn't do this go up to the
trucks honk uh because it was that sort
of vibe it was amazing so there was
honking throughout the day continuing
beyond the first few days no because I
was only on my feet remember until the
fourth so for the first couple of days I
will say there were there was honking
for the first couple days everybody came
in but it was not sustained for weeks I
was here all three weeks and we heard
that after your fall in the ice and
break of your leg you were confined to
the hotel most most of the time most of
the time I got out at least once a week
and there was that meeting I went to the
arc with the road captains it might have
been one other I remember some other
reason I was in the lobby went in and I
just can't remember what it was but yeah
so you wouldn't have heard the honking
uh directly on the street because you
weren't on the street for a good period
of time well I was in a hotel in
downtown downtown Ottawa two blocks away
from Parliament Hill there were trucks a
couple of trucks parked on the street in
front of the hotel those weren't honking
the adjacent Street they weren't honking
if I'm staying in downtown Ottawa right
in the core of all of it and I'm not
hearing honking I know where the
honking's coming from but you're aware
that many residents were expressing
concerns that they were hearing frequent
loud honking and they were disturbed by
that honking
and I want to project motives onto
people uh I would just say that I
disagree and perhaps there's other
motives for it I don't know
um I just know my experience and what I
saw both when I was on foot for the
first couple of days which was that
amazing moment where everybody came from
Quebec uh to meet with the Western
Canadians yeah there was honking then
um oh and I will admit as well during
the uh the speeches on the Sundays that
when the pastor would give his speech
when somebody would finish the trucks
were there would people would applaud
and the trucks that were there the six
trucks on either side they would honk
and Applause but that's all I saw but
you are aware that Ottawa residents
ultimately brought an application for an
injunction against the honking and the
court in fact granted that motion that's
right that's what I mentioned before and
I I may have caught you wrong but I
believe that you you just told uh one of
my friends that you weren't a
participant in that proceeding at all in
that motion to obtain an injunction
procedure no that was handled by the
lawyers that were representing us and
evidence on use for use on that motion
on February 7th what did it say what
specifically it uh I believe it uh it
attested to the fact that you were in
Ottawa as part of the protest and you
did not own a truck that's right so you
know your truck the truck wasn't in uh
in Ottawa but you affirmed that
affidavit for use in the motion
injunction
I'm getting lost can you simplify that
and
sir you you told us earlier that you are
not involved whatsoever yes in the
motion for an injunction on February 7th
against the horn honking when I didn't I
wasn't there I didn't uh I didn't attend
the proceeding okay you didn't attend
the proceeding but you did in fact
Supply an affidavit for use in that
proceeding I signed an affidavit for my
lawyers yes thank you and again you're
aware that that motion was successful
and that the court was convinced on the
evidence that there was honking and it
would cause irreparable harm if the
honking were to continue uh okay it's
that way they worded it irreparable harm
were you ever provided a copy of the
Court's decision
I was provided with Court decisions
later on like they would show us but it
was so busy there were so many things
going on and I kind of we all left the
legal stuff in the hands of legal I
dealt with messaging certain people
dealt with trucks the security that sort
of thing so it was
so many things came in and out right
so the lawyers for the jccf never
provided you with a copy of that court
order at the time it was obtained it
might have been within the the couple of
days they would have sent an email and
just because I was busy
were you aware that person went to that
court order you were required to
communicate the terms of the order on
your personal social media
no nobody told me that
and in fact you you never did
communicate the terms of the order on
your social media
I don't believe so I'm trying to think I
don't believe so
okay I could be wrong but I don't there
were so many thousands of messages that
I put out there I'm trying to think if I
was told Community but I don't I don't
recall that I don't recall that
you've told us that uh you didn't hear a
lot of honking you didn't think it was a
key feature of this
this at all is that fair that's right so
I want to ask you about
um your your your personality on social
media you have a Twitter account Mr
Victor that has honk in your name on
Twitter correct yes
and what is the significance of that why
did you include honk in your Twitter
name oh it's just um humor uh the idea
that uh when we came here I mean it's
both humor and a cry for help from the
government like the little bit of
honking that you saw it wasn't
um
it wasn't to be aggressive it's you have
to understand what these people's lives
were going through and they were just
completely desperate and I know some of
them one particular driver a Ukrainian
driver
uh he was very passionate in the
beginning for honking because he said
they don't listen to me what do I have
to do I have to honk or something I'm
like well
let's tone it down a little bit that was
in the first couple of days so some
drivers some truckers did communicate to
you that they fell
ow
about your experience in the Convoy and
I understand that the title of that book
is honking for Freedom yes and again if
honking was not a central feature of
this protest why would your book
while this is coming up on the screen Mr
Victor
um you've already been asked about those
uh daily event and safety reports that
were put out for Convoy participants yes
I believe you've told us that you didn't
have uh direct involvement in these they
were put out by Tom Quicken yeah I'm not
an intelligence analyst and I figured he
would be the best person to do that and
I think everybody agreed and Tom quiggin
uh was the host of the Quicken report
host on your podcast correct uh yeah he
also has worked for the RCMP the Bank of
Canada military uh he's got a very
impressive CV in terms of his career
working for the government
okay I do recall seeing some of these
daily event I saw a couple of them but I
just got so overloaded with stuff uh
that I couldn't make this uh my focus
but he was posting them and he also has
a social media account so I believe he
was posting them on his as well so this
looks to be the report from February
12th we'll see that at the top of the
report
uh in Mr clerk I'll just have you scroll
down to the very bottom
so we have daily humor and meme Warfare
section uh from looking through a few of
these reports it seems like it was
common to have a daily humor or joke
section at the bottom of them lighten
the load okay the sort of thing Elon
Musk does and so this uh meme or humor
section uh has a caricature of someone
labeled the Honker
and it has a variety of descriptors
around uh this caricature it says
doesn't vandalize just honks
uh uses meme Warfare in real life
creates a schedule of the honk for
maximum Freedom enhancing effects
disrupts the status quo by not letting
people sleep in tyranny
withholds the soy from the reach from
reaching the soy Jack until Freedom
improves uses the power of vibrating air
to chase the Prime Minister out of the
country just straight up says to the
crying soyjack the honking will continue
until Freedom improves train horn not
enough we need a ship horn
and there are a variety of caricatures
at the bottom uh looking to have tears
pouring out of their eyes and their
hands and their face they're called NPCs
in Internet culture and and can you
explain that to us sir a non-playable
character is the term what it means yeah
uh and and we see the reference to the
term soy Jack do you can you illuminate
us on what Jack refers to if you were
you have to really this is going down
the rabbit hold of Internet humor
culture like it's a joke right it may
not lend itself to legal proceedings but
this is you know I mentioned Elon Musk
this is the sort of thing that he would
put out frequently he's probably the
most popular to do it and also we knew
there was a honking injunction so people
would go out on social media and they
would put hashtag honk honk it wasn't
people actually going outside and
honking it was their way to to show
their support for the Convoy
but you would agree with me that this
type of humor whether it's in just or
not is perhaps not getting the message
across to Convoy participants to lay off
the horns in light of the injunction uh
no I think it's it's good to get people
to have something that it might not be
your type of humor but for the people
who were freezing in their trucks for
three weeks uh they need something they
need some sort of pick-me-up and I think
for them it's a lot a way for people to
vent right that's why we have free
speech for conflict resolution and
that's the power that's why humor was
very important and there's so many memes
going around uh the internet for through
all all of this some of it was look for
me some of it was too extreme and
distasteful I get it but I'm not going
to dictate what people should say okay
that's not that that's not my thing but
then other stuff was great it was you
know you have a whole range of different
World Views and opinions because with
people from all over the world
that were supporting us when I was in
Colombia there were people there who
wanted to meet me because they were
supporting when I was in Miami there
were people who recognized me as Uber
drivers that were supporting us so you
have a whole range of people with
different World Views and in the
interest of time I won't take you to the
second Daily report of this nature but
before the record hrf six zeros 43 uh is
a February 13th daily report that has a
humor section along these lines as well
and I don't know if you recall it off
the top of your head but there was a
daily humor section at the bottom that
says Supreme Art of War is to Tire the
enemy with honking so something that you
find equally funny along these lines I
take it well it's not literally honking
in your truck again you'll you'll
probably see those memes were grabbed
from the internet where people were
putting memes up with the hashtag Hong
Kong that's where it all comes from
and lastly sir I'll just ask you a
couple of other questions about the
impact uh just very briefly on Ottawa
residents and businesses we heard you
say this morning
um that you uh it was your understanding
the Rito Center was open initially uh
yes I was in there I got coffee at uh
Tim Hortons and and but you were aware
it was only that first weekend that it
was open it closed very soon on that
first weekend of protest and actually
remained close for the duration you
might understand that that came from the
city that uh they demanded that all the
businesses closed and the Rideau Center
as well was one of them which didn't
make sense to us because the businesses
we uh we were attending they never been
so busy I think they were so happy we
had so many businesses tell us that they
made record profits yeah so Sarah I
would tell you that your information on
that sounds to be inaccurate from uh
from our discussions with our our Bia
and uh clients
um so who was it who told you the
businesses were forced to close because
of the city
um well I think it was the iconic Cafe
was one of them uh one of the shawarma
place sources that stayed open there's a
number of videos online one that just
came out last week from somebody who
works in one of the restaurants and she
said if if I they were coming around to
our restaurant the media was coming
around telling us these people are
dangerous you should close and she said
if I wasn't there to see the media
trying to coerce us to make us think the
truckers were dangerous I might have
believed it but she I was here I saw it
I saw everybody was peaceful we served
you and it was great so I think there
was a little bit of some narrative and
politics going on there well are you are
you aware sir that businesses many
businesses were forced to close because
of maskless protesters and their concern
about the fines that they as businesses
might face if they were to stay open and
have maskless patrons
I don't know I can't comment to that
that might be the case but I do know
when my business was in downtown Toronto
uh I would try to staple stay open every
day of the week especially when uh
University students were in town and if
I had something like this
it would have been amazing I wished I
would have had an event like this when I
had my business in Toronto
notwithstanding any concerns that you
know young employees might face
harassment or anything like that you
wouldn't have had concerns when you were
running your business of those sorts of
things truckers are very well over your
time and I'm not sure this is getting
anywhere
um so
the next
is uh now is the Ontario Provincial
Police
afternoon commissioner I have no
questions thank you okay
um and uh
the uh I just let me just find out if
we're going to have much more than I
think I'll take the lunch break
um will you have some questions uh
f for the
the witness Mr kaharralius uh yes I will
okay and
democracy fund jccf will you have
questions
and Council for Mr slowly will you have
any
we will have five minutes five minutes
and re-examination
not not at this time okay so let's try
and get through it then
um Council for uh
former Chief slowly if you go ahead
I'm Nicholas DeStefano for former Chief
slowly I'm Mr Victor hi Nicholas
so we heard a lot about how you were
part of a group corporation that
represented sort of certain protesters
correct ah yes
um but there were also other groups that
were present in Ottawa protesting
correct there were so many groups yeah
yeah
um and you stated earlier that there
were more protesters than you expected
there would be I think I I think we all
agree to that right
um
the events were just on a scale that you
yourself and sort of members of your
group just did not expect correct oh yes
and within your group you testified that
you sort of had people at the Sheraton
that were responsible for messaging
um some of you were at the arc Hotel
responsible for Logistics and others
were at the Swiss Hotel sort of speaking
with the police and dealing with the
police correct yep
um did you yourself interact with any of
the PLT members from the Ops no I didn't
can you remind me who from your group
was responsible for that
I don't know if I found out
um about uh like I didn't realize that
all the road captains I don't know which
ones had PLT and which ones didn't uh it
just seemed to be random and maybe I
understand the PLT is part-time that
might have had something to do with it
because I do know there were occasions
where some uh drivers captains whatever
we're trying to get in touch with PLT
members and they couldn't so but that's
my I wasn't there with a truck I wasn't
on the ground so there really was really
no need for me to interact uh with plts
with the exception of the day that we
left when I told all the truckers what I
told on the sorry I didn't tell them I
said do you want to leave
um and I suggested call all your uh your
liaison officers and I'll meet you
upstairs in a board meeting aft in the
boardroom afterwards and I walk up and
Bridget is yelling and arguing with the
people just say you'll do whatever you
want you got to go home you gotta leave
um but I personally uh didn't
so we heard some evidence that Mr
marazzo had been in contact with the
plti yeah that's true you didn't know
about that at the time at the time I
didn't know and you would have had no
input into any of those discussions uh
no because they seem to be running their
own show right and we also heard from
you that when Mr marazzo
um or sorry we heard from you that when
members of your group did indeed
um reach an agreement or purport to
reach an agreement about the movement of
trucks that you did not agree with the
outcome of that agreement correct
well the whole idea of I was told
repeatedly that there's uh it's not
going well I didn't assume not going
well means there's a deal so and I don't
understand the deal we're not getting
that a deal is two-way right just
capitulating and saying we're leaving
like if we told that to the truck
truckers they would lose their minds get
so angry right and I'm not going to put
the text message back up on the screen
we saw a text message earlier where you
referred to thousands thousands of
protesters scolding you about the
purported agreement no not well some
were protesters many of them were
protesters but we had so much online
support that's what was driving a lot of
it so a lot of it was people within
Canada that were supporting people that
were in Ottawa that were supporting so
you had a whole mixed bag and that was
going on all the time regularly there
were people that were streaming in
Twitter spaces that's like a communal
group that they would be in a group that
was live meaning being active people
talking for 24 36 hours straight with
hundreds of people sometimes thousands
of people
and on February 6th you gave a press
conference and you mentioned there's a
transcription of this I'm not going to
put it up on the screen but but you
mentioned that in Ottawa there were
certain rabble rousers who were trying
to make this about them and they were
sort of outside of your group and
outside of your entourage you remember
that uh yeah so we always had those
other there was the our you know Freedom
Court what you know aligned with let's
say the the GoFundMe where the money was
being raised and there were all these
other little groups for sure and you
stated that you couldn't police those
people and you agree with that still uh
well that's why I explained our moral
persuasion that we definitely had
influence with them and could
communicate to them and one of the
things by the way we did communicate
we're relieved with
um Chief slowly
when he said I on February 3rd I don't
remember the date when he said this
requires a political solution this is
not a not a policing solution because
it's peaceful and we were like great
finally there's a police chief that's
not going to politicize everything it
was such a it was a moment of hope for
us
but you you agreed that members of the
protest that weren't part of your
entourage were sort of independent
operators they were sort of free free
thinkers and you could enforce them to
do something that they wouldn't do right
like for example
um you're aware that Pat King was asked
not to come to Ottawa at a certain point
and then he did indeed come right you
could you couldn't force them to do
something they didn't want to do which
is what I understand uh Tamara was
trying to mitigate that realizing that
he's not gonna he's gonna latch on but
he's going to be like many other people
he's just going to come along and I
guess my understanding is the strategy
was
keep him under control I keep him out of
the Limelight and uh but I had like I
never met him I've never talked to him
don't know him and just one last
question Mr commissioner
um
and so you would agree with me then that
even if your group was able to make some
sort of agreement with the police and
that there was some sort of buy-in to
that agreement and that it was Mobility
mobilized whether it be to stop honking
or to move trucks somewhere some of
those rabble rousers could have moved in
and parked their trucks in the exact
same spot that they were moved out of or
just simply not abided by it because you
had no control over them but no I
disagree and I disagree because people
in the trucking industry uh it's a very
regulated industry we know rules pars
documents going across the border
uh it you know it's not the Central
Casting uh description of what a trucker
is it's uh it's far more corporate Than
People realize so I was not terribly
worried that but there are people that
are very passionate about it sometimes
you need people that they need to have a
little bit more hand-holding and talking
and coming to consensus and other people
are just on board yeah we'll do it it
just it comes down to the individual
it's not truckers it's individual people
that you've got to reach out to
I said thanks thank you thank you so the
only remaining then is uh Mr uh coralios
I may be pronouncing it wrong but
foreign
what can you tell the commission about
Twitter passwords
uh Twitter passwords can be easily
changed if you have email and telephone
access to your Twitter account
um who were the first seven members of
the
Freedom Corporation if I can call it
that you gave the name earlier do you
remember the names of the first seven
directors of the corporation myself
Tamara Leach Chris Barber Chris Guerra
um
who am I forgetting because Barbara
Chris Guerra Miranda
and somebody else
Sean Thiessen what's your relationship
with Sean Thiessen uh it was actually
quite uh quite good you know Sean and I
actually connected better than uh uh
everybody like we really I mean maybe
with the exception of Tamara
uh seemed to be pretty reasonable guy he
kept in touch with him
when was the last time you spoke to
shanti's a few months ago uh maybe it's
now four or five months ago no I don't
that long a few months ago
uh can you share with the commission
your conversation with Sean Thiessen at
that time uh yeah Sean Thiessen
explained to me that they were really
upset with a tweet that you made and
they're going to try to pin this all on
you and they're going to make some
narrative that it's your fault and I
remember thinking like I don't know how
they're going to do that and um and I
said well what's the rest of the board
thinking and he said they're all really
scared uh Tamara and Chris have both
criminal and civil charges none of them
have any experience in law and they feel
like they're being held hostage
um to the jccf for free legal uh advice
and legal counsel because they don't
have any money to um to fight a
multi-million dollar class action suit
and he was very
uh he's very direct about that
um earlier my friend from the Convoy
organizers asked you
um
um asked you about your membership or
your position
in the uh Convoy organization
um are you still a member of the Convoy
organization apparently I am
there's been some dispute in the
questions as to who was retained by the
corporation so I'm not going to get into
the details of uh whether jccf was
retained or Mr Wilson but can you just
tell me in your experience dealing with
lawyers
um I think you testified that your mom
was a paralegal what do lawyers get
retained to do
I'm not sure how where this is going
um I'm not sure that's evidence that is
relevant to the case uh but uh maybe you
can explain it to me uh sure he was um
my friend from the combo organizers was
asking Mr Victor uh about the
relationship with uh Council and uh I
don't think that evidence has been
provided accurately Mr Victor has his uh
an opportunity here to answer the
question what his uh perspective as a
member of director of the Convoy
organization what they hired lawyers to
do what the job of those lawyers was to
do and what they were doing on behalf of
the board
that's what I'm trying to get at
you have a submission yes sir first my
friend is getting into something that
may in fact be privileged and the board
has not waived that privilege as a whole
second I don't understand what the
relevance of materiality of any of this
is to whether or not the emergencies act
should have been invoked okay
I think certainly what he I don't
believe your client can waive the
privilege I think that's
fundamental so I'm not sure again what
this is relevant to
um okay
um
I'll I'll ask a couple other questions
and I'll see if uh I can reframe it okay
um your uh defendant in the class action
uh that came up earlier
um after the injunction on the horn
honking took place
um are you aware aware of anyone in
Ottawa that faced uh any charges or any
other legal ramifications after the
injunction to stop uh honking uh uh was
was put in place by the court uh charges
relating to honking now
uh you're wearing that same proceeding
um there was a series of marava
injunctions and escrow orders yes uh can
you tell the commission your experience
with uh as a defendant in that
proceeding uh uh your experience with
those mariva injunctions and escrow
orders well I was receiving privileged
emails from Keith Wilson and his agent
with regards to the meriva injunction up
until I believe May of this year so my
understanding was they were still
representing me
and what were you asked to do as part of
the those court orders
oh I was to surrender
um the seed phrase of the Bitcoin which
is a combination
to uh the Bitcoin app of which there
were five codes or five seed phrases and
I had one of them
and and what did you do with that uh
Siege phrase and uh and the code I
submitted it to Keith Wilson via his
agent
um Norm Groot who was representing me in
the uh
uh in the mariva agent and my
understanding is that went to the
bankruptcy trustee or whoever deals with
it uh you you testified uh earlier with
my friends from the um
Ottawa neighborhood association
apologies if I'm not uh identifying the
party correctly
uh that the term honking
uh
uh became uh popular as a tech
what was the incident during the
protests that led to
um honking becoming something that would
get traction on social media online
uh the particular incident uh
there was
um
a number of things they're particularly
when they the the tenor of the protest
changed
um when those first videos came out
um but then you start to see a lot of
people getting on board it became
popular there was a Bitcoin drive it
just became like a meme uh and a
cultural significantly event online with
uh on Twitter and social media in
general was the hashtag honking or honk
more popular after the horn in Junction
or less popular uh it was more popular
because they couldn't honk it was the
only thing they could do is type hashtag
honk are you suggesting that the hashtag
honk replaced actual honking on the
street exactly
um if I can ask the clerk to bring up
hrf 1291 page 55 it's a long PDF
I apologize
there's a series of text messages
between Dean French and Mr Wilson
so what page did you say page 55 of the
PDF
okay
Mr Victor do you see that uh it's fuzzy
but I can see it can you read it
uh yes he's excited to get your call
please remind your board I never once
spoke to Premier Ford about this or
Katie Telford uh
journals Chief and then he correct it as
Trudeau who's Katie Telford uh that's
the chief of staff of the Prime Minister
is there is there can you tell us about
the significance of this text message
from Mr French to Mr Wilson well this
would indicate that firstly he has the
ability to reach out to the premier and
the Prime Minister
um if he wanted and he's clearly a
significant significantly politically
connected uh figure
and in your time providing messaging on
behalf of uh the protests or the
corporation
did anyone from the premier's office or
the prime minister's office approach you
for a discussion to get to a peaceful
resolution no never not once
just uh one second Mr commissioner hrf
1325
Please Mr Clerk
Mr Victor you uh identified the members
the directors of the corporation
um you see this uh document seems to be
meeting notes from a meeting at City
Hall
what directors from the corporation were
at this meeting uh looks like Chris
Barber and that's all
can you say that again please uh Chris
Barber and no one else
these are not board members
okay your time is up to the
is there uh anything that you need to
deal with or can we wrap this up
I think we are close to wrapping it up
if you can just give me 15 seconds Mr
commissioner that's perfect
there is an uh an email and evidence
and I'm running out of time so I'm not
going to look for the number
and at the uh it's an email from Mr
Wilson to you
and the third line of the email
says Trudeau will be pissed
can you tell us your opinion on that
line from Mr Wilson to you
Trudeau will be pissed I've I just wait
a minute there's an objection sir
um this witness is being asked to
interpret a document not authored by him
and give his opinion of it and I don't
again see how any of this is relevant it
was an email from Mr Wilson to Mr Victor
who submitted an Evidence
um uh and I'd like Mr Victor to share
his thoughts on what he thought of an
email concluding with Trudeau will be
pissed meant from Mr Wilson we don't
have contacts I don't even know what
he's referring to sir and okay I don't
take a few minutes I'll find you the
doctrine I just thought for the I think
it wasn't a document submitted by Mr
Victor I assume the other parties knew
the document yeah if you're going to
refer to the document I think we have to
have it brought up so that
we'll try to identify to just give us a
moment
okay
so do you have a reference for the
number or reference number trying to
find it Mr commissioner I apologize
uh for Council do you have the date at
all this potential email
do you have the date for it
um
hrf 1276
foreign
I'm telling you about yes
when you read a line from Mr Wilson at
the time Trudeau is going to be pissed
uh can you tell us
um can you give commission such shed
some light to the commission on uh what
you're reading there I was quite shocked
uh I produced a podcast with lawyers my
mother's a paralegal I've been around
lawyers my whole life I've never I've
never seen lawyers speak like that I
thought we were getting professional
counsel we got that King in a suit
okay sir yes I don't understand this and
I would note that my friend has just put
up evidence proving that this individual
knew about the deal but other than that
I don't think it's appropriate for him
to comment on Trudeau is going to be
pissed and his view of what is
appropriate language and what is not and
I don't want to get into the case law
about what that is and how lawyers are
allowed to communicate I don't need to I
don't think the groin decision Etc but
uh sir this is not relevant yeah I okay
I disagree it goes to the motivation of
the individual sending email to Mr
Victor I
I think you've put the question it's
been answered
if the documents there we'll have to
deal with it so thank you commissioner
okay any re-examination
no Mr commissioner
no okay so thank you so that you're now
free to uh to go thank you thank you
very much for your testimony
no 55 minutes we're going to take a
little bit shorter today and come back
uh at uh
2 30.
the commission is in recess until until
2 30.
order a lot
um
the commission is reconvened that
commission report
afternoon commissioner the next Witness
will be
James bowder
and it's uh Jeff Leon co-commit co-lead
Council for the commission
Mr bowder will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm uh the
Bible please
foreign
for the record please State and spell
your first name a full name James j a m
e s Ralph
r-a-l-p-h butter b-a-u-d-e-r
[Music]
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do thank
you
thank you
commissioner uh Mr bowder does not have
counsel and uh he's requested to take
the protections available to him in
giving his evidence
okay uh well I understand uh you're
under subpoena Mr powder correct correct
okay I
um
have deemed that the witness has
objected to answer each and every
question on the ground that his answer
May in tend to incriminate him or may
tend to establish his liability to a
civil proceeding at the instance of the
crown or any other person
and if but for the the act
or the act of any provincial legislature
the witness would therefore have been
excused from answering the question
then all other Witnesses by reason of
the act or provincial act compelled to
answer
the answer so given shall not be used or
admissible in evidence against him in
any criminal trial or other criminal
proceeding
against him thereafter taking place
other than of course a prosecution for
perjury in the giving of that evidence
or for the giving of contradictory
evidence
so that will be for each question and
answer it's taken that you've
taken the protection afforded to you
under the charter and the various
statutes okay thank you commissioner
good afternoon Mr batter
good afternoon Jeffrey
can you tell me where you were born I
was born in Kamloops BC Canada I
understand today is your birthday it is
well happy birthday thank you
um and um you currently reside in in
Calgary correct and uh for how long uh
better part of my life I guess uh I met
my beautiful uh wife Sandy and moved
there
15 years ago I guess I've been in
Alberta in BC my whole life okay and um
what do you do for a living I am a truck
driver
and
um how long have you been driving a
truck
uh since I was a kid on the farm and
I've been there
in my early 20s
and then uh
went into a different career path than
truck driving and
uh from there I just uh picked up the
the wheels a couple years ago okay and
what was that other career path my
background uh started in oil and gas
when I was 18 years old and by uh the
age of 26 I had worked up to consultant
level of where then I specialized in uh
various uh levels of governance policy
design and risk mitigation
internationally at the C plus director
level
and I understand uh you have some
education in corporate governance
I've got a
very interesting CV yes
could you just briefly say tell us a bit
about your
corporate governance uh
experience
so I don't know why that's relevant here
today uh however I spent a better part
of my career looking for the truth and
auditing and assessing governance models
looking at uh
the root cause analysis of our
governance and then cross-referencing
that over to policies and looking at
policy design and then using risk
mitigation factories and modelings from
there was able to develop corrective
action models for projects all over the
world thank you and um
I want to deal with some of the convoys
that you've been involved in I
understand that in 2019 you participated
in the United We Roll Convoy that's in
February 2019. correct and uh
that Convoy went from
Calgary to Ottawa correct
Red Deer actually Red Deer and um
that Convoy was involved in protesting
legislation uh related to oil and gas
issues yes at that time I believe
naughty notley and Justin Trudeau were
ganging up on us and we said enough of
that
and what was your role in relation to
that Convoy other than participating in
it did you have a role yes it did my
role was to represent Unity
I had just started the Canada Unity
foundation and I got a call from some
beautiful people and said uh James this
is right up your alley you should get
into this and uh that was an amazing
journey and uh just amazing did you play
a role in the planning no okay
now you you mentioned Canada Unity
um I understand that
a Canada Unity is a humanitarian
organization that brings people together
and bases its foundation on community is
that correct
and one of the things that Canada Unity
does is oppose covid-19 Public Health
measures
what Canada Unity is has developed into
has been my honor and privilege to serve
we represent and we defend all Canadian
lawful Freedom of Choice by coming
together in unity
okay and that's the mission statement
and um
you have taken a position that uh with
respect to covid-19 Public Health
measures what's that position
I find them all unlawful
and starting in August of 2021 I
understand you started planning
for a convoy to Ottawa is that correct
correct
and you use the name for that Convoy for
Freedom correct
if you'd like I could elaborate a little
bit on that
because there is some relevance to this
and how that Convoy for Freedom was
originated
because it's it's pretty important yes
when I'm looking
at my wife who comes to me and says
James it's your job to protect the
family
I didn't know what that would detail
however I I just
found my faith
and got recently baptized
and that day I got baptized
it stuck it stuck deeply
and you can imagine my world going from
International
flying a you know the only object of uh
news I got was CNN and BBC in an airport
so I have a pretty good understanding of
how Corporate
decision makers and policy makers can
get very distracted with
the media and not get the full facts so
I made a prayer
to save my soul because of all the
division and divisiveness that I was
witnessing in my country and the answer
to that prayer was
Convoy for Freedom okay and to
specialize and put Unity at the
Forefront of that Convoy that's and
Jesus
um
Canada Unity have members
a few how many
hundreds of thousands
and uh how do you join Canada Unity we
have a platform multiple platforms
now uh Mr clerk could you put up on the
screen com
505.
and I understand this to be a copy of a
Facebook page of yours and it's dated
August 30 2021
correct
and um
you say want to know what Justine
Trudeau hates more than protesters a
convoy parked on his front step just
saying
and then
um
you go on if you have a semi truck and
are willing to step up to save our great
nation from becoming China to text me I
am ready to make some noise but I need
you big trucker so was this a call for
people to participate in your convoy yep
yeah I was watching and witnessing the
the destruction of Australia and our
brothers and sisters down there and um
two factors gave me the motivation to do
this other than answering
and and being directed by God on this
was a the United rural Convoy and me
coming here and witnessing uh the
homeless in the streets where you can
check this on Canada unity's YouTube I I
didn't participate in the politics
because I'm non-political with our
foundation and that's hard to see that
we're actually there's a definite line
there uh
so I went out and I actually fed the
homeless and I made a documentary on it
okay remember that was my first time I
came here so then oh and you're yeah
yeah so
watching uh Australia start a convoy
over there over these unlawful mandates
and seeing our brothers and sisters down
south get treated like
third world citizens uh it gave me
enough uh motivation to step up and I
and do what Canadians do we are the
peacekeepers of the world we need to
step up in unity and show the world what
peace and unity is All Above I just want
to remind you as we've talked about we
have an hour for you to give your
evidence I know you want to be able to
tell your story so um you were supposed
to do this
um
okay so you say further down
um the Convoy will be 100 geared for
uniting Canada no political agendas
you say simple terms Novac vax passports
Canada wide
no masks mandate canada-wide no more
lockdowns Canada wide we demand our
government put immediate stop to all of
the above correct and so that was the
the goal of
back Convoy yep
and I you started from
Calgary and uh went to to Ottawa correct
did you go
in terms of the planning how many
vehicles were part of that Convoy uh
upwards of 500 sometimes and then there
was
we made a big boo-boo when we started we
had all our registration dates and my
wife and I were in Calgary with action
for Canada and we were
Convoy of one
okay so and we got going and then it
just got it got bigger and bigger and
bigger and it just uh it grew
and you you planned it all did you yes
you develop the maps and The Roots the
logistics schedules uh no actually I
made a I made a post asking for help and
uh from there uh I got a lot of help
a lot of help and I'm grateful for that
and when did you arrive in Ottawa I
can't remember to be the honest uh it
was in October sometime
and if you're gonna ask me dates I don't
know I'm terrible with dates so no
October is fine if you need the actual
date evidence
I'll ask you for it okay
um now if I can ask you to put up on the
screen please uh com50858
this is another uh Facebook page of
yours from December 13 2021
and it says operation bear hug Ottawa
was a great success this was what we've
just been talking about the the Convoy
um
and
you say operation bear hug what is the
way why bear hug
so if you want I've got
ah hang on here okay uh where is that
one that I'd like to bring up sorry
because I could actually read my
evidence to answer your question John or
Jeffrey what are you referring to
jba0000 so six zero is four three
and then I can answer that question
about the bear hook right there
that's not it
okay well can we can you just give me an
explanation sir of why you use the term
I'd really like to actually read my
evidence that I submitted here to
Jeffrey what I quoted this is not the
evidence well can we do it this way sir
if you answer my question so we'll get
the object of a bear hug okay let's
let's let's be honest here we are in a
country of division by Design the very
root foundations of our government and
our governance have division in it so
the opposite of division
is unity
pure and simple and we are a country
that has got many problems with the
vision
and if you're in touch with God and
you're you're praying all the way
through this
the one thing that that came to our team
and this was a team effort
I I can't remember the exact person that
came up and he said bear hug
and we started looking at this from a
psychology point of view and it has been
an amazing journey
to keep love and peace as an organizer
with a bunch of Truckers
uh Bridget mentioned here a couple of
days ago that he had a couple hundred
truckers together and you know we're a
little Rowdy and I know I am one so
how do you bring together a country in
unity that's fighting in
division uh a bear hug love love love
and if you want I can give you a
demonstration no I don't need a
demonstration thank you because it was
very much evident and if if those that
went down to Ottawa or anywhere across
Canada we go on to my next question
please
um sorry your foot back up com505858
and um
just quickly to I want to deal with the
things you did in Ottawa uh it on that
in that Convoy say you went maskless
shopping and maskless dining you know on
day one
and every day and then on day two you
went to Dollarama and they shut down
their tails but they were told by the
police to open correct and then day
three you did a media blockade at CTV
what's a media blockade
uh it's it's
we just showed up and blocked the
parking lot uh yes uh not like we were
on the street so there is laws on on
doing this and and the police of Ottawa
were very very helpful uh and and these
are the laws that we can operate within
yeah and then I've been working with the
police all the way through from day one
August uh every day and they just this
is what we can do so we held CTV and you
know
I think for half an hour or 45 minutes
each person and then we had a little
chit chat with them about their
propagandas that they were spreading and
yeah it was awful then on day four uh
you did the same thing uh with CBC
yes and then you say you went over to
Justine Trudeau's and the governor
General's houses and held a block party
in the middle of the street shutting
down the road for about 30 minutes
and you say the police were called and
they didn't interfere correct that so
that lasted 30 minutes at each residence
correct and and there was a there was a
I do remember
something we did two back-to-back
convoys over there because the first
Convoy we were told that Trudeau was
going to be in the the main house you
know uh on Sussex I think and then he
wasn't there so
we turned around we came back to
Confederation Park
and then we got news that he was at the
cottage
so we did the pretty big Convoy size at
that point so we jumped in and we we
went back to the cottage and and you
know the police that were there with us
they were pretty pretty cool
uh they all started scurrying and and
trying to catch up to us and then they
caught up to us and they said James what
are you doing
so I said we lost something
and he said well would you lose I said
our freedom we're trying to go find it
okay thank you and then um
foreign
Minister Trudeau's uh house uh again is
what you're telling us and the governor
General's house and you block the road
during rush hour traffic is that
correct and all the evidence in the
videos we uploaded for you for that yeah
and further down you mentioned bear hug
2. correct and so you your plan was to
repeat this if you could
do that so the original bear hug one uh
we had been marketing and promoting
Convoy to Ottawa and doing several
convoys all across the board and
marketing when the time comes that the
federal mandate is imposed on the
trucking industry get ready
be prepared
so we thought that was going to come on
in December that's why we were there for
bear hug one and it didn't happen so we
knew that the federal government was
still itching to put this Federal travel
mandate on and force us to take vaccines
just to travel so
we went home uh uh as you can see and
then just as I get into Calgary Facebook
shuts off my everything they reinstated
it but we were completely uh
taken out of the equation so I'd like to
go on and talk about the mou that you
mentioned in that uh the memorandum of
understanding yes and um
can you bring up please com50866
foreign
and can you just scroll through that and
confirm for me that that is the the your
memorandum of understanding
I have the original right here so well
piece of History right here in front of
me
that's 15 pages that's not the original
can you tell me what this document is
then I need to see the whole document I
haven't seen this yeah okay well I I
will scroll through it
ah there we go okay no so this is the
French and English version yes okay yeah
this was the original
okay and then
um
I take that this document was prepared
by you
and by your wife Sandra
and by a gentleman named Martin brodman
correct and who is uh Mr broad Martin
brodman is a truck driver uh with a also
similar interesting costs uh with his uh
background he also worked International
as well
and I think it would be an
understatement to say that this is a
very important document to you
um
it served its purpose okay and has it
remained the same since the outset have
there been any changes to it
not since we uh strategically withdrew
sorry not since we were strategically
withdrew and so that's um you went
through that in February 2022 February
8th I believe yeah yeah after we got uh
viciously talked by this government and
slandered and defamed and character
assassination and everything we'll come
to that okay um if we can go to page two
please
if you just scroll up
next page
foreign
can you go back
now the parties uh to this agreement
if you can scroll
a little further
um
are the are listed as the
um
concerned Canadian citizens
the Senate of Canada and the governor
general
I think you missed a few more people
back up there please I'm trying to we
can all read it I'm just trying to
summarize it
um
and um
if you can keep going please
um
to where it's uh on back uh what to
where it says the Senate of Canada
um or sorry let me start uh with the
concerned Canadian citizens where we
were there it says uh represented by
you and your wife and Martin brought
correct
correct and the
Senate of Canada would be represented by
The Honorable George J ferry QC the
speaker
correct and the uh
governor general would be the honorable
Mary Mae Simon correct representing the
queen in Canada
now um did you have uh any legal
assistance in drafting this document no
the three of you did it on your own yep
and so I because an mou isn't a legal
anything it's just words
so
and I take it that
your intention was to have the the
Senate and the governor general
um
enter into this mou along with you okay
had the senate or the governor general
responded
then the next step would have been
immediately contacting multiple
organizations that we've been working
with across Canada like police on guard
for the action for Canada vaccine choice
I mean I could keep going we had to take
back our freedom we had a lot of groups
that we could have
um very very
uh we could have facilitated uh
establishing the Canadian citizens
committee
so that we could then sit down in in
partnership with the Senate and the
governor general and address the
unlawful mandates that are happening
across this country and come to some
resolution
now can we come to article three where
it says mandate
I'd just like to review review these
with you so Canada
Unity that's CU and
um I guess that's
s-c-ggc which is the Senate and the
governor general agree to form a
committee called citizens of Canada
committee
and
that committee undertakes and appoints
authorized representatives
are sorry the Senate commit and governor
general undertake authorized to appoint
authorized representatives and Canadian
Unity does the same correct
uh at that point Canada Unity is out
because we would have had a group of of
individuals that come forward of doctors
and scientists and Specialists and so on
and so forth so that that point Canada
Unity would have been out of it and he
would have taken it over the document
sir and if you go to article one you see
Canada unity and in Brackets see you and
then we come down to article 3A it says
see you so you're referring there to
Canada Unity right
correct
and if we can look at
uh
our article 3D
um
the the parties adopt and adhere to
various uh legislation that you've set
out there and uh coming down to E
um
scgc will affect the as of midnight on
that date instruct all levels of the
federal provincial Territorial and
Municipal governments to immediately
cease and desist all unconstitutional
human rights discriminatory and
segregated actions and not limited to
immediately instruct all levels of
federal provincial Territorial and
Municipal governments
to not only stop but furthermore wave
all stars cov2 and not limited to SARS
cov2 subsequent variation fines that
have been issued and imposed on its
citizens institutions and private
Enterprises
and so in that
the
this
scgc would have the authority to
instruct those levels of government to
do that if we'd all entered into a an
agreement this is just uh you know here
we'd like to talk about this but it
means nothing because nobody signed it
and nobody entered into it so yeah
remember that was the hope that we had
presented that we could sit down and
collectively come to an agreement to
cease and desist on all these unlawful
mandates and you understand sir that the
purpose of a memorandum of understanding
is to set out the principles that will
then be formalized into an agreement
right yeah I believe that's right here
in front of you that was our principles
that we wanted to and if we look at
paragraph f
um I won't read everything but uh there
but it's again instruct all levels of
government to reinstate all employees
and all branches of government
Private Industry institutional sector
employees with full lawful employment
rights prior to the wrongful dismissal
and unlawful dismissive
dismissal stemming from SARS cov2
and subsequent passport vaccine passport
mandates
and uh
if we can just and then we go over to G
um
the SC GGC will issue a cease and desist
order
abolishing all federal provincial
Territorial and Municipal vaccine ports
passport requirements vaccine
discriminatory regulations initiatives
and mandates regarding SARS cov2 correct
and so this committee would have the
power to issue a cease and desist order
if we had uh been able to get to that
aspect and the committee had come to an
agreement that uh we had proved our case
that all of this was unlawful at that
point and obviously uh The Next Step
would be to do a cease and desist
because of laws being broken and tyranny
and treason and crimes against humanity
that are listed within the document
and then uh
H provides for further cease and desist
order
to the members of the government of
Canada
with instructions to the premiers and
the mayors
to stop all such unlawful activities
pursuant to article 3 so they would have
the power to do that if you'd come to an
agreement
correct
and then
in Jay it says by signing this
memorandum Canada Unity will immediately
stop operation bear hug Ottawa
demonstration slash Convoy and federal
referendum activities and will strive to
work with all groups and entities to
bring this country together in unity
that was if you had this
memorandum agreed to then you were going
to stop the protest is that right
correct if we could have entered into an
agreement that would have been
that's all we wanted to do is
communicate with our government and we
tried every single option available to
us multiple multiple times we exhausted
all means of communication with this
government from one
part of Canada from coast to coast to
coast
and you'll see in
um just to further the the points you've
been making under l
there's to be a final signed agreement
in place within 90 days of accepting the
memorandum correct yeah we felt that 90
days would have been given enough time
to strike the Committees and talk to
Canada about this process and then from
there
sign into and enter into an agreement
and then if we can come down to article
4C
um
scgc will represent itself as the
government of Canada as a whole and not
party related correct you're saying that
SC GGC
is now the government of Canada no
no uh not even close in in correlation
to everything that we would be
discussing as a committee
we have the people and the government
together and that was you know the best
that we could come up with is that this
committee would bring forward on behalf
of the government of Canada and
represent uh the wills of of the
committee
okay and um and that it wouldn't and and
so
in that it wouldn't be party related
because when you look at the Liberals
versus the ndps versus the conservatives
there's so much division in that whole
process of governance right there in
itself that we didn't want the parties
being involved we wanted to have a
direct correlation to the source root of
our laws which is we believe the Senate
because they make the laws they amend
the laws and a very interesting part in
the Helsinki act that's listed in here
it comes from the Nuremberg codes
can enforce the laws
okay when our government has chosen
to completely ignore
all the the moral aspects that come from
the laws that so many people represent
and defend
so you're saying the Senate under those
acts has the right to enforce the laws
against the the elected government is
that what you're saying under the
Declaration
Helsinki
yes okay thank you now because we signed
on to it
as a government and as a country to
stand up for all humanity and end
discrimination and segregation and it is
a law that we as a country
let's just stay complicated I'm no I
know you're you're emotional and that
and that's understandable but if you try
and just Paul keep it down no I don't
apologize I don't have to apologize I
will calm down just just this is
emotional when we see our government
completely
violating all the laws I understand well
there's where do we turn to the Senate
is our last hope
and that's what's in their paychecks and
their job descriptions
now can I and you widely publicized the
your mou you wanted as many people as
possible to know what you were doing
correct yeah and um I want to skip ahead
if I can for
um
um well actually let me ask you first um
in when you were in um
Ottawa with um the the Canada Unity
Convoy I understand you sent this by
registered mail to uh the Senate and the
governor general is that right we sent
it all over and it's listed in the mlu
who we sent it to okay but those were
the people that you sent it to because
those are the parties and then you sent
it to a number of other entities correct
correct and um
foreign
if we can come forward for just a moment
and I'll come back to the freedom con
Convoy in January February 22.
um I understand
um one of your purposes uh was to again
see if you could get the attention of
the Senate and the
uh and the governor general to
sign this memorandum correct enter into
an agreement with it with the committee
and um when you were in
Ottawa in in uh
January February 2022 did you again send
it to those parties it's already been
sent I see okay and it was receiving an
enormous amount of support uh our
servers were going crazy and literally
and you were aware weren't you that the
governor general was getting a lot of
phone calls from people that supported
this no I wasn't okay why uh was that a
problem
I'm just asking the question sir
okay so was I
um now you told us before that uh you
withdrew the mou I think on February 8th
and if you can bring up uh
ott30s24296
.
foreign
you'll see that's addressed to honorable
Mary Simon governor general withdrawing
the memorandum of understanding
um
it has come to our attention that the
mou is being erroneously presented in
the house as a means of displacing the
democratically elected government this
was not the intention behind or purpose
of this document
um so you in effect retracted it correct
I didn't retract it was true
sorry I didn't retract I withdrew
okay
um
and if I had my last if I had my
statement I could actually bring that
statement up uh that I gave you
um
and
um
the um
and why did you do that
why did you withdraw it
I can tell you I didn't want to
and that I didn't need to
however
we had grown and morphed so fast
as a
humble family of Truckers coming
together
and there was documents flying Left
Right Center press releases Zoom calls
we were going at Mach 2 and two phones
and
and uh 18 gears
and I I think looking back at
the amount of work that we were doing
Nationwide to come together and put this
this Convoy together there were so many
people that had never heard of me and I
hadn't heard of them but we were all
coming together for the greater good so
one thing that we we had done is sit
down as a group and um
we had brought this forward Martin being
the the president of truckers United Inc
had a lot of truckers and
um
yeah we talked about the mou we
addressed that uh it deals with all of
our mandates
and it's a document that we're
presenting to the government to try to
communicate and we want to negotiate and
sit down and say hey you've created and
committed crimes against us by
unlawfully enacting these unlawful
mandates so we would like to sit down as
a group and the mou actually addresses
all of that it always did from day one
because two truckers sat down and wrote
it and a bunch of other truckers came in
at last minute
uh and uh they didn't get a privilege to
uh you know who here has actually read
the mou sorry sir that's not the way you
conduct yourself in this room would you
answer my question what's the question
again
let me suggest to you that you withdrew
it because there were people other
people associated with the freedom Envoy
so everybody let me finish this game
together in Ottawa and be finished
please sir I will thank you
you withdrew it because other people
involved in the freedom Conboy asked you
to do so because it was creating
problems for the very reasons that you
list there that people
um use a uh uh interpreted it as
displacing the democratically elected
government is that right correct thank
you and uh well I won't you did refer to
a document I don't think we have to
bring it up now but it's jba 6064
um where you explain that
um the memorandum of understanding was
officially withdrawn on February 8
because of external pressures after an
intense slanderous media smear campaign
directed at the group Canada unity and
the founders
the authors Martin brodman James boder
and and Sandra correct
yeah if they can just go back in time on
that because it was it was pretty Raw
I understand here here we are is is a
freedom
movement and
inside that Freedom Movement we have
been talking about fake media and all
the slander stuff they do and how our
government uses very very hateful
harmful wordsmithing directed at us
and
it was never the intention
to cause
confusion behind this but I love my
brothers and sisters that were coming
here so much that this mean this meant
nothing we'd already won because we came
here together in unity so in in our
perspective internally the fact that
they tuned on to CBC and CTV and Global
which they better be lowering up because
I'm going to be suing them for
everything on what they've done to me
and my family uh that's that's when it
was like this has gone so out of control
that it's lost
where it should be and at this point
I just said you know what team
we've won
the rest is in God's hands let's just
withdraw this from a a
temporary point of view and uh sit back
and observe and see where this goes so
right and the media was in your view
mischaracterizing it as an attempt to
overthrow Canada's democratic government
yeah uh so so
I I just want to put it out there that
um I want you to all think here for a
second here
they are unlawfully arrested sorry sir
I'm going to stop you this isn't the
place to give speeches you answer the
question and you've answered it thank
you there's more to ask but
could you
uh pull up uh Mr clerk ALB
four zeros one eight one nine
now are you familiar with the fact that
after the uh emergencies act came into
effect
There Was an explanation offered by the
government as to why they put it into
effect
I haven't seen this document before okay
I'll I just want to take you to one
paragraph and ask you about it if you
can go to page five please
um
so that paragraph that starts the
protests
if you look on the screen it's there
sir
the protests have become a rallying
point for anti-government and
anti-authority anti-vaccination
conspiracy theory and white supremacist
groups throughout Canada and other
Western countries protesters have
varying ideological grievances with
demands ranging from an end to all
public health restrictions to overthrow
the elected government
as one example
protest organizers have suggested
forming a coalition government
with opposition parties and the
involvement of governor general Mary
Simon was that part of your memorandum
of understanding nope this is hilarious
though and you see it says this
suggestion appears to be an evolution of
a previous proposal from a widely
circulated memorandum of understanding
from a group called Canada Unity that is
taking part in the Convoy
uh the memorandum of understanding
proposed that the Senate and governor
general to could agree to join them in
forming a committee
to order the revocation of covid-19
restriction and That vaccine mandates I
just want to deal with the issue of
appears to be an evolution in your view
did was there ever an evolution from the
member of andam of understanding uh to
suggest that there be a coalition
government with opposition parties and
the governor general no we talked about
that already in there very said that the
the reason that we didn't want the
parties in was because they weren't
invited this was just strictly the
people of Canada and to sit with their
Senate
um that was it and so I that this is
just this will help me actually with my
lawsuit when I sue them so thank you
you're welcome
now um
do you know Tom marazzo uh Mr Tom
I didn't know him did you ever talk to
him about your memorandum of
understanding yeah
I don't know if I can't really recall if
we did we talked for about 15 minutes uh
twice
over the phone and then in person
and then
and if we can uh we're grateful
I just want to show you a couple of
other
uh well in in the interests of time I
will uh
move on
um you mentioned a document before I
want to take you to it com
uh
five zeros eight five seven
Jeffrey for one second can I just
reference or Jason uh can you reference
well you can get it afterwards sir the
number was ALB
one eight one nine a l b
zero zero zero four zeros
lots of zeros one eight one nine point
zero zero sorry I'll give you that again
ALB
ERS one eight one nine thanks Jeffrey
got it yeah you're welcome
now um can we go to com
uh five zeros eight five seven
and I think you referred to to this uh
before and I wanted to give you a chance
uh uh to
tell me about you'll see it's a
again a Facebook post dated Facebook
post dated September 16 21 uh to
Constable Isabel Seer Pittock of the
Ottawa Police
um and you told us before that you uh
remained in in contact with the Ottawa
Police during the Canada Unity Convoy
correct and and was this part of the
contact that you were talking about yeah
so I mean speaking of of contact with
the police the uh prior to us getting
involved we took this mou to police on
guard for the Nationwide and we were
ecstatic as two truck drivers that this
prestigious honored group of Canadians
that represent our police and our
military would endorse the mou
Nationwide and uh you're kind of
venturing off the questions so get a
chance at the end yeah we were a
statement or something so let okay sorry
because we want to try and get through
it because there's some stuff I like to
tell stories I know you do and it's
obvious but
we're going to try and control this okay
thank you this I I can tell you that
this document is in evidence now and it
will be reviewed as part of the process
of the Commission in in uh coming to its
uh conclusions I'd like to take you now
to the freedom Conboy in uh
that in the period of uh January uh
February 2022.
um I understand that you your view is
that this was just a continuation of the
planning that you started in August 20
in August of 21. correct we didn't stop
our whole team just uh 24 7.
every day we were doing it we were going
and we were standing up for an awful
freedom of choice and
um at some point you uh
were be put in touch with um
some other people who were thinking of
organizing a convoy as well
when in uh in late December early
January
that King I oh
uh yeah remember
calling me wanting in on this Convoy so
who called you uh about that do you
remember uh
no what what are you where are you going
out with just Jeffrey well a lot
remember called you about
uh getting a convoy going the end of
December early January uh
a lot of people were calling me to get a
like we were already did you speak to
Chris Barber uh nope until the zoom call
I didn't know Chris before okay I met
him on a zoom who who invited you to the
zoom call uh at king
um I told Pat to put us so
you're referring to how we all came
together as a team okay so but I believe
just to answer my my questions and and
we'll get through this yeah so you got
to be a little bit more you know like if
you're looking for specific information
and who I was talking to then just put
their name so let's go to the the uh
Facebook live event that was hosted by
Pat King that was January 13th okay and
did you know Mr King at this point yep
how did you know uh he was with uh the
Convoy uh that we came here to Ottawa
with uh back in 2018. and did you follow
him on social media not really no okay
um
and I and you recall that Bridget Belton
and Chris Barber
uh also
participated in in that Facebook live
yes and um later on uh you uh
met Tamara Leach
here in the arc hotel for the first time
okay and I didn't talk to her I just
seen her
and I never met her before and I talked
to her on the phone prior to launching
all this I did my due diligence to make
sure that um
uh are our trusted and vested interest
in in this whole movement
um one thing that
you don't want to put truck drivers with
with funds and stuff like that we got
enough to do and we were looking for and
trying to recruit uh somebody that we
could trust uh to handle all the funds
and I remember uh talking with with
Bridget
and then talking and she'd mentioned uh
that Chris was hooked up with her and
they were you know building the Convoy
they were going to do some slow rolls
and stuff like that and I think we'd
mentioned uh that we already had bear
hug Canada so that was the you know for
for those that couldn't come to Ottawa
bear hug Canada would represent the slow
rolls and so on and so forth can I just
stop you there those were individual uh
protests that you had uh were promoting
across the country Nationwide yeah so
um at that point yeah we all came
together on a big zoom and yeah and so
um
I I understand that you're what from
your perspective what happened then was
that um
uh this was a uh you provided
the the structure for
uh people to
participate in this uh
Convoy by providing the material that
you'd already worked up and developed
for your own Convoy uh all the
logistical aspects behind the scenes
with with our national Partnerships that
we established uh that you know they
were all involved uh already and anybody
was welcome because we're about Unity so
we were you want in come on in uh we
don't care uh this is for uh all of
Canada to come together in unity so
and so um
were you in touch with the uh you left
Calgary uh when uh on this uh
to recall which time
for the uh in
January of 22. yeah you know when we
left yeah and um
were you in touch with the you yourself
were you in touch with the police along
the way extensively every day
uh talking about what sort of things uh
we had all sorts of roots going on we
had
captains of the yin yang that were
coming in the
uh Western route was was pretty easy to
put together uh it was the Eastern uh
Southern eastern Ontario Roots they gave
us a lot of logistical
stress and we had to work very very
carefully with with multiple police uh
individuals and so what we did was
instead of working I worked at the with
uh with staff surgeons that had been
working with since August 1st so hey
we're coming back how you doing uh get
prepared and then from there they
started funneling
um police to start connecting in with
the captains and so and as we started
bringing more captains in then we would
start working on the the roots in the
back end so that it all flowed and if
you look at all the route maps and
everything else everything flowed into
Wellington
so and um I I take it that you were in
contact with both the opp and the
Ottawa Police Services OPP PPS and Ops
and so what happened when you got to uh
Ottawa
how did where did you what did were you
directed to go somewhere I was in uh
kimmingham from the west and uh what I
wanted to do was hook up with Martin
brodman and
I knew that Bridget was bringing in uh
the the
the crew and and our family coming in
from Southern Ontario and and and uh it
was always planned uh that she would
come in a day ahead of time and then
that actually turned out to we had to
split it up at the last minute because
there was just so many trucks and it was
just so large so that became a Friday
and a Saturday event
um
then from there I left to get literally
drove all night kind of thing so that we
could get over to meet with uh the
Eastern Convoy as the Western Conway
with Chris and and Tamara they're coming
in
Bridget's in with all the the captains
from uh the southern area and there's
still more captains coming in on that
day as well
uh so then we're bringing the west or
sorry we've got the West roots and then
we went and grabbed uh the east route so
that we could uh all come together at
unity and when you came together
um and about to enter
Ottawa
were you being directed where to go yeah
we were shamboozled and blindsided
because I can tell you that was not the
original plans that we had set down with
those please
uh if you looked at the original mapping
that was well well posted it was all
points lead into Wellington
and we had really good detailed mopping
on that so you can imagine our surprise
when we get to these blockades that
honestly
a real Convoy
do a 98 crash the gate we got us a
convoy
we didn't crash no Gates because we
respect the laws we respect the citizens
we were working in partnership with the
police
but when we hit that that you know the
edge town and we're like this isn't this
isn't what we planned on and from that
point on
it
you know I got a lot of flack for that
people were blaming me and throwing me
under the bus as soon as I got downtown
it's like and I was like I didn't do
this this is what were they blaming you
for uh for not getting the trucks in to
Wellington like we had all agreed on and
was the plan for all the trucks to be on
Wellington there was two mean routes
that were on our maps and our Logistics
team had uh put that in and our maps are
uploaded into the server so there again
uh you'd have to bring those back up for
and and review them all but it was
two main corridors that we'd had and I
don't have that off the top of my head
and uh
and so where did you yourself go I went
back to Confederation Park to start with
unity one and that's where I parked
Unity one and then straight over to the
arc hotel and what uh the type of
vehicle where you drive
a 1991 Glendale Royal classic that
was adopted and named Unity One not by
us but
uh
sorry for uh Unity one because it was
the first it was the first
Convoy vehicle that started this Unity
movement and what size vehicle is that
that's big it's 30-footer okay and uh
can you put up uh please Mr Clerk opp00
1489
this is a document you won't have seen
before
Mr bowder but it's uh comes from the
Ontario provincial police report and
it's dated January 28th
2022
um
if you can go to item five I believe it
is
and it refers to a
video posted on the Canada Unity
Facebook page
um
and it says James boder who is driving
in the Convoy indicates that operation
bear hug was intended to bring
the law to Ottawa and they will not
leave the city until the law has been
restored and they get their thoughtful
Freedom back is that something that you
you can recall communicating to the opp
that you talk direct yeah multiple times
and then it says uh well botter states
that they have made plans so that
members of the public and public
transportation in Ottawa will not be
disrupted let me stop there what were
those plans
from day one Convoy one
always keep the lanes open that was well
communicated we had a code of conduct
that uh everybody had agreed to had been
distributed to all the truckers
uh well communicated in the between the
captains and the police we worked in
Partnership together uh multiple times
conversations and so on and so forth and
Public Safety has always been precedent
number one
always
so anything that we could do working
together in Partnership and that that
actual word was used multiple times
partnership and safety
thank you and it goes on
to say he also hints that there are
plans that they cannot make public for
strategic and security reasons where's
that
powder further states that he
anticipates that they will win in
Ottawa after which they will proceed to
the United States to support the truck
drivers there was that part of your
what date is it what date is this
January 28 2022 28 22. yeah
um
we lit up the world and our brothers and
sisters down south uh in the Border uh
all the truck drivers they started
seeing what we're doing and uh yeah they
were pretty excited and they started
convoying down there and we figured well
when this is done uh maybe we'll go down
there and we'll give them some support
because they're supporting us up here so
that was what that was about and then it
says
um he further references a memorandum of
understanding that has been prepared
that once signed will result in prime
minister Trudeau Aaron O'Toole and the
NDP leader stepping down is that
something that uh you you told the the
opp
um don't recall
sorry I mean obviously I mean if if we
catch them uh committing treason
which we believe they have uh they'd be
stepping down right
and all the evidence that we wanted to
sit down with the Senate and say here
you know we we believe our government is
committing treason uh enforce the laws
please Senate uh at that point yes we
would definitely expect to see Trudeau
and uh well Aaron O'Toole isn't any more
uh but uh you know applicable members
that uh would they be identified uh
throughout uh Canada that have committed
treason
and crimes against humanity and we will
never stop until that is public and on
you know another hearing needs to come
from us
um I see my time is up could I have a
few more minutes please you actually
have another 15 minutes oh I do I'm good
well we we uh it's your lucky day keep
it going
actually it's for 13 minutes thank you
um
now you told us you were in uh you
parked your your vehicle in
Confederation Park and um I understand
that um
there were some people who set up a TP
in Confederation part were you part of
that a TB yeah uh there was no teepees
we wanted TPS and we could have had
teepees uh but there was no teepees that
I was aware of was there an incident
that uh
um the police spoke to about uh uh
regarding uh Pat King
things that were going on at
Confederation Park correct and can you
briefly tell the commissioner what that
was so a couple of days into uh
landing at the ark it was pretty hectic
and chaotic and I was very blessed to
come across these two uh
Tribal Sovereign
mothers
that I met at the ark hotel and being my
wife is Algonquin it was a very
interesting conversation and and you
know we respect our elders deeply and
when two Clan Moms come up do you want
to talk to you and you know the
relevance behind confed Park is that
when we were here for bear hug one we
had attained the permission
to use confed Park and we attained the
permission again to use confed Park okay
so we had all that in play uh for bear
hug one and bear hug 2. so that's why we
took Unity One took inside Park and our
team was down there and then comes along
um what I think is
controlled op
because what I was seeing from from Pat
King
and then this incident that happened at
confed Park where
this uh
what I learned from the the clan mums
was that there was a fake Chief named
chief JD Anderson
he's claiming himself as a chief but I
find out from the clan mums who are the
hierarchy and the law in tribal that
this was not the case and that
um he was running around Ottawa and
there was a
so I'm a truck I don't know anything
about controlled off and all the rest of
that stuff and a lot of us didn't that's
why we had to call police on guard and
help you know get in here and I take it
that there was lots of those little
incidents and Bubbles of just you know
[ __ ] disturbers right looking for your
attention and I take it that at some
point it got wrapped up in that yeah and
then they did something that is very
wrong
um they started a fire and a sacred fire
okay there's a difference between
starting a a you know a burn barrel kind
of thing but this
fake Chief was running around and Pat's
there and all these controlled op people
that we'd identified were hanging out
and it just was very greasy it wasn't
this wasn't our
you know that they basically just sort
of were taking confed park over and from
there
that caused a lot of conflict and I take
it uh that ultimately uh they uh they oh
it got big this incident just about
caused a like it was you have no idea
what happened behind the scenes and that
took me out okay you didn't know where
James was putting fires out trying to
stop uh the Indian natives uh you know
from going after pat King and and these
fake Chiefs so I worked with the clan
mums who then worked with City Hall I
worked with the police and together we
worked in Partnership for safety and we
had to shut down confed Park and I was
mad
because had that not had that event
not happened
the clan moms were working to try to
bring in some teepees and you can
imagine if we'd had some teepees there
because that would have completed the
circle of unity
without our tribal
we have no unity in this country
and they were very much a big part of
this Unity movement from coast to coast
to coast so we were really excited to
get thank you an opportunity and sadly
controlled obviously so
um
there we've heard evidence about
um various complaints made by residents
when the Convoy was in Ottawa things
like constant honking uh smell of diesel
fumes harassment did you see an
experience that
I experienced the biggest
Unity celebration in my life
and with that you got everything else
that comes with it and just a few more
questions
um
did you have any contact with truckers
that were um
organizing uh blockades at Windsor nope
Coots nope Emerson nope Siri nope
and
yesterday
um Mr marazzo
um
in his evidence he he we had a live
stream press conference from February
7th
and he made the statement
I'm willing to sit at a table with the
conservatives in the NDP and the block
as a coalition
I'll sit with the governor general put
us at the table with somebody that
actually cares about Canada did you know
about that statement no did you have
anything to do with it no
sounds like a good statement though
that's what we wanted to do
and Tom was entrusted uh deeply uh and
we're very grateful for Tom
very grateful
he was exactly what we needed to help a
bunch of truckers out that had a lot of
emotions
a lot of fears
we had
multiple police officers and agencies
there's just so much going on I
understand
I think they had a at some point after
the emergency Act was invoked I
understand that you and your your wife
were arrested all right correct and I
actually would like to bring that
they blew up if we could because uh that
shows how long is the video not even
sexy quick from the least show part of
it relevant because it it really is um
it's the new video that you just
received you you oh no go ahead yeah
that's yeah the one that I just yes that
we had problems with yes this is the
hearing clerk just for everyone's
benefit uh that video is a jba 6081
thank you
[Music]
so I'm just coming out of the arc Hotel
here on Sunday
okay
Constable here if you're planning on
leaving yes we were and you can see the
blockade of snow where we couldn't leave
we were obstructed we couldn't leave if
we tried
just down the other side behind Unity
one here just down the road there's a
snow clearing crew coming down
especially with it
so you're willing to leave right now we
don't need to take action
okay okay
right there we're cooperating
now also when I came down I was
blindsided I hadn't even had my morning
coffee or nothing and 15 of these
officers had a crowbar they were trying
to break into Unity One I said hey
I'll get the keys okay uh please don't
don't hurt it
and uh ran back up I grabbed my keys I
came back down
I want out
to anybody
well I know so the question is they're
going to give you time to check out well
we're talking minutes minutes how am I
supposed to get out of that in minutes
well can you back it up and go out uh an
RV don't back out of that crap
I was blocked by Ottawa
City Crews that didn't do their job and
clean the streets
vehicles that are parked in this zone
are all being toten's East
find your own way home
[Music]
I actually don't okay what's your name
Stu Stu where do you live I'm in the
hotel here where do you live is this
your house actually I'm homeless and
I've lived downtown Ottawa you live
downtown Ottawa no I'm homeless
I don't have ID
I've got I guess my health card
this video
is over
the conversation is over what part of
that you don't understand we've already
arrested two people at this location
yeah absolutely
so when I run your name they're going to
tell me your address is going to come
back to what find your own way home
probably somewhere in Sudbury because
I'm homeless and I've been in Ottawa
since uh Canada day and I've been living
here I'm on the like uh
at what point can we forward it yeah
just a little bit about sure try there
okay let's try there yeah
[Music]
maybe back
keep going keep going
I think what you're gonna see from here
I don't know
keep going I there is audio extensive
audio behind this okay well it's a
little too long at this time because
it's already I don't know but we get I
was arrested your evidence to what
happened to you uh you'll notice that we
cooperated completely and if you
got the rest of this you would you would
you would see that my wife and I were
very lawful very peaceful very
respectful as we always have been with
the police those are my questions sir
thank you okay thank you
um if we could uh I could call on the
government of Canada please
good afternoon Mr bowder afternoon my
name is Brendan vanillis and I'm one of
the lawyers for the government of Canada
in this matter
happy birthday thank you
I wonder if we could go to a document
that you wrote I think after you had
left Ottawa which time it's jba 6043
on the first time the second time or the
third time because I did three National
Nationwide convoys I'm not sure you
might have to tell me but um let me just
ask you first if this is a letter that
you prepared
yep
um and looking at it I suppose it in
fact you were still on the as you say on
the front line in Ottawa when you wrote
it and you talk about having been there
for about three weeks right
can you just uh
shrink this down a little bit so I can
just
I I mean there's there's so much that uh
okay so what's your what what do you
need good question so this is a document
that you wrote and made public after
being in Ottawa for about three weeks
okay is that fair okay
and
if we look at the seventh paragraph on
the page
um it's the one that starts the call for
Freedom unity and love has gone out and
Canadians answer do you see that correct
and in the last sentence of that
paragraph you say that you made a choice
you Canadians I guess made a choice to
come to Ottawa to Coots to Windsor and
make your stand for freedom is it fair
all across Canada Coast to Coast we came
together for our freedoms and you told
them Mr Leon that you were not in
contact directly with the participants
at the events in Coots and Windsor for
example while you were in Ottawa but you
were grateful for the response across
the country is that fair
foreign
because they chose Unity over division
and
you accomplished more than you could
have hoped to accomplish in terms of the
national and international response is
that fair Mr bowder
you um
saw that what you had done inspired the
protests at the borders in Coots Windsor
and Emerson Manitoba for example
what I had done I did what were you
another sit down you and what you and
others we Team Canada had done
the collective you when I ask those
questions
and that um those efforts by you and
others
um
also inspired events at the Thousand
Islands bridge near Cornwall the blue
water in Sarnia Port Huron Crossing the
Peace Bridge the Fort Francis Crossing
in the Confederation Bridge Bridge in
Prince Edward Island right
it was a a lot of people
coming together because they were in
pain you inspired convoys in Surrey BC
Vancouver Toronto Quebec City Regina and
Winnipeg
I Convoy for Freedom it's what we do so
if if I'm uh guilty of anything it's uh
because I loved Convoy and I love
looking for my freedom that's missing so
apparently other people you know they
wanted to Convoy to on their own Accords
under the Bill of Rights and
and similar convoys were inspired in the
United States too right
well we started campaigning uh
strategically bear hug uh which I I'm
still
wowed uh at how that traveled around the
world
um it was
Convoy for freedom freedom for Convoy
and bear hug those three
just exploded around the world and it's
still amazing it's goodly it went as far
as New Zealand Australia Paris Belgium
Finland and the Netherlands right
thank you
and the United Kingdom okay
worldwide we had the biggest Unity
movement in the world that echo's town
in history and that's
All of Us Canada thank you for coming
together in unity and showing the world
what this is all about
thank you
could we go to your statement of
evidence which is submitted which you
submitted to the commission it's jba60
this is the statement that you you
prepared and you submitted this um I
guess over the weekend eh
oh boy oh boy you're bringing this one
up are you
this is the evidence statement that you
were asking Mr Leon to see earlier
Canada this is the one that you want to
look at and download and read because it
has links to evidence contained within
that link Trudeau to treason
we'll come back to that could we go to
page four please
if you could go to the towards the
bottom of the page under the heading the
launch of Canada Unity Convoy for
freedom
you see that area there
yep
and you describe in the first paragraph
under that heading that what happened to
you in the spring of 2021 that led to
the launch of Canada Unity right yep
and I understand from what you've
written here that
your employer
where you are a full-time truck driver I
came to you and said that you would need
to provide proof that you'd been
injected with the covet vaccines
in order to be allowed access to
their clients facilities right
yeah
and um
and therefore you say that you were
forced to quit your job right
yeah
and that's because if you were not
willing to become vaccinated then you
would not be able to continue to attend
at your employer's clients place of
business right
vaccinated with the RMA uh Gene altering
therapy uh yes
um
and that was a requirement that was
imposed upon your employer as a
condition of continuing to do business
with the client right correct
and to be clear that was not a decision
that was imposed upon you by uh
government is that fair
no that's not fair
okay
could we go to page six please
okay sir can you back up and what was
that question again
they said that that was not a decision
that was imposed upon you by government
oh no that uh 100 was imposed by this
federal government as the mean root of
all of it and then followed by
provincial governments that are so eager
for a little piece of the trough to get
some money and then the municipal
governments at the very end uh so a
three-ring circus of of just
total unlawful issue of unlawful
mandates that's that's your explanation
for why you quit your employment Mr
bowder no I quit my employment because I
never got to put that ever in me I I
don't have any problems with vaccines of
travel internationally I got lots of
vaccines okay those are medically
approved and tested and everything else
but there's no darn way I'm going to put
some Gene altering therapy into me
that's no good and and no way that's my
medical uh rights that's my lawful
rights and there's so many laws that are
in this mou that highlight that
Canada
could we go to page seven please of this
document
the second last paragraph on the page
please
shoot I may have the wrong page excuse
me a moment
you'd said six before but
foreign
I just don't want to get it wrong twice
that's why we're here because we did get
it wrong
we chose division over unity and
hopefully we'll get it right and we
don't have to go down this path again
just we can just wait for the question
excuse me it is page six second last
paragraph on page six
you see at the end of that paragraph Mr
bowder you've
written here that the words Convoy for
freedom and operation bear hug got out
internationally deeply embarrassing our
liberal minister
specifically Trudeau and Freeland as
they were called out by the
International Community
as they rightfully should be you see
that yep
who specifically in the International
Community did you have in mind when you
I don't have names there's videos all
over the place uh like you'd have to do
that research yourself
there's a lot of evidence out there and
if you would like or you need evidence
by all means I can provide it I just
don't have that recollection off the top
of my head today
I just wanted to understand what you had
meant to do that's all that's it thank
you
um
could we go now to another document that
is a letter from you of February the
16th it's jba 6 or Sorry Seven zeros
eight
you see this is a letter from Canada to
Unity I take it by you that you
submitted to the commission and wrote to
the Ottawa Police do you see that
correct
and if we look at the third and fourth
paragraph on the page please
starting with the the paragraph that
starts Canada unity and the Convoy for
Freedom do you see that correct can you
say that God you're also very concerned
to hear about the estimated 2 000
missing firearms for Peterborough
Ontario right
when crimes are committed what do we do
we call the police okay and we had Intel
we couldn't confirm or deny or anything
we just had Intel and any intel of
crimes being committed that we could
identify
hey right away 9-1-1 this was a little
bit more important that required because
it just as you can see the the the this
was more where I felt that if it was put
in a document uh that maybe it would get
a little bit more um
uh assistance from the police to make
sure that uh if you can scroll the very
top
and I'm not a I'm not a weapons expert
all I know is that that lrad weapon
um was causing a lot of fear amongst
everybody and it was so we wanted to do
our best remember we're Partnerships
with the police all the way through hey
what's going on uh can you please
address this and and put uh everybody at
peace because if that had been the case
we would have all said no no I would
have contacted everybody I would have
stood on buildings and said
no please
well if you just go back to my question
you'd become aware around February the
13th when it came out in the newspapers
that there had been a trailer of
approximately 2 000 stolen firearms
from a trailer in Peterborough Ontario
is that what you're referring to
from the best of I mean
whatever's here is what I can recall
from what was happening there was a lot
going on I was just you don't dispute
that timing no this is just a risk
mitigation process to try to uh you know
give uh the police an opportunity to
respond and do some uh and you say your
concern is not least because of that
number of firearms clips and ammo being
so easily taken but because of their
unknown location right yeah that's the
evidence I mean we were getting into all
that this was happening and they didn't
know where it was so
and and you immediately if you look to
the next paragraph you said we have
concerns that these weapons will be used
against peaceful demonstrators or the
citizens of Ottawa in order to blame the
participants of this lawful
demonstration right correct
you you were concerned that there was a
connection between the events of the uh
that were occurring in Auto on the
freedom Convoy and the theft of this
large quantity of firearms right I
didn't know anything uh other than I got
some Intel and I can't connect any of
the dots I'm not a you know this is just
um an observational request letter
really
um that this is stuff that I'm getting
it's concerning it's deeply concerning
and I don't have all the evidence or the
facts but please investigate and then
put us put us at ease sure sure and you
knew by February the 16th about the fact
that a large quantity of firearms had
been
seized under search warrant in Coots
Alberta at the border blockade right
I'd heard of uh
some stuff that was uh being seized and
so on and so forth at that time
regardless it was a reasonable concern
for you to wonder if there was a
connection between these stolen firearms
in Peterborough and what was going on in
Ottawa Windsor and elsewhere yeah
because this was so close
um
when you get a rumor or a specula you
don't play around with this like this is
serious business and it's over my pay
grade and I felt that the rate response
was to notify the police so
I think we did thank you Mr butter those
are all my questions thank you
thank you next uh or the
Convoy organizers
good afternoon Mr bowder my name is
Brendan Miller and I'm counsel to the
freedom Corp which is an organization
that represented the protesters that
were here in Ottawa in January and
February 2022 I am the Lesser better
looking Brandon come with the lawyers
come come forward or butcher Mike a
little bit because yes very very okay
so I want to First discuss with you
again you've mentioned and has been put
in evidence this memorandum of
understanding right correct so I take it
that was just basically a piece of paper
Fair yeah right and therein and nothing
that I've seen at least Canada Unity has
never called for any form of violence no
now you never called to violently throw
overthrow the government of Canada never
you never offered to do any form of
sabotage like blowing up Bridges or
anything like that no no you didn't
actually can I from that one there
speaking of rumors again we got a rumor
that our big trucks down in in Windsor
uh or the big bridge down there right
um that the vibration
so we put a call out used our social
media hey everybody if this is the case
uh out
um get off that bridge okay and that's
that's all that I could do from my
position to try to risk mitigate right
uh anything to do with risk right I'm
gonna jump in and try to take a high
risk down to alert right but uh I take
it that there was no motivation and uh
no expression on part of your
organization yourself uh to call for any
form of violence or destruction of
property no we're calling for love and
unity and and peace and and giving bear
hugs I mean violence is the last thing
in our minds now you don't have to
answer this question and I'm just
telling you because you don't have a
lawyer because what I'm about to ask you
is subject to privilege okay so you
don't have to answer it you're not
required did you have a lawyer help you
prepare the memorandum of understanding
no okay no just two truck drivers two
truck drivers so it's just a document
written by two truck drivers yes all
right with no legal advice no all right
and you can agree with me that in that
document of course it it's proposing
that the governor general and the Senate
would essentially take over government
in consultation with the committee is
not take over government yeah no
they would because the the those are the
key holders of our laws okay when when
Trudeau messes up we're supposed to be
able to go to the governor general and
have a communication with her or whom
him or whoever is is elected in that
position and when you research into the
Helsinki act you're going to find a very
very interesting right and I don't I
don't need to this is just the only
question I just want to make sure you're
clear you understand of course the
governor general is appointed by the
Prime Minister correct right and you
understand that senators are appointed
correct in Canada so those are
non-democratic actors right yep right so
can you agree with me that what you were
actually asking for was somewhat of an
undemocratic solution
yeah well Democratic I guess uh I mean
if you're asking uh to come together uh
at a table and communicate
um and you know if they don't respond
you have nothing right right you got
nothing right and you're going to
communicate yourself and do the wall
because it takes two parties to make an
mou right okay somebody the other thing
I want to ask you is this is that my
clients Freedom Corp Tamara Lich Tom
morrazzo uh Chris Barber et cetera none
of them
supported the memorandum of
understanding they actually asked you to
withdraw it right it was them who
requested it I didn't hear them requests
they didn't come to me personally and
say James would you request this my wife
and The Sovereign Clan mums
um we talked and out of respect uh just
to say hey I mean it's it served its
purpose okay at that point because of
other situations with the freedom Corp
where I was put Tom in place and then
from there I backed off because I was
dealing with all the [ __ ] that Pat had
been doing and everything else and I
didn't even get a chance to come and
talk to the freedom Corp I don't even
know who they were okay and so really I
didn't know who the freedom Corp was
until weeks down the road all right and
I take it my friend uh uh with the
government he put two-year discussion or
a statement that you made about the
Prime Minister had been condemned by the
International Community do you remember
when he put that to you just moment yeah
right was what you're making reference
to just to remind you was it the March
2022 incident where the Prime Minister
was to speak uh in European Parliament
and a bunch of the members of parliament
walked out and gave speeches against him
invoking the emergencies Act is that
what you were referring to yeah that's
the like there's evidence out there it's
pretty easy to find but yeah that's it
thank you
okay thank you uh next nice to meet the
freedom Corp for the first time
I call on the Ottawa Police Service
thank you very much my name is David
mishakovsky I'm a lawyer for the Ottawa
Police Service Mr botter
nice to meet you Dave thank you you too
I understand that you participated you
said in an earlier Convoy to Ottawa is
that right yeah and that was the United
We Roll yeah that was in 2019 correct
and I believe in that case you um ended
up staying in Ottawa for several weeks
2019.
in 2019 yeah no we came we we were here
for three days and we went back home
three days yeah and it was peaceful
yeah and were you uh parked on
Wellington I believe uh we were there
and then we were out at uh arm prior and
then we came back in I think it was back
and forth for a couple of days honked
our horns and went home and you
maintained contact with the police while
I was not an organizer in that first
2019. that was uh compliments of Glenn
carrot and Hayley whale
I was just uh I was here with my camera
and I was a participant and I was
invited to be on the Convoy because uh
you know trucker and and I was just
invited I was a participant and and my
wife had told me uh she says James this
is my first launch of Canada Unity kind
of thing she said it's not about you
point the camera on everybody else and
give them their voice and let their
voice be on the platform sorry I wasn't
an organizer of 2019 at all no capacity
at all appreciate that uh but you were
here with a number of other vehicles
correct and you had no issues with the
police no no problems not that I was
aware no I was too busy feeding the
homeless in Ottawa okay and so you
there'd be no reason for the police to
suspect this time that the Convoy you
participated in would cause problems
because it didn't last time either
correct no correlation at all none
and I wasn't involved in the with with
any of the dealings with the police uh
for 2019 at all uh just a participant I
just want to talk about the parking
situation
um you talked about where you could park
in Ottawa do you recall that which time
uh this time okay and I think uh the
first Bear Hugger the second bear hook
I'm sorry the first bear hug or the
second bear hook
the this time when you were here in
February okay second bear hug two right
okay and so you said you were um given
some maps so if we could just maybe call
up that map uh it's jba four zeros zero
zero six eight
and so you'll see this uh it we'll just
stroll through it for a minute and then
I'll come back to it can you just back
up for a second please sure
take direction from the police when a
replicable leave open space for emergent
vehicles at all times no closed trailers
permitted on Wellington uh all staging
areas must be kept on adjacent emergency
vehicle yeah yeah
and this is what you were referring to
and then there's some maps if we scroll
down
yeah
there's a lot of maps right so this is
what you were talking about the
information you had correct Logistics
and planning and all sorts of stuff and
so if we um could please look at people
that was a big team that put this all
together were you coming eastbound on
Highway 417 which time this time uh I
actually came in from the East right so
with Martin and the Eastern Convoy
okay so were you traveling eastbound on
Highway 417
uh
eastbound
no westbound you were coming outbound I
I'm from Calgary I don't know your
States and these Maps I got a big team
okay okay and I know that they
specialized in doing a lot of logistics
and and mapping and everything else and
just know that I overviewed and I made
sure that the main uh the safety points
were in in in correlation for all of our
captains and if our captains had any
problems or questions and we would make
a wreck you know and so you weren't able
to park on Wellington this year correct
yeah all points lead to Wellington and
so you'll see on page three the map uh
shows
um uh parking only in CR uh Lane
capacity 38 tractor trailers do you see
that on Wellington yeah and so uh that
was our goal all the way along was take
the curbs leave the center open for
everybody and then we're there lawfully
and we're you know right thank you you
see there's a limited amount of parking
on Wellington if you know how long sorry
if you know how long a block is and how
long 53 foot trailer is and so on and so
forth and you do the math roughly you
can get about 38 tractors in there right
so you you agree with me there was
limited parking and you knew that on
Wellington Street correct
yeah right and so if we keep scrolling
down
there are then uh instructions for where
vehicles uh are supposed to come in
depending on whether they're coming from
the west or the East and there are
staging areas for those Vehicles correct
yep
so there's nothing that's suggested that
there was unlimited parking on
Wellington correct
nope okay
and um if you could also look at um OPP
uh speaking of maps and parking if we
could just turn up uh Oppo uh
four zeros uh four two six one
laughs
and so if we could turn please to page
five
uh you will see on the bottom uh well if
you look at Parliament Hill area one
you'll see the traffic plan provides
that a decision will be made by The
Incident Commander based on the location
of the individual convoys on when to
shut down traffic in this key area and
then if you scroll down a little further
where it's a stacking area you'll see
the real estate roadway on Wellington
will be filled on a first come first uh
on a first come basis no spots reserved
and then vehicles are to be staged along
Wellington uh
uh and so there were Specific
Instructions you understood as to where
the convoys were supposed to be uh
parking correct correct
um and then just finally just to
um
conclude
um there is um
an article in I believe Vice magazine
about you have you seen that one
you got it
um well let me let me just get a
reference that do you want to pull it up
um let me just ask you
um this sir the article talks about
um
um you having
um
uh
Facebook uh postings saying that the
2020 election in the U.S was rigged
what's that have to do with this yeah
if those are if that's what's posted on
you I believe that it was right but
right what's that got to do with this
and you've shared on that Facebook
hashtags for Q Anon
there yeah so and um that 911 was
planned by a shadowy uh government body
is that correct
if I if you've seen it uh there again
you're you're trying to make me recall
stuff uh that I don't have uh to recall
but I'm gonna take your word uh okay
that you've seen it with your own eyes
obviously that you're trying to do stuff
but what's the point what does that have
to do with us being here to talk about
an emergency act that was unlawfully
invoked by Trudeau
right and um
sorry I didn't mean to cut you off just
to finish off
um I understand and I'll pull up this
document and maybe you could just
confirm it it's uh OPP four zeros3562
and if we could um please go to page
five
just going to ask you about two pages on
it
third
bullet under opens
Source information sorry
yeah and so it indicates an image of
Ottawa Police notice to demonstrators
has been posted to the freedom Convoy
Facebook group page
and you see that
yep okay and is that in fact correct you
did see that notice to protesters
negative
you did not see it nope this is
Freedom Convoy 22 I'm Conway for
freedoms the original
okay so you didn't you didn't see that
okay
and then if you could please go
um
to uh page seven
the second paragraph I believe
yeah you're actually highlighted in
there and it indicates police
information indicates James Bater of
Canada Unity was more so aligned with uh
king that's Pat King his current
position as to who he may align with or
direct his some odd 40 odd trucks
remains a gap so am I correct that you
are were in fact aligned with uh Mr King
in what perspective uh in terms of your
participation in in the uh so packing I
mean it's no secret I mean the guy is a
social media guy and and that's what we
brought pop King in for it was social
media and he was really good at it plus
he also had a background in in convoys
and Logistics and stuff like that so I
mean pot was pot and
um but we don't have to agree that's the
beauty of of of all of this is that we
all had individual rights to be here and
we came together as a team with our
indifferences right and um and then it
talks about you having about 40 odd
trucks uh that you believed were in your
controls that is that a reasonable
estimate no it was more or less
um with respect to what date when and 40
trucks like I I don't even that would
you would have some influence on whether
they would stay or go
I don't have influence over anybody
that's exercising their Bill of Rights
nor would I ever want to okay thank you
all free will to come here on our own
thank you very much Miss you're welcome
thank you
okay next is the uh Ontario Provincial
Police the opp
you're on mute or we can't hear you so
is he here in the court no he's uh oh
zoom zoom zoom oh okay we're High Times
can you hear me okay now yes we can yep
okay I guess there might be a bit of a
delay which caused that issue Bob and
Sir can you see me in here can see me on
the screen and hear me okay
yep
right my name is Chris Diana I'm counsel
to the opp I just have a couple of
questions that just arose out of some of
the evidence that you gave in response
to questions from my friend Council to
government of Canada
uh he brought you to a document where
you expressed some concern that a number
of firearms had been stolen from the
Peterborough area do you remember that
yes
and I take it you were concerned about
the possible existence of firearms
perhaps in your area there
rightfully yes
all right do you know what happened with
those Firearms nope uh that was the last
I heard of it was that report and then
from there I got distracted uh and off
to another
putting out something else
okay so I would put to you and just
because I don't think that's information
that should should be out there without
resolution but I would put to you that
those Firearms were recovered only a
couple of days after they were stolen uh
do you know that no I I honestly after
that uh there was a lot of other things
and I just didn't get a chance to uh
follow back on it but I'm glad that uh
you know
um if if we were able to help uh in any
way and just alert yeah you know it's
just one of those things when you see
something yeah phone Crime Stoppers kind
of thing so we were just doing it to
help but sir thanks I think Police
Services were aware of it but
commissioner I think this is an
important fact that again that I don't
think should be just kind of out there
is a loose end and although this
document was not on the list to be put
to the witness I think it's relevant to
this issue and so I would like to refer
to it now on this point and that's
document OPP four zeros1549
foreign
if we can make it a bit bigger thank you
and sir you will not recognize this
document as internal email
correspondence within the opp uh if you
can go to page two please
and under it says update 10 this is an
email from Brad Collins who's with the
OBP to a number of others within the opp
you'll see it says peel Regional Police
confirmed the recovery of the stolen
load of firearms from Peterborough
Police Service jurisdiction information
developing but the load of rifles has
been recovered safer possibly a few
individual pieces removed from skids do
you see that sir yes
all right well thank you commissioner I
have no further questions but I thought
that was a factual issue that should be
dealt with thank you for clearing this
up that we were able to help assist in
Catching some bad guys
no further questions thank you okay
thank you
uh next Council uh for former Chief
slowly thank you commissioner Tom Curry
for for the former Chief we have no
questions for Mr Clark okay thank you
okay next is uh City varroa
Alyssa Tompkins for the city of Ottawa
this city has no questions for this
witness thank you
next is the uh Ottawa residence
coalition
uh good afternoon Mr botter my name is
Paul champ I'm lawyer for the Ottawa
Coalition of residents and businesses
just have some questions
nice to meet you
um the mou uh people can sign that or
show support for it online or at the
present uh time that we had it uh going
out there we yeah you could sign on it
right and then you would get a digital
certificate of event his City and
everything else stating that you
actually signed it the like DocuSign
right right and and to your knowledge
did the other uh some or some of the
Convoy organizers did some of them sign
it
there's no way I could sit here and
recall close to 400 000 signatures
that's fine no problem so uh next I just
want to talk to you a little bit about
what the plan was uh when you were
coming to Ottawa you know seeing some of
the videos and whatnot and your your
Zoom call on on January 23rd with um
Barber and Ms Belton and Mr King
um
what was the plan when you were going to
come to downtown
Ottawa you were
you were going to try to like encircle
downtown was that what operation bear
hug was nope
uh we wanted to come here and talk with
our government the federal government
pacifically
okay I'll I'd ask the clerk to bring up
uh document com00838
and that's the transcript while while
he's calling that up
um I want to ask you another question
about uh some of the the protest tactics
you were thinking about when you came to
Ottawa this time
um was it was it discussed or was it
planned to have groups of people without
masks going to restaurants and shops and
uh stores yeah that was part of the
point to make the point that you're free
people who could go where you want
because I mean we were here for bear hug
one right and we've got all the videos
of us
exercising under the Bill of Rights are
lawful freedom of choice
and it just proves that when you follow
the path of law you'll find that these
mandates don't have the law to back them
up that's why we went with the police
and we talked with the police and we
communicated with the police and we got
it all in video sure but air there all
the time and at any given time if we had
committed and broken laws we would have
been arrested right there but you know
what the police of Ottawa were really
helpful and they showed us that we can
do lawful events and and from there we
told
Ottawa that when we were here we would
be back so so but the plan was as a form
of protest to go into restaurants and
shops without masks to show that yeah we
were protesting that all over the world
and the and the and I I know I'm going
to regret doing this but the Canadian
Bill of Rights has property rights what
about the property rights of the
restaurant or the shop owners why
couldn't they ask people to not come in
unless they're wearing masks didn't they
have those rights or was your rights
more important than their rights well
let's see here so
you're asking Canadians
to violate and participate
in an unlawful mandate
so
I don't want to break the law
and and put myself in a situation where
you know like these mandates are going
to be proven that they were unlawful all
the way through and history will write
that not me if you could just bring up
page 27 uh and while that's coming up
I'll ask you just another question on
that Mr bowder but uh wasn't that maybe
a little bit of a recipe for Conflict at
times if a store owner or like a teenage
staff asked people to leave who aren't
wearing masks and they wouldn't leave
wasn't that a risk of some conflict
there I I'd say that the risk of
conflict was the day that the the
unlawful mandates were put across Canada
and our government
um ignored us from there on in right so
because the government imposed those
unlawful mandates that gave you thank
you
thank you for saying they were unlawful
that you and protest with could then
override the rights of a of us no we
couldn't override anybody or it could
threaten the staff please if I could
finish but so but when a staff member
would ask people to leave you saw some
conflicts in stores and restaurants
didn't you Mr bowder seen conflicts all
over this country yeah but you saw some
in Ottawa while there were several
thousand people at downtown and big
trucks going into storage yeah no and
that's why we brought the police along
with us and they handled conflicts if
you
if you could try and you're you're eager
to answer I understand but if you could
wait till the questions finished okay
sorry so if we could just roll to near
the bottom of this page where it starts
Mr Patrick King just up a bit Mr Patrick
King uh you let the spark here again but
it's not just going to roll into ottawan
park in the trucks for a couple of days
James give them an idea of what's going
on I apologize slow down for the
translators thank you James give me give
them an idea of what's going to partake
in Ottawa when we're there just an idea
don't let the cat out of the bag just
yet but let them uh give them a little
bit of an idea
uh what was the what was the cat in the
bag at that point Mr bowder
do you recall
what date is this this is uh sorry this
is I apologize Mr bowder this is a
transcript of your Zoom call with Ms
Belton and Mr Barber and Mr King on
January the 23rd as you're planning
if we go through maybe this will assist
your memory so at the bottom it says Mr
James batter okay well you know let's
see here what is a bear hug detail well
a we're going to have some fun doing a
bunch of convoys all over Ottawa okay we
won't mention where but we're going to
have fun definitely going a whole
different pile of Convoy activities we
may potentially Convoy over to Justin
Trudeau's house good says Mr Barber uh
Mr James Bader you know little things
like that we may get stuck on a couple
of bridges things like that so that was
part of the plan Mr bowder is to maybe
block bridges for a period of time
well if you notice that when we were in
Ottawa the first time we did Bluff a
lawful blockades right so I mean we are
allowed under our Bill of Rights and so
on and so forth to do coordinated uh
with the police we wouldn't have done
any of this without the police I can
tell you that so but but what you did in
2019 Mr bowder I didn't I I didn't do
2019. okay that was another organizer so
please right so you don't have to
understand that was already put on
record that I did not have anything to
do with 2018
organizer right you didn't have anything
to do with organizing just said you're
homeless but you participated in that
protest in 2019 and that protest in
which you participated with a number of
trucks in a convoy you came from staging
areas a couple a few times a day did
drove around downtown a few times around
the parliament buildings and then would
go back and you did that a few days and
that was a successful protest no it
wasn't no it wasn't so this time you had
to do something more is that right
right that was the plan you had to do
something more you had to not simply
come downtown you had to stay downtown
and create a bear hug around downtown is
that right
that's your words well operation bear
hug is your words but is that what it
meant is you wanted to do something
different and bigger this time is that
right yeah
and uh because uh seriously every other
option to try to communicate with those
government had failed that's right so
you needed to increase the volume so to
speak correct you had to encircle
downtown and apply some pressure right
what do you mean my encircle and a pry
pressure well in circle have trucks all
around downtown love
hug right hug yeah so okay so and and
apply pressure
to who to what to the the people that
you're hugging
um
so all right Mr bowder uh just I only
have a couple more minutes here but I
want to ask you about horns now the
horns when they're very loud and when
they're all going at the same time I've
heard it described as something that's
almost biblical is that something how
you would describe it yeah I'd say that
uh when with the reference of the
the trumpets and Bringing Down the Walls
of Jericho right and that's where I was
going to go uh Joshua book six talks
about how you bring down the walls of
Jericho with the trumpets right I have
honestly never read the Bible and I just
got baptized last year and I still
haven't read the Bible and I really am a
weird duck and I don't get it but that's
the truth I could
could we uh
particularly counsel uh
I don't want to set off things and I
think it's important that it at a
minimum
Council give the example
what does that mean sir so did I do
something wrong no you did nothing I'm
sorry I'm I'm just having some trouble
with with the council with the crowd and
Council but that's my problem don't
worry you're giving your evidence
everything's okay from your perspective
okay I'm nearly finished here Mr bowder
I just want to understand so you haven't
read the Bible but it sounds like you
know the story of Jericho right I've
heard of it from from uh others it was
fascinating it was really interesting
right and that inspired you a bit for
the the tactics uh for the Convoy
protest in Ottawa correct
um
no well you raised it before I did so so
right if if you want to get into this
and talk about God so when I got
baptized
I was told by God to put this Convoy
together and come down and that's that's
where I'm at I I don't want to get into
big uh uh discussion about your your
faith Mr bowder I respect your faith I
just want to understand to what extent
your faith inspired the tactics that
that you suggested and worked on with
others with Ottawa so it's my
understanding with with Jericho the plan
was to encircle the city they walked
around the city six times six days
where they walked around the Parliament
building because that's where the Evil's
at well and on Saturday the first day of
the protest Saturday the 29th isn't that
what the trucks did they did a circle
around the parliament buildings they
went across the bridges over to Gatineau
and around right the first bear hook
yeah no no this this one in in on
January of 20. I don't know I was out in
the East so I don't know what was
happening on that because we had two
days of convoys coming from all over
Canada
um and I was like I said I was with the
Eastern crew and we got stuck out in the
middle of nowhere and then we had to
come in here and that pissed off a bunch
of people and
it's just what it is thank you very much
Mr Bauer thank you
thank you next is uh the
democracy fund citizens for freedom
jccf
good afternoon Mr bowder my name is Rob
kittridge and I'm counsel for the
Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms and you like me are a Chatty
Man and a challenging witness so I'm
going to try and do it trying to be
challenging honestly yeah I'm trying to
be as open as I can I I agree that you
are being as opened as as you can but
I'm going to try and uh
persuade you to give me yes or no
answers if you can because what we're
trying to one of the things okay so one
of the things we're trying to do here we
have a short period of time and I am
trying to construct an argument that the
emergencies Act was invoked unlawfully
by Trudeau and your yes or no answers
will help me to do that
um I can play with this pardon me I can
get along with it all right well let's
see let's see how well we do
um so uh what I'm looking for is a
little clarification on a series of
questions that my friend Council for
Canada asked you earlier on today about
how you and others in Ottawa inspired
other protests across Canada and around
the world
you had an emotional response to those
questions as I think I would as well if
I were in your position
and I just wanted to get a bit of
clarification for the record about what
inspired meant to you in that context
um and again if we can do yes or no
questions yes sir no answers that would
be great
um Council for Canada said that when he
said you he didn't just mean you he
meant and I quote the collective view
meaning you and the other people in
Ottawa uh was that your understanding
when you answered those questions
no I thought he was referring to me to
you specifically yeah all right
um
so Council for I I thought well it
doesn't matter what I think uh Council
for Canada suggested what you and that
you uh inspired other protests across
Canada and around the world you agreed
you remember that series of questions to
you yeah the questions yeah all right
um I understood your answers and your
emotional response to mean that you were
proud that the protest here in Ottawa
had been seen by others in Canada and
around the world
and that they had independently decided
to protest themselves was that your
understanding
yeah can you say yes for the record
because it's a written transcript so
um
and I say sorry a lot pardon mythical
Canadian I say sorry a lot right as do I
uh so while the while the Ottawa
protesters yourself included may have
inspired protests outside of Ottawa you
didn't organize any of those other
protests to do yeah
people elsewhere may have seen what you
and others were doing here in Ottawa but
they independently decided to follow
that example and raise their voices in
protest didn't they yes
um and uh just to be uh I guess fair to
you since you've been so fair to me um I
have a minute or two left if I was
wondering if there was anything you'd
like to tell us about how it felt to
inspire people around the world to raise
their voices
objection get into my feelings objection
I'm not sure how that's relevant
oh
it's okay it's okay yeah I I I
still to this day
how I feel
I'm broken but because
people come together and they chose on
their own accord
to choose one word Unity
I will forever
be grateful and thankful for
and
forgiving the world hope
needed it
feelings and I'm sorry
well thank you very much Mr bowder those
are my questions thanks for love and
thanks for the Bear Hugs Mr commissioner
that's Paul champ on the record I
apologize for not saying it earlier for
the purposes of transcripts I just know
I I didn't ask Mr bowder any questions
about his many hateful comments about
Islam uh his many hateful and bigoted
comments about uh homosexuals I'm not
sure how this is relevant
I didn't think it was Romance when I
asked but that's why I'm asking why Mr
bowder is given an opportunity to to
answer those kinds of questions what
they're which are otherwise it's
firstly it was a question within his
time period and he was asked how he felt
I'm not sure what that adds if that's
your point in terms of the evidence but
in any event I was going to give him as
he's unrepresented an opportunity to say
something at the end so I think all this
is done is
do it in advance but what exactly is
your point you wanted what Struck from
the record or do you want a further
opportunity to cross-examine what is it
you're after
well Mr bowder has asked he's made many
comments about uh Unity um if if that's
relevant to the commission I could ask
uh I would ask for to ask him some
questions about his views on Unity if
you want to do further cross-examination
uh you stopped at the end I was prepared
I didn't cut you off if you want to come
back up you can go ahead
Mr bowder you've testified many times
about your love and Brotherhood for
others and your love of unity uh but you
would agree with me uh you don't feel
Unity towards all Canadians it does not
include Canadians for example of his
Islamic faith isn't that right no
you you are upset that you feel the
government of Canada promotes Islamic
ideologies you've said that before
correct was that before I got found God
okay so you've said that before was that
before I found God because you're you're
asking dates and I don't agree with what
you're saying now to date right now okay
well that's okay that's where I'm under
oh I don't agree with that okay I thank
you I appreciate that now we've seen
some documents up there where you've
referred to prime minister just to
Justin Trudeau as Justine Trudeau what I
referred to him as Justine Trudeau why
not
are you trying to suggest something it's
emasculating or making some kind of
comments or suggestions
I don't know I mean could be a typo
was it a typo it's your word sir well
maybe it's a typo I don't know but are
you telling us it's a typo or were you
trying to suggest something because you
think it's somehow negative to a bit of
uh transgender so forth there's an alpha
male uh trucker oil Patch Farm Boy kind
of guy uh and see an old little Mr
Trudeau there in his boxing shorts with
his Juice Box water bottle sort of
things yeah
we call him Justine thank you Mr thank
you Mr commissioner thank you
um
okay that's any re-examination
no thank you okay
thank you Mr Butler you're free to go uh
am I free to go or here yes you are this
is uh you're completed your examination
right on
um I'm not done because am I not allowed
my 15 minutes or no if you'd like to
make a statement uh that's fine
but I'd really like to bring up and I'm
just I lost my video stuff and it's got
to do with
hmm hang on here
where is the video Jason where are you
uh
the speech out in uh Quebec
the unities
which number
media press release I I don't have it on
here
okay is it in the file or no which
number okay I just he
I'd like to leave I really would like to
have that video of this
I I have four videos
um with a jba prefix uh I can give you
the titles if that helps you that I have
I have one that says massless shopping
one that says James at Trudeau's house
December 21st that's worth watching uh
one that's mou served December 21st no
and then we already showed jba 81 during
commission councils we tried to upload a
lot of evidence and we had problems and
technical issues and so on and so forth
but it was uh it was a very it's too bad
maybe you could just sum it up for us it
was when we left
Calgary
my wife and I
and
for those that want to do their research
in Canada and
look into the definition and our history
and our governance and respects to
division over Unity
when I was looking at all the governance
aspects and policy aspects looking for a
solution you can imagine when the word
Unity was given to me and that has
forever changed my life my heart my mind
and
from there
I I did this little research because I
was very
very stricken that that in our country
there was nothing really out there for
Canada entity
like you Googled back then and there was
only one reference
that I could find as a as a western
Alberta oil Patch Farm Boy growing up
with this
the West hates the east
and the East hates the West
and I started asking myself well
they're Canadian aren't they they're our
brothers and sisters
where does this Division come from
so get into our governance and I find
out that by Design
we are designed to be divided right in
our governance
and that Disturbed me deeply it's uh it
was so that's when I made the first
prayer I said God what do we do and he
says Unity
what
how am I going to put that into a
corrective action
well you look at our history and and how
close we were to dividing
Quebec somebody in Quebec
saved this country and I don't know who
I tried and I tried to find this one
person because if you remember in
history when Quebec wanted to separate
and we had a 51 to 49 vote
what if somebody hadn't raised their
hand and said Unity
because that was the only reference I
could find
at that time was somebody had raised
their hand in Quebec and said unity and
then there was a Canada Unity flag
and that was it I was like this can't
beat so I went on Google and I
registered all of everything Canada
unity all of it
trademark all the everything I'm not
sure so can I just interrupt you for a
minute I mean my stories I try to sorry
sir
it's yeah it's a little too much of a
story I'm not sure but it helps us I
understand you're on you your union
but that's fine I think your message has
been given and uh we've seen let's let's
wrap it up just please like
what I observed was that Unity was
missing and I'm thankful to this day for
Quebec for standing up and saving
country uh and putting Unity onto that
that table it is my humble humble honor
to come from the West
and come out to Quebec with my wife
and
with the olive branch of unity and say
let's stop dividing let's stop the
division let's come together and
thank you Canada for that precious
precious moment in your history
okay thank you we're going to adjourn
for the afternoon break
for 15 minutes
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
order a lot
foreign
[Applause]
good afternoon commissioner the next
witness is uh tomorrow Leach
[Applause]
Ms Leach will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm I
would like to swear on the Bible please
foreign
please State your full name and spell it
out Tamara Lee Leach l-i-c-h
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God I do so
swear thank you thank you uh sir Brendan
Miller for Freedom Corp and also Council
to Ms Leach we have already invoked in
writing on October 7th 2022 all the
proper provisions of the relevant
statutes with respect to testimony here
today but I believe my friends
consenting that I can have that
invocation marked as an exhibit if we
could bring up document
hrf0001610 please
foreign
just scroll down to I believe the third
page
oh fourth my apologies
and there is the invocation and thank
you sir
thank you okay I understand she's
under subpoena so that's confirming that
okay thank you
good afternoon Miss Leach good evening
my name is John Mather I'm commission
counsel
I'm going to start with some questions
about your background
um can you tell the commission where you
were born uh Saskatoon Saskatchewan and
uh where do you live now Medicine Hat
Alberta
and could you tell us
in brief just give us a summary of your
employment history I've been primarily
oil and gas Logistics and administration
um and we understand or the commission
understands that prior to kova 19 you
were politically active is that a fair
statement yes I was okay uh you were
among other things a regional
coordinator for wegzit in Southeastern
Alberta yes sir uh you were on the board
of directors for wegzit Canada yes sir
and at one point you were Vice President
of communications with wexit Canada yes
I was uh for those who may not be as
familiar with Alberta politics can you
explain what we exit is uh wexit started
out as a movement I guess based off of
the brexit movement that started in the
UK and
um we I joined that movement I was very
concerned about the things that I was
seeing happening to Western Canadians in
politics and became I guess a bit of an
advocate so I I got involved in the
movement and we morphed into a
provincial and a federal party
and at one point we exit merged Into the
Wild Rose independence party is that
correct it did yes
um and you at some point left that party
and then joined the Maverick party is
that correct uh how that happened was um
I was sitting on two boards when it
first came out the provincial wexit
Alberta as well as the wexit Canada and
during covid my husband and I relocated
to Manitoba for about 19 months during
the pandemic so I I left that board
right as that merger happened but I
stuck with the wexit Canada board and
then we renamed ourselves into the
Maverick party so is Maverick
essentially wigs it but with the new
name basically
um and when you said you had concerns
about uh I think West How the West Was
being treated can you expand on what
those concerns were yes sir um at that
time we were dealing with a BLC 69 and
Bill c-48
um and I was just seeing friends and
family that that worked in the energy
industry in Alberta
suffering as a result of some of that
legislation there was job losses and
I just saw
I just saw people losing their jobs and
coming into my office you know handing
me their resume with tears in their eyes
asking for a job two weeks before
Christmas and I just felt like I needed
to get involved and exercise my
Democratic rights and again for people
who maybe not be as familiar can you
explain how those bills at least in your
mind led to the job loss you're talking
about well B Bill 269 was the no more
pipelines bill and I think you can
recall at that time there was the Trans
Mountain pipeline expansion and other
pipelines that they had been discussing
or proposing energy East for an example
and um when all those got canceled a lot
of people didn't have any work
what is the goal of the Maverick party
the goal of the Maverick party was to
seek constitutional reform for better
equality for western Canada or to seek
an independence very much like what
Quebec has
um being referred to as a nation within
a nation
and what can you give any examples of
the Constitutional reform that the
Maverick party is seeking
I believe one of them was the um the
getting more equal seats in the House of
Commons I I mean a big concern for
people in the west is that every
election before the polls even
close in Alberta the uh it's already
decided the elections are already
decided so I think myself and a lot of
people in the west just felt like we
didn't really have a voice in the House
of Commons
does the Maverick party consider the
federal government to have too much
power
don't necessarily think so
um and going back to the Constitutional
reforms that you reference and then I
think the next thing you said was if
there isn't a constitutional reform then
ultimately the goal of the Maverick
party is independence from Canada is
that correct correct yes
um have you ever been a trucker misleach
never
um the commission understands that uh in
2019 you also participated in the yellow
vest movement I did can you explain what
the yellow vest movement was
well at that point there had been a
yellow vest I'm sorry I don't speak
French I'm not sure of the the French
term but there had been similar protests
in France and the organization that I I
joined in Medicine Hat again was
primarily to deal with the legislation
against our energy industry which is
what we were advocating for and we had
would have rallies every Saturday from
one to two in front of the Tim Hortons
and stand there with flags and hold
signs that kind of thing and so those
yellow vest rallies were rallies in
opposition to the same legislation we
spoke about earlier that's correct
and you mentioned that it was uh
maybe is inspired the right word by the
movement in France what would be the
right word
I guess inspired maybe uh and did were
you aware that the movement in France uh
eventually came under some controversy
for being associated with islamophobia I
was not aware of that
um and so I think you mentioned uh but
it's commission's understanding that you
were the organizer of the yellow vest
rallies in Medicine Hat I kind of moved
into that role
um as I like I said I was going to the
rallies and meeting people and offered
to help in any way that I could
and it's the commission's understanding
that uh the uh yellow vest in medicine
had ended up changing its name is that
right yes they did and why did the
yellow vest group in Medicine Hat change
its name
um I've read this morning an article and
I don't really remember what what
happened at that time but I did see in
the evidence that I was reviewing last
night that there had been death threats
against the prime minister so clearly we
wanted to distance ourselves from that
right and so if I could pull up com50908
and then if we could scroll down to the
headline
this is an article from January 12 2019
and says following death threats to
Trudeau yellow vest medicine hat looks
to change their name is that the article
you're referring to yes sir and uh the
article states that um not on the
Medicine Hat Facebook page but on the
more General yellow vest Canada Facebook
page there had been death threats that
had been posted about prime minister
Trudeau is do you recall that occurring
at the time
they I I don't really recall that but
we did I do recall that we did change
our name I'm not sure what the threats
were per se but we did change our name
and did the name I appreciate you might
not recall the specific threats but the
name change was as a result of this yes
yes that's not something that I ever
advocated for or anybody that I was
associated with in the Medicine Hat
movement right and if we could go to
page three of the article
It quotes uh you miss leech is saying
stay positive is number one we don't
want any name calling bashing or
belittlement respecting people's privacy
is also a big one we will not tolerate
threats hate speech or anything like
that we don't want that kind of stigma
attached to our cause do you see that
there yes and I take it that's a a view
you held at the time hold today
absolutely right and that's ultimately a
you had to deliver a similar message at
times when it came to the protest in
Ottawa is that true I did yes
uh the commission has heard evidence uh
on a few occasions about a convoy in
2019 called United We Rule
um are you familiar with that Convoy I
am
uh did you participate in that Convoy I
did not did you have any involvement in
that Convoy I didn't have involvement in
that Convoy other than maybe uh
connecting people's phone numbers or
getting people connected that we're
going at the same time as to that United
United reroll was was starting there was
a lot of
um I guess many convoys I would call
them in little communities and so I I
was a part of or organizing the little
one that went through our community
so you uh connected people's phone
numbers and then organized a smaller
Convoy within Medicine Hat yes sir can
you provide more detail about what you
mean when you say you were connecting
people's phone numbers well just because
I've moved around a lot I know a lot of
people and that would be have been the
extent of my involvement if someone was
looking for a contact number per se
um were you aware at the time that Pat
King was involved in the United We Roll
Convoy that's when I first heard of Mr
King and how did you first hear of Mr
King
um he was well I was on social media so
of course you know you're scrolling and
you would see videos so that's that's
how I came to know of of him he had a
social media
live stream he was live streaming it
um during United We Rule did you ever
communicate with Mr King no I did not
when was the first time you communicated
with Mr King the first time I ever
remember communicating with him was
after we had started this Convoy so in
the context of the Ottawa Convoy yes sir
we'll get back to that in a minute
between United We Roll in the Ottawa
Convoy did you follow Mr King on social
media
I followed Mr King until the United
reroll was over and then I I stopped
following him at that point and when we
talk about following did you make a
deliberate decision to click on follow
on Facebook I did and why did you make
that decision at that point in time
because it was over and I really had no
further reason to follow him
did you come to form an impression of Mr
King's views in following him during
United We Roll
everybody was loud
um but very boisterous
um
other than that I didn't really know too
much about him do you recall finding
anything he said offensive and with
respect to United We Rule
I don't recall that no
um
did you communicate with James Bower at
all during United We Rule I don't
believe so no do you remember when the
first time was that you met Mr bowder I
would have met Mr bowder for the first
time in person in Ottawa this past
winter right and then had you met him
virtually before then no
or sorry when we were organizing my my
apologies yes as we organized he was in
the meetings so again within the context
of January 2022 yes
so moving now to the freedom Convoy how
did you get involved in the freedom
Convoy a friend of mine sent me Mr
Barber's Tick Tock video uh where he was
calling for a shutdown on the 23rd of
January
um
she sent me that video and I I watched
it and I texted her back right away and
I said well what do you think about
possibly another Convoy to Ottawa and
she kind of laughed and said well it you
know it didn't really accomplish much I
mean it was great to see the crowds come
together but they were just slow down a
bit please
yes sir
uh and um and then I'd reached out to
another friend and I asked him the same
thing and uh we just sort of came to the
same conclusion that we weren't sure if
that was an idea that was
that would be successful
a friend of mine or an acquaintance of
mine from Red Deer that was involved in
the united reroll gave me Mr barber's
phone number and I contacted him on
January the 13th
and we discussed I can't really remember
the details of the conversation I do
remember
um that I I said I'm here to help you in
any way I can my background is logistics
and organization and administration and
you are going to need social media and
you're going to need some funding and if
I can help you at all I'd be happy to do
that okay a few questions arising under
that
um do you remember who the acquaintant
was that acquaintance was that gave you
Mr barber's phone number yes it was
Glenn carrot okay
um and did Mr Carrot participate in the
Convoy do you know he did not and the
two friends that you uh you indicated
you had a conversation with about
whether or not a convoy again was a good
idea who were they uh Cindy Parker from
Medicine Hat she ended up assisting on
the finance committee that I was going
to create and she also assisted with the
social media and uh Kevin
he was a friend of mine that I worked
with in Manitoba and I understood from
your answer but correct me if I'm wrong
that both Miss Parker and Miss I'm going
to mispronounce the last name Mr
lachinsky was that
did they participate in United We Rule
no not to my knowledge
so
why did you want to get involved in the
Convoy why did you want to reach out to
Mr Barber
I was growing increasingly alarmed with
the mandates and the harm that I was
seeing the mandates inflict on Canadians
sorry I'm going to get emotional I'll
try not to
um
and
I I just felt like I needed to exercise
my Democratic rights I have tried over
the years emailing MPS
and just never got a response and I just
felt that this was important
for Canadians
who had been living under lockdowns and
restrictions for two years
when you say emailing MPS have you been
emailing them about covid-19 mandates I
believe I did once yes but I had emailed
previously like I said in conjunction
with the bill c-69 and Bill c-48 and
never felt like
anyone was listening to me and I know it
wasn't me there was other people that
were emailing also and you just get
these thanks for contacting our office
blow off emails
so you would form this impression that
you were having difficulty getting
someone to listen to you in the
government based on letters you sent
primarily with respect to the the the
pipeline issues we've been talking about
that's correct yes
um
how had covid-19 restrictions or
mandates affected you personally
well I lost my job
my husband also lost his job on the same
day
my parents run a pilot truck business
and a lot of their business was involved
crossing the border which they were no
longer allowed to do
at the time of the Convoy there was
Rumblings of uh stopping cross-border
inter-provincial sorry travel if you
were unvaccinated my parents live in
Saskatchewan my grandmother's in
Saskatchewan and I have a daughter and a
granddaughter in Manitoba so I found
that incredibly alarming
and why did you lose your job
we were sent home uh I guess in early
January because of the Omicron variant
and that combined obviously with the
downturn in the economy at that time
they closed the shop that I was working
at
and the majority of us were laid off and
what shop was that
it was for an oil and gas Services
Company
um were you affected At All by vaccine
passports or other restrictions on
unvaccinated people
we didn't go out you know my husband and
I played in a band we weren't allowed to
even go and and play everything was shut
down
um
we just that's part of the reason with
that we went to Manitoba after after we
both lost our jobs we went to visit my
daughter
and um realized that the city that we
were in was basically a ghost town and
we would prefer to be out on the farm in
the country helping them on the farm and
and
being productive
what did you want to achieve by
participating in the freedom Convoy
I was hoping that somebody would come
and listen to us and listen to the
concerns that we had
essentially
about the mandates in particular
did you have a goal beyond having
someone come and listen to you about the
mandates no we wanted to be heard
we wanted to have discussions we wanted
to end the mandates
was your goal to have the mandates end
or was a discussion enough or was that
something you hadn't turned your mind to
for me I feel if we would have just been
able to have a discussion with somebody
that that would have at least opened a
dialogue
and and as the Convoy came across Canada
you know Canadians were telling us don't
stop don't stop until we're free don't
stop until the mandates are lifted so
honestly a bit of both
the frustration that you were describing
with respect to mandates
did that feel familiar to the
frustration you had been feeling with
respect to the pipeline and oil and gas
issues
I was much more frustrated over the
mandates
and why was that
because I was seeing families torn apart
the suicides in my hometown were so
numerous that they stopped reporting
them
um
elderly people were dying by themselves
in long-term care facilities
and saying goodbye over iPads
my grandma
is 94 years old
and she was locked in her little
apartment by herself for two years
and now that she can go out and do
things she's not healthy enough she lost
two years of her life
my father is I'm so sorry
take your time
my father is a very
social man he is the coffee row
Saskatchewan
father and
I remember him telling me one day that
he went down to the local restaurant
that he went to every single day
and these are small towns where
everybody knows everybody and he was
asked to leave
and I didn't want my children and my
grandchildren to live in a world like
that
I was
becoming increasingly alarmed
listening to my prime minister
call me a racist
and say that I shouldn't be tolerated
I've found his rhetoric to be incredibly
divisive and I'm I'm a believer that if
you are a leader of a country
you have to lead all of your people even
if you don't agree with them
and I I just saw so much
coming across Canada every day I heard
stories people at least three people
would tell me they were planning their
suicides until we started the Convoy
or stories of people that we were too
late
I heard from
families that were living in their
vehicles because they lost their jobs I
heard from
people that had lost their jobs and lost
everything
I have
the tears of thousands of Canadians on
my shoulder
who every day told me that we were
bringing them hope
I saw little old ladies praying on their
knees on the side of the road and I saw
little children holding signs saying
thank you for giving me back my future
sorry
so you offered to help when reaching out
to Chris Barber and it's our
understanding that one of the first
things you did was create a Facebook
page is that correct yes sir and started
the GoFundMe campaign is that correct
answer I did and you did the both of
those things on January 14th I did and a
Twitter account also and a Twitter
account was that different than the
Twitter account that we saw earlier
today that was your personal business
that was my personal one yes
um
with respect to GoFundMe had you ever
done fundraising before
uh not in not on that type of platform
um just community
you know uh selling chocolate covered
almonds or stuff like that
so never done an online social media
driven uh no fundraiser
and then it's the commission's
understanding that on January 17th you
created or the organizers created a
finance committee is that correct yes I
did and can you explain what the finance
committee's purpose was
yes well
when we when I started the GoFundMe I
had asked I think it was Mr Barber what
should I set the target for
and he said two hundred thousand dollars
and I said no way I kind of laughed I
was like that sounds greedy and I don't
believe that we'll ever hit that
I and I said well how about I said it
for a hundred thousand dollars and and I
said I feel even funny about doing that
I I was literally expecting maybe twenty
thousand dollars in donations which I
was prepared to hand I've I felt I would
be able to handle that with my very
minimal accounting skills
and um I can't remember what the total
was up to on Monday morning but I
realized that I wanted to create a
finance committee
um so that Canadians that were donating
this money would rest assured that we
were going to be open and transparent
and accountable and that they would know
exactly what was happening with with
their donations I just felt that was so
important
and how would a committee assist with
that
well there was uh in the initial meeting
there was two bookkeepers that had
obviously accounting experience Cindy
Parker was also on that committee uh
noline villabren joined us also she's a
clan mother at Danae Clan mother from
the Northwest Territories and we were in
consultation with a chartered accountant
in Medicine Hat so we we formed the
committee obviously we had a lot of
things to figure out such as how we were
going to pay the costs of of the
truckers to get to Ottawa
and they came up with some calculations
based on distance I'm not sure if it's
been entered inevited as it might be but
um because clearly if you're from some
place in Ontario
um
and we'll get into that more in a minute
um
commission also understands it was
around January 21st 2022 when the
GoFundMe donations hit a million dollars
does that sound accurate probably there
was a lot going on then but yeah yeah in
and around there yes um what was your
reaction when that Milestone was hit
I believe I
well I was blown away we did not see
that coming did not expect that we were
going to have that level of support and
um
it was funny as we were driving across
Canada and the Committee Member or
somebody would call me or text me and
say you've got to bump it up again
because there was a few days there where
Canadians were donating a million
dollars a day and
um
and it was a very exciting and
exhilarating of course but at the same
time I would just feel myself almost
getting like more and more anxiety
because
from my view when you're talking that
kind of money the the lawyers are coming
and here we are today
right because
that kind of money you know in the
millions of dollars a lot of
responsibility it's a massive
responsibility
um other than set up the finance
committee uh what else did you do to
address the responsibility that came
with having millions of dollars
well um as you heard from Mr Victor I
contacted him and um I I was for the
same reason that we added Chris to the
accounts I I didn't want to be solely
responsible so
um I I added him on to the GoFundMe
campaign
um just as I had added Chris Barber as a
signatory on my accounts
anything else
probably sorry my mind went blank that's
okay
um
and then
on February 2nd 2022 we understand
um that one million dollars from the
GoFundMe account was transferred to a TD
bank account and your name is that
Accord with your recollection yes sir
and then
that TD Bank account was frozen the next
day is that does that sound right that
sounds about right yep and then you
there was actually another TD Bank
account that got frozen is that correct
yes
um we we opened another or I opened a
checking account underneath that account
so that we could keep the e-transfers
separate from the the GoFundMe donations
I don't know why I just thought it would
be maybe easier that way to keep them
distinct I wasn't sure obviously again
what was going to happen and I was
trying to just make sure that every all
the
boxes were were ticked and everything
was going to be easily identifiable or
easy to account for I guess is a better
way right and the commission's
understanding that uh donations were
received both through GoFundMe and
through e-transfers and I what I
understand you'd be saying is to
segregate where the money came from you
opened a second account specifically for
each transfers yes sir within a few days
or probably actually within a couple
days of the GoFundMe campaign we were
receiving messages
um about people that were very hesitant
to use the GoFundMe platform and they
were requesting an alternative method to
donate money so that's why we started
that
how did you find out that your bank
accounts had been frozen
uh Mr Chad Eros and I had gone down to
the bank to the the lawyers had flown in
and we were going to cover the cost of
that flight and so we went down to the
TD Bank here in Ottawa and we were going
to wire that company and that's when uh
we were told no there's a hold on your
account
uh the lady was excellent she says she
gave me a note and said there's a Mr J
Stein that has left his name on here if
you could contact him
um and then she indicated that he was
working with the fraud department
if we could pull up
com.or705 and Miss leachwell comes up
this is uh the overview report that was
presented this morning with respect to
crowdfunding I'm
um
and if we could go to uh paragraph 87
which is on page 33.
so uh here miss Leach it's uh this
describes that on February 5th 2022 you
attempted to make a wire transfer to
Northern Air Charter PR Inc from an from
an Ottawa TD Branch this transaction was
denied is this what you were referring
to just previously yes
um
and that was the flight I think you said
that it brought Mr Wilson and your
husband and others to Ottawa that's
correct sir
um who approved the using of the funds
for that purpose
oh boy
um I'm not sure if at that time
we had already had the board
um
created or not
and the board are you referring to the
board of the directors for the
not-for-profit corporation yes yeah I
don't I don't know if that was if that
was created yet
um I I don't really remember
honestly I think it was maybe with me
and Chad and Mr Barber did you did you
consult with the finance committee
before attempting to use the money for
that purpose I don't believe I did do
you know why
sorry that's okay do you know why you
didn't consult with the finance
committee
um other than it was very busy and crazy
at times it was It was kind of chaotic
at that point so
um we recognized that we needed to have
legal counsel
um and legal advice here on the ground
so I guess we felt it was just urgent
and and so that's why
um
if we could uh we can take that down
um
in that same report I won't turn it up
but uh it indicates that uh most of the
one million dollars was was frozen and
you weren't able to withdraw it from the
account is that correct that's correct
do you recall how much you were able to
withdraw uh I believe it was twenty six
thousand dollars
so ten thousand dollars of that uh if
you would like me to break it down for
you you're anticipating my question so
yes please go ahead uh ten thousand
dollars of that was wired to a bulk fuel
supplier
uh three thousand dollars was
e-transferred to another fuel provider
uh Chris and I had gone down sorry Mr
Barber and I had gone down to the TD and
we uh withdrew
3 000 in cash from one account and ten
thousand in cash from
um or sorry one branch and then went to
the next branch
and then
um
and I remember being very nervous about
it because I was very conscious that we
needed receipts when we needed to be
accountable and uh
um and they were the the road captains
that went out and bought whatever
supplies fuel uh they I believe some of
that went to fuel
um when they were when they brought the
receipts back there was actually extra
money
uh in the in the kitty so
so uh when you're talking about the road
captains are you talking about the
Thirteen thousand dollars that wasn't
for the first two bulk fuel purchases
you that's correct yes and am I
understanding correctly that that money
was distributed to the road captains uh
I believe so I
um
I I didn't keep it I I had 10 million
problems of my own so I wasn't where I
didn't want to be handling any of the
cash so
um I can't I think I gave it to Chris
and then Chris distributed it to the
road captains from there to provide fuel
and the ten thousand dollars that was
used for the one bulk fuel purchase do
you recall where you purchased the fuel
from I believe it was a company called
fillerup.ca
and there was also a three thousand
dollar fuel purchase do you recall yeah
that went to uh Adam something who is
with the Quebec uh the cool the Quebec
part of the Convoy like I'm sorry I
can't remember his last name that's
that's okay
um
um after the few was purchased how was
it distributed
the fuel yes
that I left up to the professionals did
you through dealing with the
professionals did you come to have any
understanding of how they distributed
the fuel
I'm assuming with a fuel bulker of some
sort or I honestly don't know and when
you're talking about the professionals
who are you referring to the truck
drivers
is there anyone in particular or any
people in particular who are responsible
for overseeing the logistics of
Distributing fuel
uh we did have a few volunteers that
came on board
um there was a gentleman that was there
for the first I think he was there for
the first week who looked after that
um
and then he had to leave and another
gentleman stepped in and took it over
who was from Alberta Calgary I believe
and then another gentleman from Ontario
that that assisted
and who were those gentlemen uh the
first one I believe was Joey mitsu
m-i-z-u uh tihan
I'm sorry I don't know his last name he
was from Calgary and then John skubick
who is from Ontario
what happened to the receipts that the
captains returned I have them in an
envelope in my in my room I they were um
scanned and sent I believe Eva chippyuk
had scanned them and there was one of
the road captain's uncle was here so he
created a spreadsheet so that we could
keep track of all of them also
if we could go to gfm156
foreign
so this is a GoFundMe
attestation letter are you familiar with
this document yes okay can you describe
uh what this document is and uh
what it's purpose was
I don't really remember the details is
it okay if I read it yeah okay yeah
so it looks to me they just wanted
confirmation on how the where the funds
were going and how they would be
distributed right and and the clerk has
scrolled down now and what I what I want
to ask you about is it says with the
oversight of the finance committee I
will execute the following plan to meet
the stated purpose of the fundraiser and
distribute the funds raised and released
to me and then it sets out a process do
you see that there I do sir do you
recall making this form of commitment to
GoFundMe
I do yep and it's our understanding that
GoFundMe sought this sort of commitment
as part of the ongoing discussion about
whether or not it would release the
funds is that correct yes I I believe
they were trying to do their due
diligence
um and you see here it sets out a
process funds will be distributed via
e-transfer directly from the TD
unlimited checking account established
in my name to individual Convoy
participants participants must submit
their own Convoy registration forms fuel
receipts and verification for their
participation from the road Captain to
that participant registration is
verified by the respective Road captains
upon
demonstration of completion receipts and
confirmation of the journey to Ottawa
and reimbursement amounts will be
calculated at an estimated rate of 62
cents per kilometer driven do you see
that I do sir so this this attestation
it appears was contemplating how people
would be reimbursed on their way to
Ottawa is that right yes was any similar
plan made for uh disbursements once the
Convoy was in Ottawa
well um I guess what the finance
committee we decided to do was obviously
come up with registration forms because
we felt that that was really important
and a code of conduct also and that is
based off of the calculations that the
finance committee had come up with to to
pay them for so
uh when it was not anticipated how large
this was going to grow
um I thought e-transfers would be very a
very easy way to disperse the money and
that's what the registration was for so
that we would have their contact
information and their email addresses in
order to make that happen
so my question was with respect to
distribution once you were in Ottawa was
the plan to use the registration forms
once money was distributed in Ottawa as
well it was that was that was the plan
did you follow that plan well we didn't
need to because the funds were were
frozen and what about for the 26
thousand dollars
I'm sorry what about for the 26 000. oh
that was from the e-transfer money
not the GoFundMe money so the GoFundMe
money you had a distribution plan
um but for the you transfer money you
did not that's correct
did you consider having a distribution
plan for that you transfer money
at that point
um I had handed over everything to the
finance committee because once Mr Barber
and I got on the road I was quite busy
doing other things
um so my communications with them were
quite
quick and and I trusted them they I
trusted that they knew what they were
doing and
yeah
and well you may have turned things over
to the finance committee it's the
commission's understanding again from
testimony and documents that we've read
that
um you you became the person associated
with the GoFundMe campaign and the
person associated with the the 10 plus
million dollars is that was that your
experience
yes
what impact did that have on you
well it was incredibly again
it was an incredible responsibility and
again my I I was
wanted to always be as open and
transparent about it as possible which
is why I started doing the lives so that
I could let people know you know what
was happening the finance committee has
been formulated and try and do little
updates on on what we were achieving at
that point
did you get a lot of questions about the
money and what you were planning to do
with it
oh of course yeah everybody wanted to
know about the money did uh you get a
lot of people approaching you and asking
you if they could have some of the money
I did yes
um and Mr Eros who we've spoken about it
had an interview with the commission and
he said that at some point after
February 1st he spoke with you on the
phone and you told them that you were
feeling overwhelmed because a lot of
people were circling you and asking for
money and he said that you called them
vultures in a text message yeah that's
that's how I didn't mean they were
vultures I just felt like the the
vultures are circling
how did you handle having all these
people circling around you and seeking
money
the best I could I I had created a
finance committee to ensure that
um the money that was donated was
protected and that I was protected and
we had I I just wanted
um
I don't know I just put one foot in
front of the other and I would just
explain that I was not in a like this
was not my money to give out
and that we needed to
the the money was primarily like it said
in the GoFundMe campaign primarily for
the truck for that it was for the
truckers for Feud uh sorry fool for fuel
food and lodgings if needed and so
um
I couldn't buy hot dogs
I didn't feel like buying a sound system
for 150 000 was appropriate when I
couldn't get money out to give to the to
the to the truck drivers so I had a lot
of people coming at me and um my hands
were tied at one point I had somebody
threatening that they were going to get
a lawyer to come after me for the money
which was kind of ridiculous because
that was really at that point just going
to tie it up even longer
you know
I'm gonna now ask you some questions
about the organization of the of the the
freedom Convoy
um first question for you is
at the time did you see yourself as one
of the founders of the Convoy a
supporter
who did you see as the founders uh Mr
Barber and Miss Belton
did you view Mr King or Mr bowder as
founders of the Convoy I did not
when you joined were you aware that they
had been assisting in planning and
promotion of the Convoy I found out and
I can't recall if it was in my initial
discussion with Mr Barber or the next
day it would have been either the 13th
or the 14th that I found out that they
were involved but I don't remember
exactly which date
I appreciate that you saw yourself as a
supporter and you're not one of the
founders did you come to see yourself as
one of the leaders of the Convoy
I came to see myself as part of a team
and maybe it was because of the GoFundMe
that my name was on or maybe it was
because of the live videos that I was
doing
I was I was I felt I was perceived as
that but I I
all I wanted to do was help
did you see yourself as having having
any say greater than anyone else on the
team I did not and who did you see as a
member the members of that team
obviously uh Miss Belton and Mr Barber
uh the road captains Joe Johnson Miranda
gassier Ryan mahilowitz
Dale ends
Sean Thiessen
I hope I'm not forgetting anyone
so when Mr Wilson described you as an
organic leader
do you agree with that statement
I guess that's yeah I guess that's what
I alluded to with my previous answer
right
and what I understood you from your
previous answer is that you were seen as
the leader but you yourself didn't feel
that you were the leader absolutely not
foreign
ER and his testimony discussed that
there was power struggles among the
organizers was that something you
observed as well
it was and I and I think when you have
anything any type of organization
there's always power struggles involved
and uh and ours was no different
what power struggles Did You observe
I saw
what I perceived was you know people
organizations coming in perhaps trying
to
to
um
take over or I hate to use the word
takeover but
I believe that they were all there for
with with the same goals that we had
it's just that maybe some had different
agendas or or
um
we're looking to possibly promote their
own brand there was there was obviously
I had a lot of people coming up to me as
we were just talking about you know
telling me what I needed to do with the
money should do with the money could be
doing with the money what I had to had
to do and and um
it was it was very overwhelming
what were some of the people or groups
that were doing that
um the first one that I
was concerned about was an organization
called taking back our freedoms
um and I felt
again that they were there
with the right end goal and in mind
I remember they showed up with bags of
swag
um
all of a sudden
I was getting pulled into meetings with
um I believe it was gifts and go
because we were looking at there had
been obviously problems starting with
GoFundMe and we weren't sure what was
going to happen and so I I honestly
don't I remember being in meetings and
conference calls and I really didn't
even know what was going on
um and I had a discussion with Mr Eros
after one of those and he was concerned
when you talk about bags of Swag and
that was the the the the
are you was is that a case where you
were concerned that well then the group
might have had the same goals they were
seeking a promotional opportunity is
that what you're referring to
essentially right
um
did you have concerns that there were
other groups or individuals who were
seeking to use the uh
the the mass media coverage the and the
10 million dollars as a way to promote
themselves instead of focus on the cause
not that I can think of offhand now
did you ever turn your mind to whether
or not this was acting as a promotional
opportunity for yourself absolutely not
I I never in a million years saw this
coming I never had an agenda I literally
just wanted to help some truckers drive
across Canada and stand in front of
parliament with some signs that was
literally what I had envisioned
um so the commission understands that uh
you participated in a press conference
on February 3rd 2022 Mr Wilson also
attended do you know which conference
I'm referring to I do okay
um
and I'm going to ask you some questions
about uh that conference in a second but
first I just want to understand when you
first met Mr Wilson
uh they flew in on the evening of the
2nd of February I believe and uh it was
it was quite late at night when they
arrived
um
they came to I think I was still at the
ark hotel at that point
and they came up and
introduced themselves there was five
five lawyers I believe that showed up
and that's when I first first met them
um and how did it come about that the
Convoy was looking for a lawyer
well I know that there was a doctor that
was
um in Ottawa with us that that was quite
concerned I believe about what he he was
seeing from these organizations that
were coming in
and if I remember correctly he's the one
that set up a call with the jccf I'm
sorry who was that doctor uh Dr Francis
Christian okay
and was it your understanding at the
time that it was the jccf that had
arranged for Mr Wilson and others to
come and assist the Convoy yes yes and
what was your understanding of what the
jccf was
I had heard of them before
um never imagined I'd ever need to use
them
um about the Justice Center for
constitutional Freedom so I I at that
point I just understood them to be a
charitable organization that assisted
with legal cases helping to fund
defendants in legal cases such as this
had you met Mr Wilson prior to February
2nd no so can you please explain to the
commission how it came to pass that you
met Mr Wilson for the first time on
February 2nd and then on February 3rd
we're at a news conference with him
yes I can
um again
there was a lot of pressure
that was happening at this time
um it was it was Mr marazzo and I I
think within the first day or so I think
he saw me running around and people
pulling me in all sorts of directions
and he took me into a room and we sat
down and in his very calm voice he told
me
you know you need to take a day off you
need to just take a day and and not do
anything and just relax
so I decided I think so I thought okay
well maybe Thursday I'll just try and
sneak away and have a nap or you know
um just get
relax for a little bit and um so I
agreed to it I was like okay I'll try
and then we had a meeting
I think it was Tuesday evening
it was actually probably Tuesday that
day that we had that talk we had a we
had a meeting Tuesday evening which
would be the night before they arrived
and one of the gentlemen from
taking back our freedoms told me I was
to be at the Marriott hotel for a press
conference the next day at one o'clock
was that on the first going to the
second or the second going I believe
that was the first going into the second
sorry
um and I said no I can't I can't I I'm
gonna get some rest and and they were
quite alarmed that I was that I was
turning them down
I have no media experience
I
I felt
and I'm not saying that this is what
they were doing but I felt at that point
like I was literally being thrown to the
wolves
they were going to take me to the
Marriott give me 10 minutes of media
training and then put me in front of the
mainstream media like I grew up in
Saskatchewan this is not my world you
know and so I was of of course I had a
lot of anxiety and it was a big
responsibility for us here you know we
and to to
I I was really concerned about
being put in that situation
terribly unprepared
so that was the first yeah sorry I'm not
having to answer your question no no no
sorry I didn't mean to cut you off if
you yeah I forgot we I still hadn't
answered it so uh Mr Wilson and the team
came in on Tuesday night uh we met with
them
um he explained to me his reasons for
being there which was
bit of concern for his children also
and I immediately liked him
and and his team
I told them about this press conference
probably begged him to help me because
he's had experience with this
um
as someone who is a very trusting person
I was rapidly becoming aware that I
needed to
be careful who I trusted if that makes
sense
and so I trusted Keith and his team
immediately
and he agreed to help me and it was it
was crazy it was a crazy day we we uh I
can't remember
if he drafted a draft of the statement I
made or perhaps the the the media
committee had our Communications
committee had something to do with that
um anyways he agreed to help me and and
uh
they were like Knights and Shining Armor
in my opinion
so I'm so
um
you said in that answer that you maybe
maybe we'll back up so February 1st
um I took her from your answers fair to
say you were already feeling overwhelmed
by everything that was going on yes
definitely before I left Medicine Hat I
was feeling overwhelmed
um and now you were being asked to do a
press conference
um which you were not feeling prepared
to undertake is that fair that's fair
and you said in your answer that you
also were getting the sense you needed
to be careful who you trusted
yes
[Music]
um
because as these groups would come in I
did trust them I I tried like if you
wanted to help we need your help you are
welcome here
um and in that instance
um
if I may back up just a bit so as we
were organizing before we even left
um obviously the finance committee was
one thing I recognized needed to be
created instantaneously right away uh
our Facebook page was being inundated
with messages that I was unable to keep
up with so I created I found volunteers
and created a social media committee to
have that or to look after that
um I I then realized that we needed I
guess a media team or or uh like a I
guess a media team would be the best
thing so there was a little committee
made with that which you heard Mr Victor
allude to today that he was a part of
um
and I forget where I was going could you
ask me your question again please
my question was really you said you in
in the February 1st to second period you
begin sensing you need to be careful who
you trust oh yeah I want to understand
what had caused you to have that feeling
yes
um I just can't remember what my point
was with the committee has been anyways
um
yeah I felt
at that point like everyone kind of
not everyone I felt that some people
didn't see me
they just saw 10 million dollars over my
head
and of course as they would come in and
these organizations would come in and
there were many many wonderful
organizations and obviously we were very
grateful for their help but again in
that case I was feeling as the days went
on
um I was getting more and more
uncomfortable with
them coming in and and
um taking over the meetings that we're
like our briefing meetings
I got
I actually left the ark Hotel because
all of a sudden
they were in the room next to me on the
seventh floor
which I thought was really odd and one
of the road captains made mention to me
that
we had a coffee in my room one morning I
rode the road captains and myself and
they mentioned that when they left
people like they were opening and
closing their door to see who was
leaving my room I don't mean to
interrupt you but can you explain who
the day is in this situation
I'm not sure who the room was who it
belonged to but uh Mr Beyer and Mr
peloso
um and their team were in that room and
this they were with the taking back our
freedoms group yes was there any other
groups causing you this sort of concern
not that I can recall
and so what was different about Mr
Wilson and the people he was with
what you mean why did I trust those
that's another way of putting it yet um
um I felt that they were genuine
um as I said when Mr Wilson was
explaining to me his reasons uh he was a
lawyer obviously he was sent there to
help us but he he was also had concerns
and uh he was concerned for the future
of his children too and and I
I guess I just had I had to trust them
and he gave me no reason not to
and then at the next day you did appear
at the news conference with Mr Wilson is
that correct that's correct sir all
right and at that press conference Mr
Wilson described you as the spark that
Lit the fire do you recall that
I do do you agree with Mr Wilson were
you the spark that Lit the fire
as I said I never saw myself in that
light and I still don't I feel like I
was part of just an amazing team
appreciate I would not describe myself
as the spark that led the fire
appreciating everything you've said
about Mr Wilson and I've heard you did
it concern you that Mr Wilson opened the
press conference by placing you in the
spotlight like that
I I didn't really think about it to be
honest
um
now I want to ask you some questions
about sort of your day-to-day life in
Ottawa when you were
participating in the Convoy and we've
heard the evidence and I've already
heard you say we understand that it was
a busy time there was a lot going on but
can you give the commission a sense of
what you were doing on a day-to-day
basis
uh well when I first arrived there I was
in and out of a lot of meetings it is
honestly a blur we had kind of a joke
there that one day felt like a week
there was so much going on but we would
have uh briefing meetings in the morning
to to lay out the to lay out you know
kind of what we anticipated for the day
um as I said when we first when we first
saw this taking off our number one
priority became safety safety for the
drivers safety for the participants
safety for the public so we had a lot of
briefings on on making sure that was you
know talking about things like keeping
the emergency lanes open
um I remember if well if I remember
correctly I believe the first weekend we
got there we had some problems with I
heard antifa that were spray painting
vehicles and breaking windows and
putting nails under uh tires and so
um they created block captains that
could monitor throughout the evening
to ensure that people were going to be
safe from I guess anti-protesters or
whatever they are
so you attended the meetings what else
did you do
lots of meetings in the beginning I was
uh at the Swiss Hotel it was so many
meetings at the beginning honestly I
tried to get out to see to talk to
people
um
the first Sunday we were there there was
a church service that we attended and I
spoke at with the clan mothers and Mr
dikter
and the Inc this the commission's heard
evidence uh for you know for instance Mr
marazzo described himself as responsible
for Logistics uh Mr Barber who uh sounds
like he spent a lot of time interacting
with truck drivers and and speaking with
them
um Mr Victor today talked about how he
was responsible for uh public relations
and messaging
um we anticipate that Mr bullford's
going to testify tomorrow and that he
was responsible for uh security and
other things
um
with all of that covered did you have a
specific responsibility
mother hen
no I guess when I first got there there
was lots of obviously meetings to do
with the finances and stuff like that
and as I said they were
um we ended up setting up a give send go
so there was conference calls and stuff
like that the details
I couldn't tell you but
um I got out to speak to the crowd and
wanted to go see the people and I went
to
um 88 or the
emblem I believe it was called
um saw and went to the truckers that
were down on Parkway so I spent some of
my time just walking around in in the
crowd and talking to people
and and fair to say that once the money
was frozen in terms of managing the
finances that was something that was
mostly off the table yes yes
um I'm going to ask you about some of
the people we've already discussed about
and some of the people we've heard in
the evidence
um
uh you've already talked about uh Mr
Eros who we understand was the
accountant for uh the non-for-profit
Corporation is that correct that's
correct how would you describe your
relationship with Mr E Ross when he was
in Ottawa he was a godsend
um I will be forever grateful
um that man
dropped everything
to come to Ottawa to help us with the
accounting portion and GoFundMe and work
with the legal team and
um
I thought he was great he uh I have very
basic accounting skills and so to have
him come in was a huge load off my
shoulders he could understand what they
were talking about he knew the big words
right
um and I was extremely grateful we had a
great relationship while he was here
yeah I'm in another name the
commission's heard about is Joseph burgo
yes did you know Mr bugle prior to the
Convoy I did not know did you know of
him prior to the Convoy I did not when
did you first meet Mr burgo
uh I believe we had stopped in I want to
say
we had a stop along the way maybe Sault
Ste Marie I can't remember anyways
um we had a little pit stop and
um I believe it was Mr Barber who
introduced me to him
and when Mr Barbara introduced you to
him was it your understanding that Mr
Barbara Mr burgo knew each other
I I'm not sure if they knew each other
or if you knew of him I don't I can't
say fair enough what did you come to
learn about Mr burgo after meeting him
he is a very good man
he
he was there also to exercise his
Democratic rights and express his
concern for what he believed was
um was happening in our country also
just a patriotic
good Christian man did you learn
anything about his background
I knew he had a business in Saskatchewan
of a successful
farm implement business in Saskatchewan
um
what what contribution did Mr bugo make
to the freedom Convoy
well um as I I believe he paid for a lot
of hotel rooms
um he covered I believe at least read
the rental of one of the conference
rooms or maybe a couple of conference
rooms there
um obviously when we
um when the lawyers flew in my husband
was on that flight and I was quite
concerned because I didn't want that
nothing I mean when when I started
GoFundMe my savings account was a dollar
13 overdrawn so I made sure I put the
dollar 13 into it right so that I never
wanted any questions asked and so
um Mr bego actually took my husband and
I into his room one day and offered to
pay for what would have been I guess
Dwayne's portion of that flight
did he do that
uh in the end Noah because I believe
after I was released from prison I was
told that adopt a trucker covered that
flight
um in his interview with the commission
Mr Eros said that at some point a Ryan
Olsen asked you for a hundred thousand
dollars to Mis reimburse Mr Buco for the
hotel rooms he had paid for do you
recall that occurring I don't recall
that occurring no
um the next person I want to ask you
about is Mr bowder who testified before
you yes did you know about Mr bowder
prior to the freedom Convoy 2022 I knew
of him um I uh I think maybe he was live
streaming during the United reroll
Convoy 2 or maybe that he was
participating or involved somehow
um so I knew of him I did not know him
what did you know about him
really nothing other than he was he was
a participant in that Convoy right at
that point I think he maybe had a
podcast or
or not a podcast but a live stream
Facebook show
did you ever watch that
um briefly I might have watched a few
Clips as I was scrolling through
Facebook but I didn't follow him
do you have any memory of what he was uh
streaming about when you did watch
I I'm not really no
um
when did you learn that Mr bowder was
involved in the Convoy
uh like I said when I spoke with Chris I
can't be sure if it was the 13th or the
14th but their their names have both
come up I wasn't in I talked to Mr
Barber on the 13th and then I believe
they had a meeting that evening over
zoom and
so it was 13 to the 14th
um at any point in time did you become
aware of the memorandum of understanding
I did I I think it was quite a few days
after that and
I
I do recall hearing about it
I've never read it I really didn't
pay any attention to it to tell you the
truth
uh do you recall what you were told
about the memorandum of understanding
just that there was a memorandum of
understanding
any indication about what was in it
no
Mr Wilson has testified and in his
interview summary stated that members of
the board had come to him at some point
in time and asked him about the
memorandum and whether or not uh it was
for lack of a better word legitimate
were you part of that conversation
maybe I I honestly don't recall that
did you interact with Mr bowder at all
while you were in Ottawa
I ran into him
I I didn't really see him that much once
we got to Ottawa
um so I think I ran into him
maybe a handful of times and if we spoke
I believe it was just kind of agreeing
in small talk I really didn't have
anything to do with him
um and we heard testimony today also
from uh Benjamin dictor he testified
that uh you you two met sometime in 2017
to or 2018 is that accurate I thought it
was 2019 but it could have been 2018.
awesome it's possible
um and then he testified that whenever
you first met that you stayed in
somewhat regular contact after that yes
we did yeah yeah
um how would you describe uh the
relationship between you and Mr Victor
before uh the Convoy
I consider him a friend
do you still consider him a friend
I'm not allowed to speak to him anymore
um
was Mr Victor testified that you asked
him to take on a public relations role
and messaging role was that correct I
did yes and um
as part of that did you give Mr dichter
permission to post on your Twitter
account I absolutely did I asked him to
help me with my Twitter account actually
um
and why did you ask him to help with
your Twitter account
because I was getting very very busy I
was getting messages about the Convoy
and I had my hands full with
um trying to to focus on the Facebook
page and help the social media committee
as well as
preparing for for our departure to
Ottawa
so I I just asked I I felt like he was
excellent on Twitter
um and I felt that he could that he
could help me with that just just to
kind of I guess keep getting the message
out or the progress
um and uh
the next person I want to ask you about
is Mr King
um if I understand correctly you became
aware of Mr King during the United
reroll because you would see him posting
and then you stopped following him at
the end of that is that correct that's
correct yes and I apologize if I did ask
you this but had you met Mr King prior
to the freedom Convoy no when did you
first meet Mr King
I was thinking about this last night I I
must have met him while we were on our
way to Ottawa but um the first time I
remember now meeting him uh was in
Winnipeg when we were discussing
uh Benjamin's concerns with the video
that he'd he'd seen that morning about
bullets flying
um I'm sure I met him along the way
before then but I I honestly don't
recall but that was definitely uh I
remember that Congress or being on the
side of the road okay and we and again I
think we'll get to that in a minute
um what would you understand Mr King's
rule to be in the Convoy prior to that
conversation
I believe he was helping with some
Logistics he was uh I I think because of
his previous experience with United
reroll he had a pretty good ideas to the
roots that they would be taking
um
so fueled helping
um to try and find fuel that type of
thing
if we could pull up com
in five zeros nine zero two
while this is coming up Miss Leach this
is a news article that's reporting on
text messages between you and Mr Barber
um it was referenced during Mr Barber's
testimony yes
um and well before we get to my
questions
um we have been advised by your Council
that you no longer have access to your
text messages is that correct that's
correct yes what happened to them
well that well I was in jail for 19 days
and of course my phone was inundated
with messages and apparently I found out
after the fact there's a setting that
you can have on your iPhone where you
can have them delete automatically
delete after 30 days
and it was set to that
so we go to page three of this article
um
so uh
do you see where it says on January 22nd
you see there I do sir okay so it says
uh on January 22nd leech told Barbara
that they needed to have they need they
need to have a very Frank discussion
with King raising concerns about past
allegations against him do you see that
I do
do you recall what the concerns were at
this point in time
well up until then I've obviously
followed Pat through the United Royal
Convoy and um but I knew him by
reputation also and
um Pat has a Mr King sorry has a lot of
people that like him and a lot of people
that don't like he's a very
controversial figure so I was getting
messages and phone calls from a lot of
people that were concerned that he was
involved
um this Frank discussion I believe
um came about because somebody had
contacted me and mentioned that Mr King
had
um lied about being a veteran
and
which is a very serious allegation and I
just felt like we needed to have a
discussion with him and you know
a Frank discussion and I guess find out
the details
and what was your concern at that point
well there was people that were not
joining the Convoy because they were
concerned about him and again because of
his reputation
um
I know he's set a lot of inflammatory
things which I was concerned about
um
and I'd and I was concerned that that
would have an impact on on what we were
trying to achieve it would take away the
focus from what it was we were trying to
achieve
so at this point in time January 22nd
you were aware of Mr King's reputation
for yes saying inflammatory things yes
controversial things yes sir uh things
that people may find racist
yes
um okay
um
had you ever been offended by anything
that Mr King had said
I'm not the type that gets easily
offended sir
but you recognize that some people would
take offense and that could have an
effect on the image of the Convoy yes
foreign
and I thought I heard you say and you
can correct me if I'm wrong that you
were actually receiving messages from
people who uh were expressing a
reluctance to participate because of Mr
King's involvement is that did I hear
that correctly that's correct do you
have a sense of how many messages you
received along those lines oh geez uh
I had a conversation with my mp about
his involvement I remember that he was
concerned about it
um
[Music]
um
Cindy Parker who had concerns about
about him also that she'd raised right
away
and um
yeah
I don't know how many messages are
there was concerns but there was also
people that were there because Pat was
involved too like I said he did have his
his followers also right right and if
and if we continue to look at the story
it goes on to say that despite the
concerns we've just talked about you
said that he was needed by the movement
um and then it makes a commentary about
later comments and then it quotes you uh
later statements sorry and then quotes
you just saying we need him and I don't
care about his past but it only takes
one we have to control his rhetoric not
even threatening to throw snowballs at
Parliament when you said we need him was
that what you were referring to that he
had a lot of followers was there
something else uh that was in reference
to conversations that we'd had with the
road captains and
um some of them you know he he had been
involved from the start and had you know
made I think he looked after the
accommodations or something in Sault Ste
Marie because he's from that area so
um
yeah so that wasn't necessarily me
saying I felt like he was needed that I
was I was kind of referencing the
conversations in general that we were
having that and some of them felt that
they were concerned
um that that if he left the people that
supported him would leave
um
my my
reference to I don't care about his past
is that I'm
I
had to believe
that everybody that was involved was
getting involved for the right reasons
and
um
as I said when I spoke with Mr Barber
that and I found out that they were
involved I was aware of his reputation
and um
I just felt
that I didn't want to start this off
um
criticizing other people again because I
just felt like
I had to believe that people that were
joining this movement were joining it
with the best of intentions regardless
of of their past at this point in time
did you think Mr King was participating
for the right reasons
I believe he is a passionate Canadian
so is that a yes yes
um
it says here that uh we uh we have to
control his rhetoric at that point in
time did you think you had you stood a
shot at uh controlling Mr King's
rhetoric
uh he's kind of a beast and he very much
speaks his mind
um
I again was just concerned with you know
to be frank
he was a bit of a hot head in my opinion
and I was just concerned that he would
say things or
um
say controversial things or inflammatory
things and so that's why I added in the
like we can't even be threatening to
throw snowballs at Parliament because
that's not what we're here for right
so
if we can pull up uh well actually
before I do that so we understand that
at a certain point you had a
conversation with Mr King and that you
asked him to not come to Ottawa that's
correct and so our understanding that
happened around January 28th does that
sound correct it was in Sudbury
and describe that conversation to the
commission
uh well we pulled into Sudbury I believe
it was by accident I think we took a
wrong turn so we ended up in in this
yard somewhere and we stopped and had a
break and
my recollection was uh Mr Mr King came
over to the truck and he said to me uh I
can't go into Ottawa I'm getting death
threats and I said good Pat you
shouldn't come into Ottawa
and and he's made a comment or said
something while I organized this whole
thing and I said no you didn't we all
did this was basically I'm paraphrasing
this was a team effort
um we all had a part in this and again
he said something about not going to or
he organized the whole thing and I said
um no you didn't
this movement is not about you this
movement is not about me uh you need to
check your ego
and if you care about this movement you
will not go to Ottawa
and in his testimony yesterday Mr King
denied that uh
you had said you need to check you're
ready to go and not come to Ottawa did
you hear that I did hear that what was
your reaction to that
I
maybe he just doesn't recall it
so ultimately as we know Mr King didn't
take your direction he did come to
Ottawa is that correct yes okay and uh
how did you feel when you learned that
he was still coming
I had other things to focus on and so uh
when once we got it once we got to
Ottawa I think I saw him
four or five times maybe
um I believe I'd been there for at least
a week again a lot of stuff happened in
three weeks um and the first time I ran
into him was down at Parkway one night
and I was just leaving and so I didn't
have a lot of interactions with him when
we were there
to your knowledge prior to February 14th
and we'll get to that later but prior to
February 14 said Pat King do or say
anything that caused you concerned while
he was in Audible
I heard a lot of rumors but I
heard a lot of rumors so
[Music]
again I had other things to worry about
uh I let I let the truckers or the road
captains kind of handle that that's that
aspect
if we could pull up uh hrf
four zeros one three four six and then
go to page 51 I believe
and again just to give you some context
while we wait I expect the document
we'll see is a code of conduct for
truckers
um and I'll have some questions for you
about that sure yep
maybe I'll take a short break at this
point just five minutes uh to stretch
our legs and we'll come back in five
minutes
[Music]
the commission lives in recess for five
minutes
right away
order a lot
order a lot
the commission has been convenient
thank you for that Indulgence now we can
run through to the end I hope and
adjourn before it uh
well it'll be late but go ahead
it's already dark
um so if we could pull up
hrf428 sorry
hrf1346 page 51.
and if we could zoom in a bit so miss
Leach this is a document titled Freedom
Convoy 2022 code of conduct are you
familiar with this document yes I am sir
can you describe what it is
it is a code of conduct we recognized
once the once the support started coming
and we began growing that we should have
something in place for people to sign
saying that they would hear would adhere
to uh
uh code of conduct right
right
um
and uh
do you recall if this was distributed
it was put on uh about the back side of
the registration forms I believe
uh and those were the registration forms
to get reimbursement yes was it
distributed in any other manner
um I think we they could get them by
email or get hard copies I think we had
them up on on a website
was there anything done to proactively
distribute them to for instance of the
people who were on the ground in Ottawa
uh we had printed off a lot of copies we
had we had big hopes when this started
and that
um and so we'd printed off a bunch of
copies to have the road captains take to
the drivers to sign uh thinking that
this would be a fairly simple task but
because of the amount of participation
that we had it was it was crazy but I
did I actually did receive a lot of them
through email so they did get out
um
I'm not asking for a precise number in
any way shape or form but do you have a
sense of how many you got back
I I'm not sure
um a lot right
um and we see here in item three it says
be respectful everyone will have their
own reasons for participating in this
Convoy and we need to be respectful of
their reasons
what were you trying to capture in that
point
well I believe in being respectful and
why well I may have been going to Ottawa
to
um
because of the mandates there are the
yeah the mandates I mean what my reasons
were for wanting the mandates to be
lifted may not have been the same as
somebody else's reasons for wanting the
Mandate lifted
to your knowledge was there anyone there
who was uh seeking to do something other
than end the mandate
no
and all the people you spoke to did
anyone ever suggest that they had any
other goal than ending the mandates
other than hearing about the mou which
as you've heard today I haven't even
read it yet
um but other than that no and what were
you hearing about the mou I know you
haven't read it but what were you
hearing about it
um
what did I hear about it um I just heard
that it was a document that was to be
presented to the governor general I
really don't recall all the details
it was just a general in passing I guess
item number four says not promote
harmful media
what did you consider to be harmful
media
well no hateful rhetoric we didn't want
any sort of divisive rhetoric
just again it goes back to point three
be respectful
um we we didn't I went I was on lives
daily saying that we are going to Ottawa
to peacefully protest and exercise our
Democratic right to assembly we are not
going there to create
problems and um
um you know I I said if you see anyone
that's not acting in a threatening
manner or an aggressive manner to get
their license plates phone the police
and report it or contact us and we could
report it
um we just didn't want any of that type
of behavior happening here because that
was never what it was about did you
believe that there might be people in
the Convoy who May promote hateful
content
it was a concern again I know when we
were on our way at one point I believe
it was when we got to Thunder Bay we
were on our way to Thunder Bay and um I
can't remember who it was but somebody
had contacted me saying they thought
that there was infiltrators antifa that
had infiltrated our Convoy from Winnipeg
that were maybe going to cause some
problems for us so there was always
that's that kind of information was
always coming to us right other than
potential actions by antifa were you
concerned about other people potentially
making or promoting hateful content
not really everyone that I talked to and
saw and
we're all there for the same for the
same reason
at any point in time to your knowledge
that any of the organizers have to do
anything to have to take any action
because there was reports of either
uh threat threats harassment violence or
hateful conduct or anything that you
would have thought was inappropriate
um well of course there was the
conversation uh that Benjamin when he
called me that one morning when we were
on our way I think it was our second day
and there had been a tweet come out
about Mr King talking about bullets and
so
um that was
obviously concerning
um we stopped and we chatted with him on
the side of the road about it he
indicated that it had been heavily
edited
by some media I'm not sure
but it was It was obviously concerning
um
do you recall if that bullet comment
whether there was we've heard evidence
of two bullet comments from Mr King at
least two one was Trudeau you're going
to catch a bullet and one was this will
all end in bullets do you recall which
one of those it was the ending in
bullets one I don't remember ever
hearing about the the one about the
prime minister
um Miss Lee you can take that down now
um
Miss Leach you've you've watched much of
these proceedings so you've heard a lot
of the evidence that we've heard about
people complaining about the horns
people saying there was harassment there
was intimidation there was unsafe uh
there's unsafe settings we've had
evidence from citizens of Ottawa who
said they felt unsafe in in their own
City
do you have anything to say to that
I encountered
hundreds and hundreds of Ottawa
residents when I was here
thanking me Thanking us saying that we
gave them hope
Ottawa residents and in fact federal
government employees that were taking
donations of food to the truckers
blankets fuel
and
um
yeah we
everyone had said the same thing to me
that I mean the word that I heard the
most on the way here and when I was here
was hope
many of the protesters who have
testified this week have Sarah to shared
a similar message talked about the
positive loving atmosphere that uh that
they experienced in the protest
do you deny that there were incidents of
harassment or incidents of intimidation
or threatening like the ones we've heard
do you deny that that happened
I never witnessed it
I never witnessed any of that any of
that type of behavior again there was
always rumors
um but but I never personally witnessed
any any Behavior like that whatsoever I
also heard that the Russians were
involved I also heard that we were tried
to burn a building down
um I mean there was a ton of
misinformation out there I had um my
family from Edmonton messaging me
texting me asking if I was okay and they
were really worried about my safety and
I said worried about my safety
like this is this is the biggest Love
Fest I've ever participated in right
when you hear the citizens of Ottawa not
all of them I appreciate that but when
you hear some of the citizens of Ottawa
say I felt harassed I felt intimidated I
felt unsafe do you believe them
I believe that's how they felt again I
can't say I never witnessed any of that
um obviously the last thing that we ever
wanted to do when we came here was to to
make the citizens of Ottawa feel that
way
and
I guess you know when
as we alluded to even in our letter with
the mayor like we never intended for
that to happen and we didn't want to
cause that kind of disruption and and we
worked really hard the road captains
that worked really hard to keep the
emergency lanes open and to of course
the horn injunction came in and worked
really hard to ensure that that was
adhered to
um because we didn't we definitely would
never wanted anybody to feel that way
right and then once the horde injunction
came in
um the the that was now a court order
but prior to the court order did you
have a view on the honking
well I did have a view on a honking as
even Mr Barber said after a couple days
it was it was getting to be a bit much
for me I I you know trying to walk down
the street and have a conversation with
somebody was
um sometimes difficult
um but again I stayed in the arc hotel
for a few days and then at the Sheridan
Hotel for a few days and um
at least in my room I
maybe I was preoccupied but I didn't
hear a lot of horns but then we weren't
also we were on uh yes uh Slater and
Albert
did you see yourself as someone who had
a level of influence over the Convoy in
the protest
I felt like I was respected that my
opinion was respected by most most of
them yes
did you ever consider given what you
said that you got and started to get
annoyed at the horns I take it you
probably at some point understood that
the horns was causing frustration to a
lot of people is that fair I've heard
that yes did you ever consider taking
any steps
to use the respect you had to reduce
or eliminate the horn honking prior to
the court order
a boat
February 4th I want to say
um my Facebook page was disabled
which is how I access the Convoy page to
do videos so
I couldn't have I guess but I never
really considered it because I left that
type of stuff up to the up to the
captains
and was it again given the respect that
you felt you had and the evidence bears
that out or that we've heard a lot of
evidence on that
um do you did you can do you think that
if you would ask the captains to take
action with respect to the horns that
they would have listened to
well they were already were
so it wasn't necessary for me to so I I
would had you instructed the captains to
stop the horn I don't no I don't think I
instructed them to I believe we had
discussions about the horns though and
what was the result of those discussions
um well for sure I know Mr Barber would
go out and and try and talk to the
drivers and uh I believe Mr marazzo is
also out
um to try and get them
uh to slow or cease
become less frequent sorry
it's okay
I'm going to move to another topic now
um and I apologize I am moving around
it's okay
um uh the commissioner's aware that on
uh January 30th uh you attended a press
conference with Mr Barber and Mr dikter
um this would be the before the arrival
of Mr Wilson do you know what I'm
talking about I do yes okay
um and uh
you had mentioned earlier that you were
uncomfortable attending a press
conference on February 2nd do you recall
why you were comfortable attending this
press conference on January 30th well I
wouldn't say I was comfortable I was
still quite nervous but
um uh Mr Barber and Mr Benjamin sorry Mr
Barber and Mr Victor were friends of
mine and also we had made the conscious
decision at that point to not have the
mainstream media there so I felt like
the Independent Media
were not going to be aggressive with me
if that makes sense and with respect to
the taking back our Freedom's press
conference was your understanding the
mainstream media would be there they
were there yes
um if we could go uh so the video the
commission has the video it's com
50850 I'm not proposing to pull it up
because again that would that would be
the end of the day but unless there's an
objection I would like to enter it into
the record and then I'm going to ask you
about the transcript which is com895 yes
so if we could pull up
com895 and go to page 10 of the
transcript page 11 of the PDF
so if we can scroll down
so scroll down
stop right there up actually scroll up
just a little bit there we go so an
unidentified reporter asks you
um
uh notes that Maxine Bernier has sort of
had a rally here in downtown Ottawa
today are you associated with him at all
are you pleased with support he's given
the Convoy what are your thoughts on
that and you respond we're not
associated we took a vote as an
organization all the committee heads and
the organizers and we are not partisan
uh
we had re we had reached out to a couple
of others a couple of other ones reached
out to us we wanted to get up and who
wanted to get up and speak and we said
no that's not what we're about this is a
grassroot movement and no politicians
are going to represent us
I mean they're kind of the reason we're
in this mess in the first place do you
recall saying that I do right
um
why was it important to you that the
movement was nonpartisan
well because I guess right within the
first couple days of us starting uh to
organize before we left I did have
politicians reaching out to me that
wanted to get up and speak and I just
felt like we
we had our message and that's the
message that we needed to to stick to
without getting it convoluted with the
messages of other politicians
and so by this point
um to tell you the truth I shouldn't say
that I'm telling the truth but
um it was about three days into
organizing the Convoy that I knew that
my time with the Maverick party was done
and the reason I knew that it was done
was because I was sitting at my kitchen
table
um and we had chats with the different
Road captains and the different areas
um going on messenger and I was chatting
with the Quebec the Quebec team and
we were told there was a thousand
truckers ready to come and support us
and I had I guess an epiphany moment
and there's me you know chatting here
and I got Google translate on the other
one and I'm talking to the quebecers me
and albertan and I just had this moment
where I just thought this division has
all been a lie
they're the same as us and and I knew
that
I didn't want to see Canada divided at
that point and I resigned from my
position with the Maverick party uh up
two or three days after I arrived in
Ottawa
so as I understand what you just said
there that uh seeing seeing the the
pan-canadian nature of the Convoy LED
you to no longer be interested in a an
Alberta secession that's correct
do you still hold that I do as a matter
of fact I'm going to learn French
um we've already referenced that Mr Eros
had an interview with the commission and
uh and and provided us some information
um one of the things Mr Eros said uh was
that he suggested I should say in his
interview that once Mr Wilson and the
other lawyers arrived in around February
uh
third I guess uh the the he's as he
describes it the Western Sovereign
sovereigntist movement tried to take
control of the narrative
do you have at any point in time did you
get any sense that there was
um direction or influence from the
people that you would have known through
your time at the moment absolutely not
did anyone uh who you had affiliations
with or know from the Maverick or wexic
party join you in Ottawa
uh the only person that I saw that came
out from there was a gentleman that had
ran as a candidate for the Maverick
party who was a friend of mine his name
was tarek
anyone else
uh not that I can remember oh sorry my
bad Colin uh
Krueger
also showed up for a few days
when did you first become aware of the
protests and blockades and Coots Alberta
oh I I'm not even sure we had so much
going on here to deal with I remember
hearing about the borders
um but I'm not sure when it was it has
already been in the news for a few days
I think
um
did you know anyone who is participating
in the protests or blockades there
I it's sort of my home area so I do know
of two of my friends that were there for
sure
um but I and I probably actually I
believe my parents even took food there
one day
um but
other than that I I don't know uh were
your friends there were either of them
involved in organizing the protester of
the blockades not to my knowledge no
um were you communicating with your
friends who were in Coots
um I think one of them had sent me a
text message
um just to see how I was doing because
he was a friend of mine and mentioned
that he was there
um but other than that no did your
friends or anyone reach out to you uh to
request support or guidance on how to
organize a protest never
did you have any understanding about the
makeup of the protest group at Coots I
did not I I really did not have time to
follow what was happening closely I just
knew
that they were happening what did you
understand their goals to be
I think they were there I assumed they
were there for the Border mandates did
your friends tell you what they were
doing when they were participating no or
sorry why they were participating to be
more precise no
did you have any Communications with any
other protesters at any of the other
protests in Canada that were occurring
at the same time as the Ottawa protests
no sir anyone any Communications with
anyone in Surrey
No Sir Emerson no sir Windsor no sir
if we could pull up hrf one two nine
four
so if you scroll down
so this is an email
uh dated Friday February 11 2022
um
and uh while it's blocked out I believe
this is an email that was sent to you is
that correct
I had 15 000 emails maybe well let's
scroll up and put some context to it
then
so you see there on two days later uh
there's an email message from February
13th from tomorrow with a signature
sincerely tomorrow tomorrow leech so it
appears that you're forwarding this
email
uh onto someone named Danny yes yeah
do you have any reason to believe you
didn't receive the email down down below
I I don't yeah I don't have any reason
to believe I didn't there was a lot I
didn't get to and if we can scroll down
so it says good afternoon please we are
looking for help to get in touch with an
Ottawa Convoy organizer or someone who
can help us my uncle is desperately
trying to organize the Convoy in Windsor
currently there is no persons or person
or persons in charge we are in immediate
need of help and direction from off from
the Ottawa Convoy organization we are
not looking for funds so much as support
Direction and to make the connection
with your convoy and scroll down I will
continue reading and then it's signed by
a Kathleen Tom in Brackets Hogan do you
recognize the name Kathleen Tom or
Kathleen Hogan I do not do you recall if
you had any other Communications from
miss Tom
I don't uh do you recall does this
refresh your memory at all about whether
or not you received any other similar
messages from anyone in Windsor or any
of the other
uh protest locations no I like I said I
had a lot of emails that I never got to
and
but I don't recall I don't recall seeing
any
now I'm going to ask you some questions
about the agreement that was reached
with the mayor of Otto with respect to
the moving of the trucks and again the
commission has heard a lot of evidence
about that but I have a few questions
for you
um
when did you first come to know that it
was possible that there might be the
opportunity to have a discussion with
the mayor
um
uh well we had a meeting with Mr French
I believe it was February the 11th
um at that point he didn't indicate to
me who he was representing I think he
was just trying to open some
negotiations and I I think it was maybe
the next day or after that then that I
found out that it was from the mayor and
so that he was on there on behalf and so
you said that was February the 11th I
think it was a Friday February the 11th
um and as we understand it the letters
that you and the mayor exchanged were on
February the 12th does that okay
recollection it does so that happened
pretty quickly didn't it it did yes can
you explain to me
how you originally how that developed
over such a short period of time
well as I said we had a meeting with Mr
French and some of the road captains and
other volunteers and it just it happened
really quickly because we wanted
uh
I viewed it as a first step a step to
start you know getting the trucks out of
the downtown core so that we could get
those those areas opened up for the
citizens and um what have they've been
saying here uh
shrinking the footprint or whatever
and and it did happen really fast and
and you know you have to understand that
we had been there now for I think that
was going into our third week
we were tired we wanted to go home so we
were looking for ways where we could
start forming an exit strategy
and while
um our concern was obviously never with
the city of Ottawa we felt it was a step
one and number two finally someone is
willing to sit down and just listen to
us and have a dialogue with us
so you were open to the notion of
shrinking the protest footprint with an
eventual view to to an exit yes did you
have a timeline in your mind about how
much longer you were willing to stay
not really
it was everything was very fluid and um
day by day
I guess my Hope was that if we could
open Communications with the mayor and
he could see that we weren't
you know the types of people that we
were being described as in the media
that perhaps that would open the door
for talks with someone with MPS or
someone in the federal government who
would take the time to sit down and
listen to us
you heard Mr Victor testify earlier
today I believe is that correct I heard
parts of it parts of it okay well Mr Mr
Victor is evidence in in some summary
was that he he did not want to shrink
the footprint and in fact he thought
shrinking the the move up to Wellington
was a bad idea and it was an attempt by
some people to make it easier for the
police to clear the protests
was that a view that Mr Victor shared
with you at any point in time
I don't recall if he ever did I I don't
recall having that conversation but
again
um
there was lots going on
do you recall if anyone within the board
of directors or anyone who you were
talking to on a regular basis whether
there was any dissenting voices anyone
who thought this was not the right move
well we talked with the road captains
before that letter went out and and had
agreement we discussed the draft of the
letter I believe and Mr Wilson and Mr
chippyick drafted it and emailed it to
everyone so that they would have a
chance to read it also and waited for
the approvals to come back in I don't
recall if any of them strongly opposed
it
to tell you like I'm not sure
I don't believe so
um Mr Victor also testified today that
after
the news of the agreement came out he
received thousands of men I think maybe
two thousand messages of people who had
concern and seemed disappointed or upset
was that something he expressed to you
not that I recall do you recall
receiving any negative feedback from
anyone after the deal was became public
on the 13th
um I think there was some people that
felt a little bit confused I mean I
remember I remember hearing that some
people didn't didn't feel or felt a
little bit confused about what was
happening
um I remember hearing something to the
effect of Tamara's negotiating with the
with the mayor behind our backs which
was not true
but again it was just all rumor like you
know
so do you recall someone specifically
saying to you that Tamara's negotiating
behind her back no I don't recall any
specific people telling I just remember
the gist of
some of the things that I was hearing
right and and other than the road
captains and the board were the fact of
the negotiations was that something that
was discussed with the protesters more
generally before the deal was entered
into
we printed off uh some information after
we after we discussed it as a group and
went out to speak to the truckers about
it to to explain to them why we felt
this was a really good idea I'm not sure
what the experiences were of the road
captains I know I went out to 88 I
believe it was and had a great
conversation with the gentleman that was
that was kind of overseeing out there
and he was in full agreement I talked to
some of the other truckers that were out
there and they were they were in full
agreement also they all thought it was a
good idea
um and we heard today uh Mr dichter talk
about the tweets that he made both from
his personal account and from your
account after the deal uh was announced
publicly in the media when did you first
learn that Mr dictator had tweeted and
then retweeted from your account that
there had been no agreement
uh must have been that same evening
um I believe I was at the Swiss Hotel
when that came out
um
and
I think it was definitely after the fact
that I'd heard about it and
it must have been that same evening I'm
assuming
what was your reaction
I was shocked but um I knew that Mr
Wilson
they they had seen it right away I think
he saw it come up on his Twitter right
away and um
I trusted them to look after it
corrected I should say did you ever
discuss the tweets with Mr Victor
I don't believe so
because so many things happened after
that
um
Monday was the invocation of the
emergencies act which we found out when
we were actually ironically on our way
to meet with Mr Brian peckford
um and I I don't recall having the
conversation with him about that but I
could have it was because it was kind of
a big deal
well the nature of the question was kind
of the big deal do you
um
um
do you I take it then but you don't
recall any specific conversations with
them I don't sir
um
Mr champ suggested I think at some point
yesterday that
um in addition to the tweets that you
went on a uh a Facebook live stream at
some point that said you didn't support
the deal that had been struck with the
mayor do you have any recollection about
that about that is does that ring any
bells and that doesn't ring any bells to
me
um and
um were you here yesterday when Mr King
testified I was yes and so you would
have seen uh that the commission showed
a video that Mr King released after the
deal had been announced uh and when she
said there was no deal uh he called and
said it's a lie it's a false flag and
told everyone uh to hold the line
um
did you see the video at that time I did
not when was the first time you saw that
video
in totality was yesterday I believe I
heard about it well I know I heard about
it um but I believe that yesterday was
the first time I watched it the whole
thing I might have seen bits of it
before what was your reaction to seeing
it yesterday
well Mr King wasn't
um in our meetings so
um
I
I
I don't really have a reaction I mean he
wasn't attending our meetings I don't
know if I'd like I said my interactions
with him were quite limited so
I don't know if he'd spoken to one of
the other Road captains or if anybody
had told him what was going on so I take
it he didn't reach out to you but no and
would you have expected Mr King before
coming out and saying that a deal you
had entered into was a lie would you
have expected him to come and check with
you first
I guess so I don't really know he kind
of does his own thing
do you still think that Mr King was at
the protest for the right reasons
I have never heard
him
speak from his lips that I could hear
racist comments I've seen the videos
that have been you know online that you
guys have shown I personally have never
beared witness to that
and I believe at his core he was here to
just like the rest of us were to
exercise his Democratic rights to a
peaceful assembly
foreign
do you have any regret that Mr King was
associated with the Convoy
I've thought a lot about the question
and
he is a part of the story
and
I I mean I can't heavily have regrets
because it is what it is
though things happen the way that they
were supposed to happen and
I guess he had a part of a part to play
I don't know
that's that's a hindsight is 20 20 right
so the as as everyone in this room knows
the emergency Zach was invoked on
February 14 2020 and 22.
um after the invocation of the ACT what
was your understanding about whether or
not people could continue to protest in
the Red Zone peacefully
well nobody had ever come up to me and
told me that we needed to leave
have you have you seen the Flyers that
uh that have been that have been shown
in the evidence uh Ops Flyers giving
notice that uh people needed to vacate
the area uh I did yes yeah I did see
those did you remember seeing Flyers
like that at the time
um I did see somebody sent me a
screenshot of one I I can't remember if
I had an actual copy of it but I had a
screenshot of one and I thought it was
odd
um
now it's been a while but I think it was
because there was spelling mistakes and
it wasn't signed by anyone I didn't know
um
I guess at this point I was kind of
questioning the validity of anything I
saw really and um it was definitely
alarming
um but again nobody ever came to us and
said you guys have to leave
right now and as far as I was concerned
we were we were peacefully protesting
we were exercising our Democratic rights
to be here and to protest
um
foreign
so if no one came and told you you had
to leave what did you think the impact
or purpose of the invocation of the
emergencies Act was
um
again this is an entirely new world for
me I didn't know I'm I remember when I
believe the city of Ottawa implemented a
state of emergency and then Mr Ford in
fact invoked a provincial state of
emergency
and I don't want to sound flippant but
what I saw from those were
small groups of police officers standing
around to larger groups of police
officers standing around
so I didn't understand fully I guess
what that meant
um in terms of what was expected of us
so it was really alarming I remember
starting to get quite anxious about what
could be coming
as uh
as one of the people who was organizing
the movement is the person who you at
least identified had been held out as a
leader even if he didn't feel that way
did you take any steps to figure out
what it meant that the emergencies act
had been invoked and what that meant for
the people who were protesting and the
people that you understood to be
supporting your convoy
uh well as I said we were on the way to
meet with Mr peckford when we heard that
Mr Trudeau was going to be invoking the
actor or announcing that he was going to
be invoking the ACT later that day
and Mr peckford thought it would be a
good idea for us to do a press
conference about it also and
um
so we did do a press conference later
that day um prior to the prime
minister's press conference
and um
we just we wanted to continue and and
peacefully protest
um of but I knew that people were
leaving which I encouraged and I believe
it was the 16th
it was the day before I was arrested
that some of the road captains and and
friends that were close to our
organization started leaving which which
of course I encouraged I mean I was
concerned
about
what could be coming we had heard that
there was quite a police presence coming
and obviously I didn't want to see
anyone be hurt so I didn't want to see
anybody get arrested
it was getting close
and you already mentioned that you got
arrested on February 17th yes I did can
you tell the commission uh what it was
like to be arrested
well it was again kind of ironic because
I went down to the war memorial that day
to attend the service that the vets were
having there every day I spent my
afternoon walking the streets with a
veteran and my husband and Miranda one
of the road captains
um just talking to people and um
I was aware the night before I'm sure
you saw the video that it was most
likely coming
um
or that there was a chance that I could
be arrested
and we went back to the hotel and within
15 minutes everybody's phones started
blowing up and that Mr Barber had been
arrested
um
Mr Beaufort and I were at the Swiss
hotel with um Mr skubick and Mr Tyson
and we discussed
what we should do what our next step
should be
and
we were concerned that if they were
starting to arrest the organizers that
they would come to the hotel
and my husband was there
and Mr beaufort's wife was there
and obviously that was the last thing
that I would ever want my husband to see
was to me be arrested
um
we definitely didn't want that sort of
activity occurring at the hotel with a
woman who had been so kind to us
actually who was about to lose her
business until we showed up
but like I said in my video I wasn't
afraid I
believe and still believe that
we did an excellent job
remaining peaceful
advocating for the police
advocating for respecting the police
and um
so we made the conscious decision to go
out
and ask the police if they were looking
for us
we walked um up to the hill
and I believe it was Metcalf
and we stopped and talked to some
officers I'm not sure what their rank
was there was two uh Suburbans pointed
with their headlights up at the hill
and we walked up to them and Mr bullford
identified
woman if we heard that they were looking
for organizers
um we are the Oregon we're part of the
volunteers and he indicated to us that
that he didn't have information on that
um Danny asked him maybe a second time
or he asked him another question and he
he um
rolled his window up communicated with
somebody rolled his window down and said
no
and I remember saying well if that
changes we're just going to be up at the
hill here
and we went up to the hill and I think
we were there for an hour and a half to
two hours
and we decided to go back to to our room
um we'd presented ourselves to the
police
they indicated that we were not
um they were not looking for us
we walked down to the arc hotel and
warmed up it was it was cold that night
um
and I believe Sean was staying there and
needed to get something so we warmed up
in there for about 10 minutes
and then started heading back to the
Swiss Hotel
as we crossed the street there had been
there was construction on my left side
of the street on in front of the
buildings I remember so it wasn't very
well lit
and as we were walking I met another
couple coming towards us and the lady
hugged me and thanked me and Danny and
she was crying and we were standing
there talking to this couple and
all of a sudden three Suburbans just
went police Suburbans I think that's
what they are went flying down the
street past us
and then a fourth one came and pulled
over and so at that point I was pretty
sure that I was about to be arrested
how has the arrest affected your life
I've lost my job
I've lost my freedom of speech
I've lost my freedom to communicate with
my friends
which was quite traumatizing because
we just experienced something huge
and we didn't get any time to even sit
down as a group
and and just talk about it and talk
about our experience we didn't have that
opportunity that was taken away from me
I have to be very careful about every
move that I make
as you know I was arrested on an alleged
breach charge for attending
a dinner in Toronto
I had the police show up at
the place that I'm staying last weekend
because somebody saw me outside smoking
a cigarette
I have a daughter that
I don't want her to be seen with me
because I'm worried
I'm so sorry
take your time
I have yet to see the particulars
of the Mischief that I am alleged to
have committed
foreign
I just
it's definitely affected my life it's
it's something that I've never been
arrested before I
the process the legal process I find
extremely frustrating my trials not till
next year I have to live under these
conditions for a year
but I will
I'll make it work
I'll manage and
I did everything I felt that I could do
in my power of through the lives that I
was doing
and I believe it worked
as I was advocating again for peaceful
protest respect the police please
respect other people that was a big part
of the reason I did that live the last
night
I
saw a lot of those flags
and while I support anyone's freedom of
speech it's not something that resonated
with me
I saw
unheard of people that were upset with
some mainstream media
and um
I just wanted to
I did my video because regardless of how
angry we are with
the luck or the leadership
that we've seen
the divisive rhetoric
the the the division between the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated that
I've seen come from elected officials
civil servants
towards their own people
and I saw those flags one day and I kept
thinking I gotta get to the stage and
make a speech like I I felt
I felt that I needed to get there and I
needed to just say you know
Mr Trudeau has three children
and I have three children
and my kids have to wake up and see this
stuff on social media too
actually when I was arrested my 19 year
old daughter woke up to read an article
that I hung myself in jail
she's 19.
thank you Miss Leach those are my
questions thank you
okay
um well we're
at the stage of
adjourning for the day and uh
I think it's welcome for everybody so
we'll come back tomorrow at 9 30. sure I
have a you have a question yes just a
request
um as you know uh the witness is now
technically under cross-examination
hasn't started but uh we would like
permission to be able to communicate
with the witness we actually are all
living in the same building in fact
she's staying pardon me yes sorry we'd
like permission sir leave to be able to
communicate with the witness though
she's still under oath uh we actually
all kind of live in the same apartment
buildings and sharing apartments with
the witness and things like that so
subject your direction
whatever works I understand that that
was a given to Chief slowly's Council we
would like the same prerogative sir if
that was possible
uh I think I don't think there actually
was a
any uh permission given uh what was
pointed out is the rule does not prevent
you from speaking to the witness as long
as you don't speak about any of the
evidence
so and and that's my understanding of
the rule so you don't need my permission
unless you want to speak to her about
her evidence in which case that's a
different matter
uh no sir but as we would have uh the
evening we would anticipate we have
already but we would anticipate the
possibility of continuing to prepare her
for cross but if that's not permitted
sir we won't do so I don't think that's
contemplated by the rule
um I'm sorry you anyone want to pipe in
on this I'm sorry
commissioner if it's of assistance uh
and
I'm not certain exactly who who helped
facilitate the the way in which we
approach the matter with the with Chief
slowly but I believe the application the
rule is that
um
the witnesses evidence given to date is
not the subject of discussion but that
would I think my friend uh would be able
to speak about the questions that he
intends to ask without going back over
what the witness has given yeah I
believe that's how we we uh we reached
agreement with our friends from the
Ottawa Police Service who had raised the
issue and uh with some of your
commissions yeah I think if lawyers have
to be aware of the rule it's basically
the same rule as applies to in courts
and you can't
speak about
the cross-examination on the evidence
you can prepare
but that's a different matter and the
line obviously we rely on lawyers to
respect that obviously I'm sure it's the
same in Alberta
kind of yes sir it is
we're all one country
okay so till 9 30 tomorrow morning
the commission is